THE FACT THAT YOU'RE TALKING TO
GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER THAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THESE HEARINGS BUT WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO SLOWLY. FIND A
SEAT FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
FRONT I DON'T BUY ON THURSDAY.
CAN'T MAKE ANY GUARANTEES ON
THE OTHER DAYS OF THE WEEK. BUT
IF YOU'D MAKE SURE YOU EXCHANGE
BUSINESS CARDS SO YOU CAN
CONTINUE THESE RELATIONSHIPS.
GLAD TO SEE EVERYONE WE'VE GOT
OUR SPEAKERS WHO ARE COMING
FORWARD. HELLO THANK YOU. WHEN
.
SIX THEY'RE READY. SO GOOD
MORNING. MORNING. BECAUSE I WAS
BORN AND RAISED HERE AT HOME
AND- I SEE- PASTOR HILL IN THE
BACK BUT I CAN DO A CLASS I.
OFFICIAL WELCOME TO THE CHURCH
OF THE BELLS WELCOME TO MY HOME
CHURCH HOME UNITED METHODIST I
AM PROUD TO BE UNITED METHODIST
ALTHOUGH ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW
WHAT ELSE TO BE FRANKLY. BUT I.
YOU KNOW I WAS RAISED IN THIS
CHURCH IN THE- UNITED METHODIST
FAITH IS THE FAITH OF. SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND SO I'M SURE THOSE
EARLY- SERMONS I REMEMBER FROM.
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON-
CERTAINLY POURED INTO ME AND
I'M SURE HAD A DIRECT INFLUENCE
ON WHO I AM TODAY PASTOR HEALED
YOU WANT TO COME IN BRING
GREETINGS ON BEHALF OF. HOME
OFFICIALLY. I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. THANK YOU. YEAH GO
OVER THERE SO WE COULD MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET YOU ON THE
LIVE STREAM. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY. IT INDEED IS THE
ONLINE A PRIVILEGE- FOR US TO
SAY WELCOME TO HOME UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH HERE IN LOS
ANGELES INDEED WE ARE FILLED
WITH JOY AND EXCITEMENT THAT
YOU HEAR PARTICULARLY- IS- WE
GATHER TO SUPPORT AND TO HEAR
FROM SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL
WHO- IS SO WONDERFUL SERVANT OF
GOD A WONDERFUL MEMBER OF THIS
CONGREGATION WHO HAS- LIVES OF
FAITH AMONG US AND WHO IS
CHALLENGED US TO. OPEN OUR
HEARTS AND OUR MINDS THAT WE
MAY DO SOMETHING INCLUSIVE AND
CARING AND LOVING AND-
RECONCILING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WE INDEED WANT YOU TO KNOW
YOU'RE AT HOME AMONG US AND- WE
CERTAINLY AWAIT HEARING THE
WORD TO MASSES THE TH PANEL
WILL OFFER TO EDUCATE AND TO
INSPIRE AND THEN TO EMPOWER US
TO ACT- IN DIFFERENT WAYS SO
THAT THE FUTURE MAY BE BRIGHTER
FOR- ALL ALL CHILDREN ALL
PEOPLE- IN NOT JUST A STATE
BUT- AROUND THE GLOBE. SO IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
HELP YOU- FEEL AT HOME WITH
THAT WANT TO DO THAT- MAN YOU
ALREADY FOUND THE RESTROOM
FACILITIES SETH OFF TO- LEFT-
OFF THE MAIN HALL IF WITHIN THE
ELSE THAT WE CAN OFFER TO MAKE
YOUR TIME AND YOUR PRESENCE ON
I. CAMPUS- A MORE ENJOYABLE AND
WE WANT TO DO THAT. PLEASE LET
US KNOW GOD'S BLESSINGS ON YOU.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYONE. WE
WILL GO LATER OKAY. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH PAST
ELABORATION EIGHT YOU FOR
WELCOMING US SO MUCH- AGAIN I'M
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL I WANT
TO WELCOME YOU TO MY HOOD THE
THIRTIETH SENATE DISTRICT
WELCOME BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING AND
IF YOU NEED TRANSLATION I'M
VERY PROUD OF THIS WE HAVE
SPANISH AND KOREAN TRANSLATORS
HERE TO HELP US THEY WILL COME
UP UNTIL YOU ALL WHERE YOU NEED
TO BE IF YOU NEED TRANSLATION
FIRST WE'VE GOT RAIN ACROSS THE
ANNALS. REINA. WE WENT TO SEE A
SUBTLE C. ALLEN THIS IS THE
SERVICES THAT THAT LOOKS
YOUNGER THAN M. MOSTLY KEEP ALL
THE ALL THE PEOPLE AND IN A
SALAD THAT THAT'S MISSING
ANYTHING MOELIS WHETHER YOU
THAT PRO RATED PEOPLE. YEMENI
THOSE. LAFAYETTE. AND NEXT WE
HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT K.
Y. C. C. AND NOW AS A TREE TO
CATCH MILITIA COMES OUT WILK
SHE HUNG BELOW TWENTY JOSH
ENGLAND TOOK A TEACHER GAUCHE
MANAGING A TONY OKAY BECAUSE I
KNOW WHICH IS A TARGET
PUNISHMENT. OKAY DIGITAL CONNIE
SMITH COMES UP AND UP. THANK
YOU ISAAC EYES IT I DIDN'T GET
MY TUTORIAL ON HOW TO SAY THANK
YOU IN KOREAN BUT THANK YOU
ISAAC. I'LL BE I'LL BE READY
NEXT TIME. OKAY YCC HAS BEEN A
REAL ACTIVE PARTNER HERE IN THE
THIRTY SENATE DISTRICTS ALLAH
THANK THEM FOR THEIR SUPPORT
TODAY. THIS HEARING IS THE
THIRD SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
CHILDREN'S WELL BEING WILL
FOCUS ON THE PAST PRESENT
FUTURE OF IMMIGRATION IN LOS
ANGELES AND CALIFORNIANS
INVESTMENT IT IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN. I'M PROUD TO BRING
THIS HEARING TO OUR HOME
DISTRICT OF LOS ANGELES AND
AGAIN THANK CALMER FOR HOSTING.
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO CHET HE
WITH THE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR C. YOUR HEALTH THIS YEAR
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND I
WERE TALKING ABOUT WAYS
CALIFORNIA COULD IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF CHILDREN ALL CHILDREN.
BY MAKING THEM HEALTHIER. BOTH
OF US HAVE WORK TO ALLEVIATE
POVERTY AND INCREASED HEALTH
ACCESS THROUGHOUT OUR CAREERS.
CHECK MY REALIZED THERE WAS
NOTHING REALLY IN THE SENATE BY
WAY OF A COMMITTEE OR SELECT
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO DELVE DEEPLY INTO THIS
SUBJECT MATTER. WE WANTED TO
FOCUS BROADLY ON THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF CHILDREN'S WELL
BEING ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE.
BASED ON THAT I WALKED AWAY
REALIZING THAT WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY PERHAPS THEY HAVE A
SELECT COMMITTEE A SELECT
COMMITTEE IS DIFFERENT IN THE
LEGISLATURE FROM THE STANDING
COMMITTEE STANDING COMMITTEE HE
MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH. MY
COLLEAGUE HERE DOCTOR PAN
SHARES THE STANDING COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE I CHEER THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AND SOMETIMES I
THINK WHAT WE FIND FRUSTRATING
AS IN THOSE COMMITTEES WHAT
WE'RE BASICALLY DOING I READ
THE REVIEWING BILL THAT COME
BEFORE US. WE HAVE A LIMITED
OPPORTUNITY TO GO DOT DELVED
DEEPLY. INTO A SPECIFIC SUBJECT
MATTER. ANSEL SELECT COMMITTEE
ALLOWS US TO DO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE BILL THAT WE'RE VOTING ON
TODAY IT ALLOWS US TO TRAVEL TO
GO TO PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TRAVEL SACRAMENTAL TO
BRING UP THEIR PERSPECTIVE SO
THAT'S THE POINT OF SELECT
COMMITTEES AND WE USE OUR TIME
DURING THE FALL. OUR
LEGISLATIVE INTERIM TO REALLY
KIND OF DO OUR OWN HOMEWORK AND
THAT'S TYPICALLY WHEN WE HAVE
THE SELECT COMMITTEES. WE HELD
OUR FIRST HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND FOCUS ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AS A SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS. WE THEN WENT TO
FRESNO DURING SUMMER BREAK.
FRIENDS NO IN THE MONTH OF JULY
YOU KNOW I'M A COMMITTED PUBLIC
SERVANT I'M COMMITTED. AND
FRESNO WAS SO HAPPY TO HAVE US
THERE THERE WE FOCUS ON HEALTH
CARE THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE
REDLINING PESTICIDE AN AIR
POLLUTION AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
CHART TRIALS ABILITY BE WELL
AND HEALTHY. AND AGAIN HERE FOR
A THIRD HEARING THIS YEAR WE'RE
FOCUSING ON IMMIGRATION IN LA
BECAUSE WE AS YOU ALL KNOW
WE'VE GOT ONE OF THE HIGHEST.
POPULATIONS OF IMMIGRANT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND WE
LOVE THE FACT THAT WE ARE ONE
OF THE MOST DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN THIS NATION. PEOPLE OF
VARYING LEGAL STATUS IS LIVE
AMONG US AND SADLY MANY ARE
LIVING IN FEAR THIS FEAR HAS
TORN FAMILIES APART AND CREATE
SERIOUS ISSUES. ISSUES AROUND
FEAR. ISSUES AROUND TRAUMA
ISSUES AROUND MIDDLE HEALTH.
THE POLITICAL CLIMATE. PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE. IN CREATING
THE SENSE OF FEAR. AND THE
BACKGROUND MATERIAL THAT YOU'LL
SEE BEFORE YOU- TALK ABOUT HOW
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
FEEDING INTO THAT CLIMATE OF
FEAR. BUT I'M ALSO CLEAR AS A
STATE LEGISLATOR THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT THE
ONLY ACCESS OF POP AXIS OF
POWER WE HERE IN CALIFORNIA CAN
DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO CULTIVATE
INCLUSION. EQUALITY AND EQUITY
IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES WE CAN
USE OUR TIME LEARNING AND
LISTENING TO PEOPLE THROUGH
HEARINGS LIKE THIS AND WE CAN
COMMUNICATE TO THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KNOW
TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. BEFORE I TURN
IT OVER THE OTHER MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF. WHO
HAVE BEEN HERE TO MAKE THIS
EVENT POSSIBLE YOU COULD
IMAGINE TO TAKE A OFFICIAL
SENATE. COMMITTEE ON THE ROAD
IS NOT EASY AND SO WE'RE ALSO
BE LIVESTREAMED- CURRENTLY ON
FACEBOOK ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE ON MY OWN
SENATE WEBSITE. AND THAT CAN'T
BE DONE BY ME IS MERELY
SNAPPING MY FINGERS SO I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF. FROM OUR SERGEANTS
REPROGRAPHICS THE SENATE
LIBRARIANS MAIL ROOM THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER MY
DISTRICT STAFF- YOU ALL MAKE
CIVIL SERVANTS SHINE AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU. AGAIN OUR
COLLABORATORS THE SEE YOUR
HEALTH FOUNDATION WORK
DILIGENTLY TO. PARTNER WITH US
THE BANK THIS HEARING POSSIBLE.
MY HOME GIRLS AT HOME GIRL
INDUSTRIES FOR MAKING THE
AMAZING PASTRIES. WE HAVE AN
OFFICE IN THE SENATE CALL SO
ARE THE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH AND THEY ARE THE TEAM
THAT WE CAN ASK TO DO THE DEEP
DIVE IN TERMS OF POLICY
RESEARCH AND- THEY- HAVE
PARTNERED WITH US ON ALL OF OUR
HEARINGS IN- HAD MADE THE
MATERIALS AVAILABLE TO YOU.
POSSIBLE. BEFORE I INTRODUCE US
SOME OF THE- STAFF MEMBER WHO
ARE HERE REPRESENTING THEIR
ESTEEMED CAUGHT THERE'S THE
BOSSES MY COLLEAGUES IN THE-
FELLOW ELECTED OFFICIALS. I'D
LIKE TO- INTRODUCE MY PARTNER
IN HEALTH EQUITY. MY COLLEAGUE
WHO REPRESENTS THE SIX SENATE
DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO STATE
SENATOR DR RICHARD PAN OKAY
THANK YOU. FIRST OF ALL I WANNA
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH- SIR
MITCHELL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND PROUD TO SERVE ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE- UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP- I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION IT'S GREAT TO BE IN
YOUR HOOD YOU SPEND A LOT OF
TIME IN MIND. IN SACRAMENTO SO
IT'S GREAT TO BE OUT HERE IN
LOS ANGELES- IN YOUR YOUR HOME
CHURCH AND C. C. EVERYONE HERE
AND TO LEARN FROM ALL OF YOU
HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA
AND- HOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO. IS
A PEDIATRICIAN CERTAINLY- I WAS
VERY CERTAINLY VERY INTERESTED
IN PARTICIPATING IN THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF. CHILDREN'S
WELL BEING IN FACT A- AS
PREVIOUSLY BEFORE OBSERVING THE
LEGISLATURE- AT UC DAVIS WHERE
I FOCUSED ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. AND
THE- AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- CENTER MITCHELL'S
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA AS-
BUDGET- CHAIR AND PREVIOUSLY-
I'M PROUD TO- TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH YOU AS YOUR SUCCESSOR ON
BUDGETS OF THREE. SOMETIMES I
EVEN SUCCEED I THINK OCCASION
SO- BUT YOU'VE DONE SO MUCH
THEY'RE TRYING TO BE SURE WE
KEEP THE MOMENTUM THERE. BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH WE NEED TO DO
AND- AS A MEMBER OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS WELL THE
VICE CHAIR- THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
FOR THE API COMMUNES WELL AS
MANY OTHER COMMITTEES AS WELL.
OVER HALF OF ALL A P. EYES ARE
ACTUALLY IMMIGRANTS. RIGHT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE API POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA OVER HALF OR
ACTUALLY- IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES
AND THEN YOU THINK THE REST YOU
KNOW HOW MANY OTHER THAN
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS- EXACTLY
THE FASTEST GROWING IMMIGRANT
GROUPS- AND CERTAINLY WE HAVE
OF COURSE A LONG HISTORY OF
IMMIGRATION FROM MANY OTHER.
BACKGROUNDS AS WELL. AND THE-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AND THAT PARTICULAR RELATION TO
CHILDREN. I THINK YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THE ATMOSPHERE THAT'S
BEING GENERATED- AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BY THE CURRENT- PRESIDENT
HIS ADMINISTRATION- AND- THAT
IS NOT ONLY OF COURSE THROUGH
THE POLICIES BUT EVEN BY
GIVING- SENSUALLY- SUPPORT OR-
ARE. ARE ARE- I WOULD SAY.
BASICALLY CONDONING
UNFORTUNATELY- ANTI IMMIGRANT
RHETORIC BY OTHERS IT IS QUITE
TROUBLING AND FACT AS WE ARE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO TRY TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTHIER
AND STRONGER AND MORE WELCOMING
AND ACTUALLY TO MOVE OUR
ECONOMY FORWARD AS WELL. I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT-
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS THE
CONNIE THAT'S DRIVING THE
ECONOMY FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
ACTUALLY BLOOMBERG NEWS SAID
ONE OF ITS BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
EMBRACE IMMIGRATION. RIGHT
ACTUALLY BECAUSE POLICY GREAT
EMBRACING IMMIGRANTS AS PART OF
THE REASON THAT WE'RE LEADING
THE COUNTRY. IN TERMS OF THE
GROWTH OF THE UNITED STATES SO.
IS WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
CERTAINLY. WE ARE TRYING TO PUT
IN POLICIES TO BE SUPPORTIVE
AND TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE GOLDEN STATE.
BUT OUR CHALLENGES THAT WE ALSO
ARE FACING POLICIES THEY'RE
MAKING PEOPLE AFRAID AND
FEARFUL OF ACTUALLY RECEIVING
THOSE SERVICES THAT ARE SO
NECESSARY TO HELP SUPPORT-
FAMILIES AND TO ALLOW.
IMMIGRANTS IN THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA SUCCEED SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING THE
TESTIMONY OUT FROM THE VARIOUS-
WITNESSES ABOUT WHAT ARE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO IS A STATE BUT
THEN ALSO HOW CAN WE CHANGE THE
CONVERSATION AROUND
IMMIGRATION- NOW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND AGAIN I WANNA
THANK. SIR MITCHELL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP CONVENING THIS
HEARING AND I KNOW THE WORK
OKAY CAN YOU DO IT AS A RESULT
OF THIS HEARING AND ALSO TO
THANK ALL THE- PEOPLE ARE
DISSIPATING THE SPEAKERS AND
THE STAFF. WORKS TOGETHER THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TALK TO PAN
I'M REALLY PROUD TO HAVE YOU
HERE AND YOU KNOW AND YOU KNOW
WHEN I SAY WHO. BUT WITH GREAT
AFFECTION. I DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO GET ANY KIND OF NEGATIVE
CONNOTATION BECAUSE I. WHO IT
IS MY HOOK AND I LOVE IT WITH
ALL MY HEART. SO BEFORE WE I
INVITE OUR FIRST PANELIST UP
LET ME JUST SAY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING- ON VIA THE LIVE
STREAM PLEASE KNOW THAT THE
CONTENT BEING REFERENCED HERE.
CAN BE FOUND ON THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WEBSITE.
WE'RE PUTTING UP THE ADDRESS
FOR YOU NOW SO YOU CAN FOLLOW
ALONG WITH THOSE MATERIALS
SHOULD YOU DECIDE TO DO SO. LET
ME ACKNOWLEDGE THE OTHER-
OFFICES THAT ARE REPRESENTED
HERE TODAY BY STAFF BECAUSE
IT'S AN IMPRESSIVE LIST. I
THINK IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH-
ARE RENEWED NOT RENEWED BUT OUR
FOCUS AND COMMITMENT ON. THE
SUBJECT MATTER BEFORE US. SO IF
YOU HOLD YOUR POSSIBLY INTO THE
LONG LIST BUT I'M SO GLAD
EVERYBODY'S HERE WE'LL BE
JOINED BY SENATOR BEEN ALLEN A
LITTLE LATER TODAY. ALL FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE FAMILY MEMBER
BLOW MELISSA KOFFLER. SENATOR
GONZALEZ ARE BRAND NEW KALI- IS
REPRESENTED BY HILDA DELGADO.
SENATE TO SUSAN RUBIO STAFF
DEDICA MENDOZA. SENATOR MARIA
PLANTED AROUSAL IS REPRESENTED
BY WILLIAM LOPEZ. CONGRESSMAN
TORRES DANIEL EAKINS. CHRIS
WOMAN THOREZ. WE'LL LEYVA.
THAT'S WHAT THE ROYAL ALBERT.
FIGARO THIS WOMAN BENETTON IS
REPRESENTED HERE BY STAFF. OF
THE OFFICE OF GEORGE MCKENNA L.
A. U. S. U. L. A. YOU. THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT REPRESENT. BY
CAROLINE FOWLER. CENTER
ALLEN'S- DAVID. BILL CARL C. IS
HERE- REP DE LA COUNTY IS A
BRAID MILLER. TOMORROW ACTUALLY
WHO THE ASSISTANT CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS INCOME
RELATION TO THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICE FOR THE COUNTY. AARON
GARCIA AND PATRICIA CAMACHO
AGAIN FROM CONGRESSMAN
BARRAGAN- CITY COUNCILMAN
DANIEL LEE IS HERE FROM THE
GREAT CITY OF CULVER CITY
WELCOME COUNCILMAN. AND RUBEN
RODRIGUEZ REPRESENTING MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE BLACK CAUCUS
IS SIMPLY MEANT REGGIE JONES
LAWYER PLEASE GIVE THEM ALL
AROUND THE PLUS AND THANK THEM
FOR BEING HERE. WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
BEN ALLEN THANK YOU SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE IF YOU
WERE WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH- JR
MITCHELL AND I HAD. HI MITCHELL
SUCH A FANTASTIC LEADER FOR
THIS COMMUNITY AND I'M I'M SO
PLEASED TO CALL MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE. I ACTUALLY IS SHE
MENTIONED- JUST APPROVED YOU
THAT I ACTUALLY I TUNED IN ON
MY PHONE- UP ON MY WAY HERE ONE
OF THE MANY REASONS WHY WE
THINK OUR STAFF WHO DO YOU WORK
SO HARD TO HELP PROVIDE. THE
LIVE STREAMING SERVICES IS NOT
ONLY. KITCHENS CAN LISTEN THESE
HEARING SO THAT THE MEMBERS CAN
LISTEN TO THEIR- THESE HEARINGS
WHEN THEY'RE STUCK IN LOS
ANGELES TRAFFIC SO. I SO I WAS
ABLE TO HEAR BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUE COMMENTS AND I I.
ECHO. ALL THE THINGS THEY SAID
I'M ACTUALLY NOT A OFFICIAL
MEMBER OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
BUT I'M LOCAL I. I REPRESENT
THE WEST SIDE- RICH IS NEXT
DOOR TO HOLLY'S DISTRICT. AND I
ALSO CHAIR JEWISH CAUCUS AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING ON A LOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN AND THE JEWISH
CAUCUSES WORKING WITH SOME OF
OUR OTHER- AND THE CAUCUSES ON
THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION ON THE
SON OF AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF IN
THE DESCENDANT OF IMMIGRANTS ON
MY- ON MY MOM'S SIDE AND- YOU
KNOW VERY. HI SO COGNIZANT OF
THE INCREDIBLE WRITTEN IS THAT
IMMIGRATION IS GIVEN TO OUR
NATION INTO OUR STATE- THE
JEWISH CARCASS ACTUALLY TOOK A
TRIP WITH THE LATINO CAUCUS
DOWN TO THE BORDER. A LITTLE
BIT THIS YEAR I DAVID IT WAS
MENTIONED AS OUR CHIEF CONCERN
FOR THE JEWISH CAUCUS. WERE
ABLE TO VISIT THE TIE- MAKES A
DETENTION ALREADY AND THEN GO
VISIT A FACILITY- THAT JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICES AND HIGHEST
THERE ARE RUNNING YOU SO YOU
KNOW THERE'S- TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR. A TOP SEEKERS ON
THE BORDER AND WE WERE ABLE TO
GET IT I'VE KIND OF FIRST. I'D
SENSE OF THE CURRENT CRISIS.
THAT EXISTS ON THE ORDER. I BUT
I BUT WE'RE GOING TO TALK. THEY
ABOUT ALL OF THE M. THE ALL OF
THE INCREDIBLE. I BOTH
OPPORTUNITIES CHALLENGES IN IN
THERE IN THE RICHNESS THAT
IMMIGRANTS BRING. TO OUR
SOCIETY- HOLLY VASTLY RIGHT
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT POLICY ISSUES IN A IN A
BROADWAY. AND THEN SOME
INTERESTING IDEAS COME OUT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS SOMETIMES
OUR BUDGET- BUDGET PLACE
SOMETIMES THEIR BILLS- BUT IT
YOU KNOW WITH. WITH WITH WITH
CENTERS PAN AND MITCHELL YOU'VE
GOT TO REALLY- VERY IMPORTANT
LEADERS IN THE SPACE AND I'M
JUST PLEASED TO WELL UP TO BE
HERE WITH THEM TONIGHT. TODAY.
THANK YOU. TO COME IN I'D LIKE
TO INVITE- DOCTOR VALLEJO WAS
GOING TO DO OUR FIRST
PRESENTATION TO JOIN A SOMEWHAT
SHE COMES UP- IT WAS MENTIONED
IN THE AUDIENCE. A SUGGESTION
WAS MADE THAT WE- HAVE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE IN HONOR OF
CONGRESSMAN. CUMMINGS AND- I-
FRANKLY I'M GONNA MAKE A
DIFFERENT SUGGESTION. I THINK
MOMENTS OF SILENCE OUR WHILE
RESPECTFUL ARE PASSIVE. AND
THERE WAS NOTHING PASSIVE ABOUT
THE ADVOCACY OF CONGRESSMAN
COMING. SO WHEN I'M GOING TO
SUGGEST YOU ALL DO. IS AT THE
END OF TODAY'S HEARING AFTER
WE'VE HEARD PRESENTATIONS BY
ALL THESE EXPERTS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A MOMENT WE GO MAKE SOME
NOISE. THE POINT OF MAKING THE
NOISE WILL BE YOU ALSO MAKING A
DECISION BASED ON THE WORK YOU
DO EVERY DAY OR PERHAPS. A NEW
RELATIONSHIP YOU FORMED BY
MEETING SOMEONE THIS MORNING OR
SOMETHING YOU HEARD BY OUR
EXPERT PANELS ABOUT AN ACTION
YOU WERE GOING TO TAKE. SO
CONGRESSMAN CUMMINGS LIFE AND
WORK WILL NOT BE IN VAIN WHAT
ACTION ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE
PLACE ON THE SUBJECT MATTER
BEFORE US TODAY. AND SO AT THE
END OF THE HEARING WHEN WE MAKE
OUR NOISE WE WILL BE PUTTING
INTO THE UNIVERSE OUR
COMMITMENT TO BE ACTION
ORIENTED. NOT MERELY PAUSING
FOR A MOMENT OF SILENCE TO MAKE
AN ONGOING COMMITMENT TO AFTER
THIS. BEAN ACTIVIST CHANGE
AGENTS FAIR ENOUGH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH THAT DOCTOR
BLAKE- IS AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY
AMERICANA STUDIES AND ETHNICITY
AND THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TODAY SHE'S GONNA
KICK US OFF BY EDUCATING US ON
THE HISTORY OF IMMIGRATION IN
L. A. IN CAL AND CALIFORNIA AND
TOUCH ON RECENT IMMIGRATION
ACTIONS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US TODAY DOCTOR
VALLEJO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY FOR- CONVENING
THIS GROUP FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
SENATOR MITCHELL IT'S SUCH A
PLEASURE. TO BE HERE. SO LOS
ANGELES HAS LONG BEEN HAILED AS
THIS GLAMOROUS MULTI ETHNIC
CITY OF POSSIBILITY AND UPWARD
MOBILITY A PLACE WHERE AMERICAN
DREAMS ARE SUPPOSEDLY MADE. BUT
AMIDST THE GLITZ AND THE
GLAMOUR INEQUALITY IN LA IS
PALPABLE AS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING AND THESE
CONTRADICTORY TRENDS IN
PROSPERITY ON THE ONE HAND BUT
ALSO POVERTY ON THE OTHER HAND
HAVE OCCURRED AGAINST A
BACKDROP OF SIGNIFICANT RACIAL
ETHNIC CHANGE. KEEP CAN YOU
CHANGE THE SITE FOR ME PLEASE.
SO IN ORDER TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE LA A TODAY
AND HOW TO CONTINUE BUILDING AN
EQUITABLE MULTI ETHNIC REGION
THAT WILL LEAD THE NATION ON
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION BECAUSE
THAT IS ONE OF OUR GOALS AT THE
STATE AT THE REGION WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR STATE AND
OUR REGION WAS BUILT ON A
SYSTEM OF SETTLER COLONIALISM
WHERE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE WERE
REMOVED AND DISPLACED FROM
THEIR LANDS WE HAVE TO COME TO
TERMS WITH THE HISTORY IN LA A
PERPETUAL ANGEL VIOLENCE AND
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. BUT ALSO
AIM TO MAINTAIN WHITE SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC DOMINANCE SO WHAT
WE NOW CALL LA IS TOM VIA LAND
AND THE TOM THE COMMUNITY
EXTENDS FROM THE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS THE SANTA ANA RIVER
IN OVER THE ENTIRE ELLIE BILLS
BASIM NORTH LA IS TO TAPE HIM
LAND IN BOTH THESE COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN LA DESPITE-
THE FACT. THAT. C. AND SOCIAL-
THE SOCIAL ENVIRONMENT. EFFORTS
TO RAISE THESE COMMUNITIES BUT
THERE'S ALSO MULTIPLE
COMMUNITIES OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE IN LA WHOSE HISTORIES
ARE EMBEDDED INTO THE FABRIC OF
OUR CITY SO THESE INCLUDE
NATIVE PEOPLES FROM. THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES AS WELL AS
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND LATIN
AMERICAN INDIGENOUS DIASPORAS
SO ALLEY ISN'T JUST AN
IMMIGRANT CITY IT ISN'T JUST AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN CITY IT'S ALSO
AN INDIGENOUS CITY. LOS ANGELES
HAS THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF ANY CITY
IN THE US NOW ELLIE IS ALSO
ROOTED. IN SPANISH AND THEN
ENGLISH SETTLER COLONIALISM SO
AFTER PLUNDERING AZTEC EMPIRE A
PLAN WAS DEVELOPED BY SPAIN TO
COLONIZE. CALIFORNIA VIA THE
MISSION SYSTEM. IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY ONE A GROUP OF FORTY ONE
PEOPLE KNOWN AS LOS POBLADO IT
IS OCCUPIED AN AREA. IN NORTH-
IT NEAR THE ALLEY RIVER. THE
PUEBLO WAS NAMED AFTER THE
PERSONALLY CAME TO BE CALLED
LOS ANGELES WHAT WE KNOW OUR
CITY YESTERDAY. SORRY A CITY
THERE THERE WAS A THRIVING
NATIVE AMERICAN AT CITY. OF THE
SETTLER COLONISTS BECAME KNOWN
AS CALIFORNIA'S THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HERE IN LA
BECAME KNOWN AS THE GABRIELINO
AFTER THE SAN GABRIEL MISSION.
AFTER MEXICAN INDEPENDENCE WAS
ACHIEVED FROM SPAIN IN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ONE THE MISSIONS LOST
THEIR GRIP ON CONTROL AND THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT CREATED HUGE
RANCHES IN CALIFORNIA. THE LAND
WAS GIVEN TO THE ELITE PEOPLE
BORN IN CALIFORNIA MIXED BLOOD
BUT WHO CONSIDER THEMSELVES AT
THE TOP OF THE RACIAL
HIERARCHY. DO ANY OF THESE
NAMES SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU LOS
FELIS YEAH. THE PAN THE MALIBU.
I'M I COULD I COULD GO ON AND
ON SAN PEDRO. IN EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT MEXICO CEDED CALIFORNIA
TO THE U. S. WITH THE SIGNING
OF THE TREATY OF GUADALUPE
HIDALGO AND THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
END THE MEXICAN AMERICAN WAR-
TEAMS LIKE ME KEEP PLEASE.
THERE CAN WAR DIDN'T END WITH
THE SIGNING OF THE TREATY IN
THE LATE NINETEENTH CENTURY I
ALLEN- WITH A MASSIVE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE AS ANGLOS
CAME INTO THE STATE CHINESE
IMMIGRANTS JAPANESE IMMIGRANTS
AND IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO. AN
ALLEY GREW AND PROSPERED
BECAUSE THE ANGLO WOULD LEAD AT
THE TIME IT DIVESTED CALIFORNIA
THE MEXICAN AMERICANS OF THEIR
LAND AND POLITICAL POWER. AND
USE LAWS SOCIAL PRACTICES AND
RACIAL VIOLENCE TO EXCLUDE AND
CATEGORIZE NON WHITE PEOPLE AS
OTHERS. NOW POPULATION
CONTINUED TO GROW AFTER THE
NINETEEN HUNDREDS PART OF THE
GROWTH WAS DUE IN PART TO
IMMIGRATION FROM MEXICO PEOPLE
WHO ARE FLEEING THE MEXICAN
REVOLUTION. BUT IT WAS ALSO DUE
TO A GREAT INTERNAL MIGRATION
WHITE ETHNICS COMING FROM OTHER
AREAS OF THE UNITED STATES AS
WELL AS BLACK AMERICANS COMING
FROM OTHER AREAS OF THE US SO
PEOPLE WERE PULLED INTO. LA
ONCE AGAIN LIKE WE SEE TODAY BY
THE PROMISE OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM EXPANDING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES- ESPECIALLY
MANUFACTURING GERALD DURING
AFTER I WORLD WAR TWO ABUNDANT
SPACE THERE WAS ONCE ABUNDANT
SPACE IN LOS ANGELES. AND THE
PROMISE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP. BY
THE MID. TWENTIETH CENTURY ONLY
WAS MAJORITY WHITE BUT WAS ALSO
A SPRAWLING METROPOLIS
COMPRISED OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
AFRICAN AMERICANS LONG SETTLED
MEXICAN ASIAN AMERICAN PEOPLE
JEWISH AMERICANS AND SOMEONE.
OF COURSE ALL OF THESE GROUPS
WERE LIVING UNDER A SYSTEM OF
WHITE SUPREMACY THAT WAS
ENFORCED BY SOCIAL PRACTICES A
WEB OF LIES AT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
CITY STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
THAT RESULTED IN RICK RACIAL
RESIDENTIAL SEGREGATION.
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER THE IMPACT OF RED
LINING WHICH CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED IN THE CASE OF LOS
ANGELES. AND THIS OF COURSE
RESULTED IN TWO MAJOR WAVES OF
CIVIL UNREST AN UPRISING IN THE
SIXTIES AND THE NINETEEN
NINETIES OF COURSE DESPITE
THESE BARRIERS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN LA CONTINUE TO THRIVE.
BUT THIS IS STORICA CONTEXT
COMBINED WITH THIS CONTEMPORARY
MOMENT. THE POLITICS OF FEAR
AND A BOLD ATTACK ON IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. SHAPES THE
INTEGRATION OF NEWER IMMIGRANTS
TO LA THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
AND THIS BRINGS ME TO ONE OF
THE CENTRAL CONCERNS WHEN
THINKING ABOUT. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY TODAY IS WHAT IS
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION. SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION WE SAY THAT IT IS
AN INTENTIONAL PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES THE NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
IT'S A GOVERNMENT POLICIES AT
THE CITY REGIONAL AND STATE
LEVEL. I THINK I HAVE TWENTY
MINUTES. IS THAT MY TWENTY
MINUTES UP. OKAY I'M WE C.
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION IS A
DYNAMIC RECIPROCAL RELATIONSHIP
IN WHICH NEW COMERS AND THE
RECEIVING SOCIETY BOTH HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR INTEGRATION
AND BOTH BENEFIT AS THEY WORK
TOGETHER TO BUILD SAFE DRIVING
AND CONNECTED COMMUNITIES SO
OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION PEOPLE
THINK THE INTEGRATION IS SOLELY
BASED ON WHAT IMMIGRANTS
THEMSELVES ARE DOING BUT THAT'S
NOT ACTUALLY HOW INTO
IMMIGRANTS FULLY INTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY IT IS A RECIPROCAL. TWO
WAY PROCESS INTEGRATION ALSO
DEPENDS ON WHAT ALL OF YOU ARE
DOING ON THE GROUND THE
POLICIES THAT YOU ARE ALL
MAKING AND WE CAN THINK OF
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AND A
COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS ONE IS
ECONOMIC MOBILITY THE ABILITY
TO FULLY ENGAGE IN THE ECONOMY
WHAT IS SOMETHING THAT. ALL OF
YOU AND SENATOR PAN CENTER JOEL
MENTIONED EARLIER IT IS WORTH
WARMTH OF WELCOME THE EXTENT TO
WHICH IMMIGRANTS ARE WELCOMED
BY THE RECEDING SOCIETY AND
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THE ABILITY
FOR IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS TO FULLY ENGAGE
ARTISTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
NOW AS SENATOR MITCHELL ALREADY
MET AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CREATE AND DELETE FEDERAL
POLICY IMMIGRATION POLICY AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL PRIMARILY WHO
IS ALLOWED TO BECOME. IMMIGRATE
THE UNITED STATES TO BECOME A
CITIZEN. AND THESE POLICIES AND
RHETORIC HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY PUNITIVE AND
RACIALIZED IN THE TRUMP IN ERA.
AND SO THAT IS WHY IT IS LEFT
UP TO STATES CITIES AND REGIONS
TO CRAFT POLICIES THAT INSURE
IMMIGRANTS THEIR CHILDREN. AND
LONG SETTLED AMERICANS CAN
THRIVE SOCIALLY CIVIC LEÓN
ECONOMICALLY. SO WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN FOR US AT TODAY CAN YOU
CHANGE ASIDE FOR ME PLEASE. SO
UNLESS YOU'VE BEEN LIVING UNDER
A ROCK IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT THE-
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE COUNTRY ARE
TRANSFORMING IN TERMS OF RACE
AND ETHNICITY SO BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE THE US IS POISED TO
BE A MAJORITY MINORITY COUNTRY
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE. 80% OF
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES
IDENTIFIED AS WHITE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY AND BETWEEN TWENTY FORTY
AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE THE
UNITED STATES WILL CEASE TO BE
MAJORITY WHITE NOW GUEST WHAT
STATE AND REGION OF RT
EXPERIENCE THESE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGES. THE PLACE WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS 67% WHITE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY M. BY TWO
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA WAS NO
LONGER A MAJORITY WHITE STATE.
BY TWENTY FIFTY. 24% OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE WHITE. LA
WAS ALREADY MAJORITY MINORITY
BEFORE THE STATE LA IS REALLY
REALLY SERVES. CHANGING IN THIS
REGARD SO IN 198053% OF I MEAN
HE CAN CHANGE HIS LIFE FOR ME
PLEASE. HE. 53% OF OUR. PEOPLE
IN LA COUNTY WERE WHITE AND
CALIFORNIA WAS 41% WHITE BY
NINETEEN NINETY. I'M SORRY AT A
LOS ANGELES AND BY TWENTY FIFTY
ONLY 19% OF PEOPLE IN LA WELL
IDENTIFIED. AS WHITE. SO
IMMIGRANTS ARE A VITAL AND
LARGE PART OF LA COUNTY. I'M
KEITH CAN CAN YOU CHANGE ASIDE
FOR ME AGAIN PLEASE YOU SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT AT THE PERCENT
IMMIGRANT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BY NINETEEN SEVENTY TWENTY
SIXTEEN. A LITTLE OVER A THIRD
OF ALLEYS COUNTY'S POPULATION
ARE FOREIGN BORN. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ABOUT 13% OF LOS
ANGELES WAS FOREIGN BORN BUT
TODAY IT'S THE THIRD. OF OUR
COUNTY. AND. IMMIGRANTS TODAY
HAVE A VARIETY OF STATUSES AS
SENATOR MITCHELL- MENTIONED SO
KEEP THE CHANGE THE SLIDE
PLEASE YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS BY IMMIGRATION
STATUS FIVE. 9% OF IMMIGRANTS
IN LA COUNTY ARE DOCUMENTED 10%
A LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENTS
AND 17% ARE NATURALIZED
CITIZENS. ONE MORE TIME FOR ME
PLEASE KEEP. 80% OF IMMIGRANTS
IN LOS ANGELES HOW BEN IN THE
COUNTRY TEN YEARS OR LONGER SO
IMMIGRANTS IN LA ARE A LONG
SETTLED POPULATION. 86% OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ONE IN FIVE
ANGELENOS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
THEMSELVES OR LIVE WITH THE
FAMILY MEMBER WHO IS A
DOCUMENTED AND 68% OF
UNDOCUMENTED ANGELENOS HAVE
BEEN IN THE US MORE. THAN A
DECADE SO THIS MEANS THAT
POLICY IS THAT FAMILIES APART
HAVE BROAD IMPACTS ON OUR
COMMUNITIES THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY IS CONNECTED TO
FAMILIES CHILDREN- WORKPLACES
SCHOOLS ALL OF THE INSTITUTIONS
IN WHICH- THAT BECAUSE OUR
SOCIETY TO FUNCTION. I WANT TO
SHOW YOU A SLIDE THAT SHOWS
SOME OF THE TOP BIRTH COUNTRIES
FOR MORE IMMIGRANTS TODAY ARE
HANDLING KEEP TEAM DECIDE FOR
ME PLEASE. IMMIGRANT ANGELENOS
ARE LATINO NEARLY ONE THIRD OR
ASIAN AMERICAN OR PACIFIC
PACIFIC ISLANDER THERE'S ALSO A
GROWING BLACK IMMIGRANT
POPULATION. BUT IF WE LOOK AT
THE TOP BIRTH COUNTRIES THEY'VE
CHANGED IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
SO THIRTY YEARS AGO 42% CAME
FROM MEXICO A PERCENT FROM EL
SALVADOR. AND 6% FROM THE
PHILIPPINES BUT OF THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO MIGRATED LESS
THAN TEN YEARS AGO TODAY ONLY A
QUARTER COME FROM MEXICO. 11%
COME FROM CHINA AND 8% COME
FROM THE PHILIPPINES AND WE'VE
SEEN MORE- AN INCREASE IN
IMMIGRANTS FROM ASIA AND ALSO
FROM CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES. NOW THERE'S TWO
ELEMENTS OF INTEGRATION THAT I
WANT TO TOUCH ON- QUICKLY ONE
IS CIVIC ENGAGEMENT KEEP CAN
YOU CHANGE THE SITE FOR ME
PLEASE. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IMMIGRANTS
BECOMING ENGAGED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND ONE IMPORTANT
WAY TO FACILITATE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. IS VIA EFFORTS
AROUND NATURALIZATION SO THE
BENEFITS OF NATURALIZATION
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE INCREASED
WAGES BETTER ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN
PROTECTIONS FROM PUNITIVE
ENFORCEMENT POLICIES. AND
THINGS LIKE BOATING WHICH MEANS
THAT IMMIGRANTS HAVE A GREATER
VOICE IN POLICY MAKING THERE'S
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BECOME. CITIZENS.
AND ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY OF
LET THE ORIGINS OF 70% ARE
LATINO TWENTY PERCENT. ARE API
SO STRONG EFFORTS AROUND
NATURALIZATION REVERBERATE AT
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY IS ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT SENATORS YOU DON'T
HAVE THE SLIDE BUT I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU A COPY OF IT. I'M
CHANGE THE SIDE FOR ME PLEASE
KEITH IMMIGRANTS INTACT AND AN
LA TEND TO BE BETWEEN THE
WORKING AGES AND THEY'RE ALSO
LARGE CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR-
INDUSTRIES AND OUR ECONOMY. AS
YOU SEE IN THIS SLIDE THE RED.
REPRESENTS NATIVE BORN
AMERICANS WHO ARE IN THE
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES BY SECTOR
AND THE GREEN BLUE AND ORANGE
REPRESENT IMMIGRANTS SO.
IMMIGRANTS ARE SPREAD ALL
ACROSS THE ECONOMIC SYSTEM OF
LOS ANGELES AND COMMITTED
IMMIGRANT EMPLOYED IN NEARLY
EVERY. ECONOMIC SECTOR BUT.
JEAN SLIDE KEITH IMMIGRANTS ARE
OFTEN PAID LESS THAN THE U. S.
BORN AND INCOMES VARIED
DEPENDING ON RECENCY OF ARRIVAL
AND ALSO IMMIGRATION STATUS THE
MORE RECENTLY ARRIVED
IMMIGRANTS MAKE LOWER INCOMES.
AS DO UNDOCUMENTED AND THOSE
WHO ARE LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS NATURALIZED
IMMIGRANTS MAKE- HAVE THE
HIGHEST HOUSEHOLD INCOMES IN LA
COUNTY. IMMIGRANTS ALSO I
EDUCATION OF COURSE ALSO VARIES
BY STATUS KEITH TEAMS ASIDE FOR
ME PLEASE. I'M THE FOREIGN BORN
HAVE LOWER LEVELS OF
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN THE
U. S. BORE THE UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION HAS THE LOWEST
LEVELS BUT OF COURSE THESE
DISPARITIES ARE RELATED TO
VARIOUS BARRIERS THAT MAKE
EDUCATION UNATTAINABLE. AND
THEN BEING LA WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT HOUSING BURDEN AND-
HOMEOWNER RENTER BURDEN KEITH
CHANGE THE SLIDE FOR ME PLEASE.
IMMIGRANTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS HAVE HIGHER
RATES OF RENT AND HOMEOWNER
BIRDING AND THIS REDUCES OF
COURSE THE ABILITY TO PAY FOR
OTHER SERVICES AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT PARENTS HAVE TO INVEST IN
THEIR CHILDREN. AND
ACCUMULATING ASSETS FOR
EMERGENCIES SO IT'S NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND RACIAL
ETHNIC DIFFERENCES IN. OUTCOMES
BUT ALSO AS SENATOR MITCHELL
MENTIONED EARLIER VARIATIONS IN
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND WHO IS
PARTICULARLY DISADVANTAGED HE
WAS AT ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZED.
AND SO FORTH SO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT FEDERAL POLICY
CHANGES OF ROT BUT I ALSO MADE
A HANDY LIST HERE CHANGE THE
SIDE FOR ME PLEASE KEITH. I'M
HERE ARE TEN THINGS THAT
SCHOLARS ACTIVIST COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IMMIGRANT SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS ARE REALLY REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT AT THE FEDERAL
POLICY LEVEL. WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT NEW ATTACKS ON
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE THOSE
ELIGIBLE FOR NATURALIZATION
THIS INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
CHANGES THE PUBLIC CHARGE WHICH
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL BE
DISCUSSING LATER. THIS OF
COURSE MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
ELIGIBLE NATURALIZER IMMIGRANTS
TO OBTAIN LEGAL RESIDENCY IF
THEY USE SOME BENEFITS. THERE'S
ALSO SIGNIFICANT ATTEMPTS TO
RESTRICT IMMIGRATION VIA LEGAL
MEANS BY REDUCING THE ASYLUM
LEASE A CEILING INCREASING FEES
MAKING VISA APPLICANTS SHOW
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD HEALTHCARE
THIS WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT. IMMIGRANTS OF COLOR
API'S AND LATINO IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARE- APPLYING FOR FAMILY
REUNIFICATION IN THE UNITED
STATES AND OF COURSE POLICIES
AROUND DETENTION AND
DEPORTATION. CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY IS ALSO A PARTICULAR
CONCERN WE NEED EVERYBODY TO BE
COUNTED SO THAT DATA CAN BE
USED TO ADDRESS INEQUALITIES.
AND I THINK MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE ISSUES TODAY BUT I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO AT DISCUSS THEM. SO
KEEP CAN YOU CHANGE THE SLIDE
FOR ME PLEASE I'M JUST GOING TO
WRAP UP HERE. MUCH OF THE DATA
THAT I PRESENTED HERE TODAY
SENATORS IS INCLUDED IN A
FORTHCOMING REPORT THE STATE OF
IMMIGRANTS IN LOS QUE A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY- FROM THE CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION THAT REPORT WILL BE
RELEASED IN DECEMBER. THAT
REPORT TAKES A DEEPER DIVE INTO
ELLIE'S IMMIGRANT POPULATION
AND PROVIDES MORE CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR BECOMING A
LEADER ON AND ON IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION ALSO ESTABLISHES A
BASELINE ON IMMIGRANTS AND
ALLIES THAT WE CAN MEASURE
MOBILITY. GOING FORWARD. THE
POINT IS THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE
HERE IN LA AS WE ALL KNOW THEY
MIGRATE FOR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY OR TO SKATE
POLITICAL TURMOIL TO REUNITE
WITH FAMILIES. AND EFFECTIVE
INTEGRATION POLICIES. MAY NEED
TO VARY BY CITY OR COMMUNITY.
POLICY ARE. MAYBE TO VERY
DEPENDING ON IMMIGRATION STATUS.
STRATEGIES FOR CREATING WELCOME
AND WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT
SHOULD ALSO BE INCLUDED AND
SHOULD ALSO BE INFORMED BY
IMMIGRANTS SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS SO A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO EMIGRATE
INTEGRATION LIKE WE'VE SEEN-
ALL OF YOU DISCUSS TODAY WILL
BENEFIT IMMIGRANTS FAMILIES BUT
ALSO LONG SETTLED ANGELENOS IN
CALIFORNIANS ALIGHT ALIKE ENDS
WHAT WE DO HERE IN LA IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY LIGHTS THE
WAY FOR OTHER REGIONS COMMITTED
TO INTEGRATING IMMIGRANTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTIVELY HELP.
NO THERE ALLEN. I SEE THE
WHEELS TURNING YOUR HEAD. I
KNOW YOU. CAN YOU I'M- GIVE US
A SENSE OF. I HAVE HOW.
SHIFTING VISA POLICIES ARE
CHANGING THE DENT CHANGING OUR
DEMOGRAPHICS HERE- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE WHERE YOU CAN YOU
ALSO GONNA COMMENT A LITTLE BIT
ON ON THE CONVERSATION GOING ON
RIGHT NOW AND IN CHANGING THE
WAY WE DO WE GRANT RB IS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND HOW YOU THINK
IT MIGHT IMPACT OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES HERE. YES THE
NUMBER OF. A PROPOSED RULE
CHANGES THAT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SUGGESTING- AND
HAVE TRIED TO IMPLEMENT- IN AN
EFFORT TO RESTRICT IMMIGRATION
INTO THE UNITED STATES OF THE
MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANTS TO ENTER
INTO THE UNITED STATES ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR THEY HELP FROM
ASIA LATIN AMERICA AND THE
CARIBBEAN MANY OF US OF COURSE
SEE THIS IS A VERY IS VERY
RACIALIZED POLICIES TO. TRY TO
PREVENT. THE. CHANGING NATURE
OF- THE UNITED STATES IS
DEMOGRAPHIC BUT THERE ARE-
POLICIES THAT ARE TRYING TO M.
IMPLEMENTS HIGHER FEES ON VISAS
FOR EXAMPLE TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM APPLYING FOR VISAS INTO
THE U. S. THERE ARE NEW
POLICIES THAT ARE BEING
SUGGESTED TO- REQUIRE
IMMIGRANTS TO SHOW THAT THEY
CAN PAY FOR OR AFFORD HEALTH
INSURANCE WHICH WILL PREVENT
PARTICULAR IMMIGRANTS FROM
APPLYING- FOR VISAS INTO THE
UNITE TO COME INTO THE UNITED
STATES PEOPLE HAVE SUGGESTED
THAT THIS WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT OF
COURSE THE API COMMUNITY AND
THE LATINO COMMUNITY WHO
OVERWHELMINGLY APPLY FOR FAMILY
REUNIFICATION IN THE U. S.
THERE ARE. ALSO ATTEMPTS TO OR
THERE AN AN ANNOUNCEMENT WAS
MADE. THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS DECREASING
AND THE REFUGEE CEILING SO THE
RARE REFUGEE CEILING IS ONCE
AGAIN DECREASING BY HALF WHICH
IS THE LOWEST LEVEL IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY AND SO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
DECREASING THE NUMBER OF
REFUGEES AND ASYLUM IS THAT
THEY WILL ALLOW INTO THE UNITED
STATES. THE CAP IS THAT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FOR NEXT YEAR
YEAH I WAS REGULARLY- THE
LATTER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WAS AROUND EIGHTY THOUSAND AND
SO THIS IS ARE YOU SAID. EIGHTY
THOUSAND UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND IT HAS BEEN
REDUCED TO EIGHTEEN AS THE
ALLEN EIGHT YEAH Q. AND SO THIS
IS. AGAIN ATTEMPTS TO PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM ENTERING IN TWO AT
THE UNITED STATES. IT HAS BEEN
HARD FOR MANY OF US TO KEEP UP
I HAVE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE THE
CHANGES ARE CONSTANT THE
CHANGES ARE INCREASINGLY-
PUNITIVE EXACTLY. EVEN IT IS IT
NOT ONLY AFFECTS THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO AT MY GREAT THE US
BUT THOSE WERE ALREADY HERE
AGAIN PUBLIC CHARGES ON MY ****
COLLEAGUES DISCUSS LATER ON IS
AN ATTACK ON PEOPLE WHO CAN
POTENTIALLY BECOME US CITIZENS-
SO THOSE ARE ALSO CONCERNS
THESE NEW ATTACKS ON. THE
ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZE IN WHO
ARE ALREADY HERE IN THE US.
WELL THE QUESTION ABOVE JUST
LOOKING AT THIS CHART THE YOU
HAD I I'VE SO IF WE WERE
ACTUALLY CHATTING ABOUT THE HOW
FAST HE WAS LOOKING AT THOSE
FOLKS WHO MIGRATED HERE MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS AGO VERSUS
THOSE. WHO COME IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGES ARE
TWO OF THEM ONE OF THEM. IS
THAT YOU KNOW THE PERCENTAGE OF
FOLKS FROM MAX. DOES DROP FROM
42% TWENTY FIVE PERCENT- AND
THEN THE OTHER ONE IS THE FACT
THAT THE- THE- NUMBER OF FOLKS
FROM CHINA JUMP FROM 3% TO
ELEVEN. CAN YOU COMMENT A
LITTLE BIT ON SOME OF THE-
GEOPOLITICS BEHIND THOSE TWO.
THOSE TWO CHEFS. YEAH THAT'S- A
GREAT QUESTION. SO THE SO THE
TRENDS IN CALIFORNIA NEAR
TRENDS. THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES MORE GENERALLY RATES OF
MEXICAN MIGRATION TO THE US ARE
ACTUALLY WHAT SCHOLARS SAY IT
WE CALL WE SAY THAT NET ZERO
BECAUSE THERE'S ACTUALLY MORE
MEXICANS LEAVING THE US THAT
ARE ARRIVING. AND THE MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES IS LONG SETTLED-
ON AVERAGE. OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS IN THE US HAVE BEEN
HERE TEN YEARS OR LONGER AND
THESE SHIFTS ACTUALLY. THE MAC
THE DECLINE IN MEXICAN
IMMIGRATION THE BEST ACTUALLY
STARTED RIGHT BEFORE THE GREAT
RECESSION SO THIS HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR DECADES SO DESPITE
WHAT YOU HEAR DONALD TRUMP'S
THOUSAND ABOUT MEXICAN
IMMIGRATION. MEXICAN
IMMIGRATION IS AT HISTORIC LOWS
TO THE UNITED STATES SOME OF
THIS- DYNAMICS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE U. S. THE LABOR
MARKET FOR EXAMPLE THAT MANY
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT IMMIGRATION
FROM MEXICO WOULD PICK BACK UP
AFTER THE RECESSION. ENDED BUT
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE CASE
THERE'S MULTIPLE DYNAMICS WITH
IN MEXICO ITSELF THE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
IMMIGRATION IS THAT. IT'S NOT
JUST AFFECTED BY WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE UNITED STATES BUT
ALSO BY WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN. AND IT'S
REALLY AFFECTED BY THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES. SO DYNAMICS IN
MEXICO SUCH AS A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN THE BIRTH RATE THE
BIRTH RATE IN MEXICO RIGHT NOW
IS. A REPLACEMENT LEVEL TWO
CHILDREN PER FAMILY. I'M WHICH
REDUCES THE QUARTER THE SIZE OF
THE POPULATION. WHO IS FACING A
G. CATION PERTINENTES. S. R. IN
MEXICO ITSELF. SO MOST OF THE.
LATINO MIGRATION IS COMING
FROM- CENTRAL AMERICA CENTRAL
AMERICAN REFUGEES WHO ARE. AND
MIGRATING BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC TURMOIL ROT BY US.
INTERVENTION IN THOSE COUNTRIES
A LONG HISTORY OF US
INTERVENTION WE HAVE SOME POSTS
ON OUR BLOG IT'S YES I I'D THAT
DISCUSS THIS MORE FULLY IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN READING
MORE ABOUT THOSE. MOST OF THE
GROWTH IN THE LATINO POPULATION
IN THE US IS COMING FROM A
GROWTH IN THE CHILDREN OF
IMMIGRANTS NOT FROM IMMIGRATION
WHEREAS MOST OF THE GROWTH IN
THE ASIAN POPULATION IS COMING
FROM. IMMIGRATION. SPECIFICALLY
TALK THE DYNAMICS OF SUCH AN
INCREASE THE FOLKS FROM CHINA-
IS THAT PARTLY BECAUSE OF THAT
AS A CHINESE GOVERNMENT LOOSEN
RESTRICTIONS ON LEAVING THE
COUNTRY. SOME OF THE INCREASE
IN IMMIGRATION FROM CHINA IS
THE WAY THAT WE SELECT
IMMIGRANTS IN THE FIRST PLACE
THE WAY THAT OUR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY SELECTS
IMMIGRANTS. WERE THE PRIMARY
WAY TO M. MIGRATE TO THE UNITED
STATES LAWFULLY IS VIA-
EMPLOYMENT OR FAMILY
REUNIFICATION. AND OUR
EMPLOYMENT POLICIES- FOR
MIGRATION TYPICALLY. PRIVILEGE
OF THOSE WHO ARE- WHO HAVE WHAT.
DEFINE AS HIGH SKILLS AND SO
THAT'S THE LAX IMMIGRANTS FROM
PARTICULAR COUNTRIES SUCH AS
HIGH SKILLED INDIAN IMMIGRANTS
OR INDIANS FROM I'M SORRY
IMMIGRANTS FROM CHINA SOME OF
IT HAS TO DO WITH OF COURSE
CHANGING DYNAMICS IN CHINA BUT
SOME OF IT ALSO HAS TO DO. WITH
FAMILY REUNIFICATION AS WELL SO
AS MIGRATION FROM CHINA I
INCREASE AFTER IMMIGRATION LAWS
CHANGED IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
THIS IS WHEN WE SAW THE STATE
THIS LARGE INCREASE IN
IMMIGRATION TO THE UNITED
STATES AFTER FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CHANGED. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE- MUCH OF
THAT INCREASE IS DUE TO FAMILY
REUNIFICATION POLICIES AND ALSO
EMPLOYMENT POLICIES. BUT I WILL
SAY I'M SORRY WHAT MANY PEOPLE
ALSO DON'T UNDERSTAND IS THAT
THE FASTEST GROWING
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY OUR ASIAN ORIGIN AS
WELL SO SOME OF- THIS IS ALSO
AGAIN A STEREO TYPE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE ABOUT WHO IS A DOCUMENTED
IN OUR IN OUR COUNTRY AND-
COMMUNITIES. ASH INTERESTING
NEPHEW MADE ONE OF THE POINTS I
WAS GONNA ASK ABOUT THAT- AND I
ALSO MAKE NOTES IT JUST AN
OBSERVATION THAT- EVEN AS- THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
DROPPED OUR- REFUGEE ACCEPTANCE
TO RECORD LOWS WE ALSO PURSUING
POLICIES TO GENERATE MORE
REFUGEES AROUND THE WORLD. MOST
RECENTLY IN THE MIDDLE EAST SO
WE CAN SPEAK ABOUT THAT. AREA
THE SO I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD AND. AND I GUESS
THE ONE SLIGHT WE DIDN'T HAVE
IN FRONT OF US BUT YOU ABOUT-
WHERE PEOPLE DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES A FOURTH SO- I GUESS
AN OBSERVATION WOULD BE IS THAT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF OUR STATE IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
IMMIGRANTS ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION WOULD
ACTUALLY BE DROPPING. RIGHT
IT'S ONLY BECAUSE OF
IMMIGRATION THAT WE ARE.
CONTINUING OUR GROWTH AND IN
FACT I KNOW THIS IS A WORKFORCE
COMMISSION BUT YOU KNOW WE
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT JOSH UP
FUTURE SHORTAGES. AND OUR WORK
FORCE AND VARIETY DIFFERENT
SECTORS. I CAN YOU SPEAK TO-
THE ROLE OF IMMIGRATION IN
TERMS OF SUSTAINING OUR
ECONOMY- IN TERMS OF WHERE. AND
WE OFTEN DO TALK ABOUT MANY
IMMIGRANTS. DO END UP THEY'LL
START OFF AND LOW WAGE AND-
SERVICE SECTOR POSITIONS BUT
ACTUALLY IF WHAT HAPPENS BOTH
THEIR OWN PROGRESSION AND UNDER
FAMILY AS WELL. AND IT IS IT'S
BASICALLY PART OF THE ENGINE
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR CONTINUING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE AT LEAST ACTUALLY
SAID NO MORE IMMIGRANTS WE
ACTUALLY OF. THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION SORT OF GOT THE
LEAST PHILOSOPHICALLY THEIR
WAY- WHAT. IMPACT WOULD THAT
HAVE ON- THE CONNIE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTRY. YES
IMMIGRANTS AT SUCH A GREAT
POINT THAT YOU- BRING UP SENATE
EARTH THANK YOU IMMIGRANTS. THE
RESEARCH SHOWS CONSISTENTLY
THAT IMMIGRANTS REVITALIZE
ECONOMIES IMMIGRANTS-
CONTRIBUTE TO THE INNOVATION IN
COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANTS START
BUSINESSES AT HIGHER RATES
NATIVE BORN- SO IMMIGRANTS.
FUNDAMENTALLY ARE AN ADDED
BENEFIT TO ECONOMIES AND
ESPECIALLY TO CALIFORNIA AND
ALLEYS ECONOMY- DECIDED YOU
DIDN'T HAVE WHICH- PROVIDE TO
YOU SHOWS THAT OVER HALF OF
PEOPLE EMPLOYED IN CONSTRUCTION
MANUFACTURING AND TRADE
SERVICES- WHOLESALE TRADE ARE
IMMIGRANTS. THESE ARE SOME OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL SECTORS THAT UP
HOLD OUR STATE AND THAT ARE
SEEING- GROWTH AS WELL AND SO
IMMIGRANTS ARE FOR PHIL AS AN
ESSENTIAL NEED. THAT OUR STATE
HAS WHAT'S ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT IS ARE THE CHILDREN
OF IMMIGRANTS SO THE CHILL. ARE
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IS WHY INVEST
IN THE CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS
REALLY IS A REALLY IMPORTANT.
IF YOU WANT TO INVEST IN THE
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS IF YOU
INVEST IN THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA YOU INVEST IN
PARENTS. YOU PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY. AND STICK BETTER
BOB YOU PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PARENTS TO NATURAL. ALL THE.
BENEFITS STREAM DOWN ITS TREND
MY. ECONOMIC INTEGRATION IT HAS
IMPACTS ON THE EDUCATION OF THE
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
THERE FOR- ATTAIN IT BETTER
PAYING JOBS HIGHER STATUS JOBS
AND SO FORTH SO IMMIGRANTS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THE ECONOMY OF
COURSE IMMIGRANTS IN THEIR
CHILDREN ARE MUCH MORE THAN
THEIR ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS.
RIGHT THEY'RE ALSO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE CIVIC VITALITY OF OUR
STATE AND. MORE NO I APPRECIATE
THAT ANSWER I KNOW THAT
UNFORTUNATELY OFTENTIMES
RHETORIC AGAINST IMMIGRATION IS
BASED ON A FIXED PIE- WELL
THEY'RE COMPETING TO TAKING
JOBS AWAY FROM US WHAT THEY'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT IS HOW
IMMIGRANTS ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE SIZE OF THE PIE. THAT'S
RIGHT SO THE AXIS ACKLEY RIGHT
AND SO WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT.
BEFORE LEYVA LOOKING AT WHAT'S
BEST FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. ALL
CATHLEEN WHETHER IMMIGRANT OR
NATIVE BORN WHERE ELSE THEN WE
NEED TO THOSE ARE THE POLICIES
WE NEED TO PURSUE AND I THINK
THAT'S I APPRECIATE AGAIN THIS
IS. THANK YOU. THIS IS ALSO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS FOR CHILDREN THAT-
AGAIN YEAH AND IT IS ABOUT
POLICIES THAT. IMPROVE THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS WHICH IS
YOU KNOW WHICH IS. INCLUDES THE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH WE HAVE OUR
CHILDREN GROW UP AND AS WELL AS
THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO PROVIDE THEM SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWER THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION YOU MADE A COMMENT
TOWARDS THE END OF YOUR
PRESENTATION. SUGGESTING THAT-
MUNICIPALITIES EVEN COULD HAVE
DIFFERING POLICIES. AND A STATE
POLICY MAKERS I THINK WE TEND
TO FOCUS ON. BEAT WRITER WRONG
OR INDIFFERENT. YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT
ALL APPROPRIATELY ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO BECAUSE
I WAS INTRIGUED BY YOUR COMMENT
TO GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE- OF. YOU
KNOW POLICY THAT THAT YOU THINK
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE- TO VERY
BASED ON MUNICIPALITY. WELL
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU'RE PUTTING
ME ON THE SPOT I'M SORRY. I WAS
STRUCK AS I THOUGHT. VERTICALLY
IN IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRATION AND
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS FOR THE
CHILD'S WELL BEING I JUST YEAH
SO I ASSUMED I WAS MISSING
SOMETHING YEAH SO POLICIES ARE
EFFORTS FOR EXAMPLE AROUND
NATURALIZATION COULD VERY RIGHT
MUNICIPALITIES AND WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE STATE AT THE CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF AN IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION WE KNOW WHERE THE
ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZE
POPULATION ACTUALLY RESIDES.
AND WE HAVE THAT DATA EVEN BY
CAN TO CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT-
SO POLICY IS MY VERY I HAVE
MORE RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE
MIGHT BE PUT INTO
NATURALIZATION EFFORTS AT A
CITY LEVEL GOT IT FIRST IS-
ANOTHER CITY WHICH MIGHT BE
MORE- FOCUSED ON- MIKE MIGHT
CREATE POLICIES. AROUND.
ECONOMIC INTEGRATION I GOT IT
SO IT IS BASED ON THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY GOT YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU YOUR AVAILABLE
ACCOUNT THE THING UP BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GIVING
US KIND OF OUR BASE LINE SO WE
ARE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE HISTORY OF THE CITY THAT WE
LIVE IN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ACTIVATE SO MUCH. FOR COMING.
I'M GONNA ASK THE SECOND PANEL
TO COME ON AND TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND WHILE I DO THAT WE'VE BEEN
JOINED WITH THIS IS A VERY.
POPULAR SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING- TODAY GERMAN. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER ALL THE ELECTED TO-
WERE GENEROUS ENOUGH TO SEND
YOUR STAFF WHICH IS A GOOD
THING BECAUSE THAT MEANS.
INFORMATION WILL BE SHARED
BROADLY- TWO OF MY ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLYWOMAN AUTUMN
BURKE AND A SOMETHING WOMAN.
SYDNEY COUNT MIKE OR DAD HAVE
STAFF HERE CAESAR MONTOYA. AND
ROBERT PULLIN MILES THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. IF YOU'RE
FOLLOWING ALONG YOUR AGENDA YOU
KNOW THAT PANEL TO WILL FOCUS
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT IN M.
AGAIN CHILDREN. WE ARE JOINED
TODAY BY MARCELA RELEASE WHO
WILL BE PROVIDING INFORMATION
ABOUT FUNDING FOR IMMIGRATION
SERVICES- SHE IS HERE
REPRESENTING SHE IS THE BRANCH
CHIEF OF THE IMMIGRATION AND
REFUGEES PROGRAM BRANCH WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. NAME MAILLOT.
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
ELIGIBILITY AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES MISS
SMALLS PRESENTATION WILL FOCUS
ON WHAT WE DID AT THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR WHICH IS EXPANDING ACCESS-
TO CHILDREN UNDER NINETEEN-
REGARDLESS OF STATUS ON WHAT WE
DID THIS YEAR'S RESPECT AS
WHICH WAS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
MEDICARE AL FOR NOW YOUNG
ADULTS AGAIN REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS SO WE'RE
GONNA HERE TODAY HOW THAT
EXPANSION WENT- FOR THE UP TO
NINETEEN YEAR OLDS AND THEIR
PLANS ON A- GO FORWARD BASIS.
AND FINALLY WE'VE BEEN JOINED
BY DAVID O'BRIEN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WHO PROVIDE THE
LATEST INFORMATION ON FINANCIAL
AID TO HELP STUDENTS KNOW WHAT
IS AVAILABLE TO THEM TO ALLOW
THEM TO OBTAIN A HIGHER
EDUCATION DEGREE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US YOU CAN DECIDE WHO
GOES FIRST WE'RE WE'RE OPEN.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU MISTER
LEWIS THIS RELEASE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR PAN
SENATOR ALLEN AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR HOSTING THIS CONVERSATION
AND TO ALL OF YOU IN THE
AUDIENCE HERE AT PRESENT IN
THIS ROOM AND WHO ARE LISTENING
TO THE DODD LIVE STREAM FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THIS
CONVERSATION- MY NAME IS
MARCELLA RUIZ AND I AM THE
BRANCH CHIEF WITH- IMMIGRATION
REFUGEE PROGRAMS BRANCH WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. IN OUR BRANCH-
WE ADMINISTER THE REFUGEE
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH
IS A FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM
THAT HAS ASSISTED IN SUPPORTING
THE INTEGRATION OF REFUGEE AND
REFUGEE FAMILIES FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS- WE ALSO
ADMINISTER MAINLY STATE FUNDED
IMMIGRATION PROGRAMS WHICH ARE.
MAINLY SUPPORT PRO BONO LEGAL
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO I WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
ADMINISTERS BUT BEFORE I. FOCUS
ON THOSE PROGRAMS I WOULD LIKE
I HAD TO SPEND SOME TIME
LIFTING UP SOME OF THE DATA AND
FEDERAL POLICIES- THAT ARE
CENTRAL TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
HOW WE THINK ABOUT OUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
AND USE. I'M I THINK THAT IT'S
ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT TO GROUND
OURSELVES AND IN THE IN THE
DATA CONVERSATION SO GREATLY
APPRECIATE DOCTOR BY YAHOO'S
PRESENTATION- A FOR CREATING
THAT CONTACTS FOR US TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION- I THINK
WHETHER. YOU'RE APPROACHING THE
CONVERSATION AROUND IMMIGRATION
POLICY THROUGH AN EQUITY LANDS
OR THROUGH AN EFFICACY LANDS
THE DEMOGRAPHICS IN CALIFORNIA
SIMPLY COMPEL THAT WE ARE VERY
INTENTIONAL IN THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE DO OR DON'T SERVE THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. SO AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. TWENTIES
POPULATION IS ROUGHLY FORTY
MILLION AND A QUARTER OF THAT
POPULATION IS FOREIGN BORN ONE
OF THE CRITICAL FACTS THAT WE
OPERATE WITHIN IN THINKING
ABOUT OUR PROGRAMS AND OUR
POLICIES ARE THAT ONE TWO
CHILDREN 50% OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. HAVE A FOREIGN BORN
PARENT AND ONCE AGAIN AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE PARENTS TO
HAVE SOME SORT OF LEGAL STATUS.
BUT WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS OF THE
AS OF OUR COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
OR WHO ARE BEING PUT AT RISK OF
BEING UNDOCUMENTED BECAUSE OF
CHANGES IN FEDERAL POLICY. SO
TO THAT END THERE ARE TWO OTHER
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS THAT I-
OTHER THREE OTHER SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KEEP IN
MIND IN THIS CONVERSATION. AT
THE TIME THAT- THE CURRENT
FEDERAL BUT MENSURATION
ANNOUNCED THE AT THE DOCK A
PROGRAM THERE WERE ROUGHLY
ABOUT A QUARTER OF A MINUTE AND
DOCTOR RECIPIENTS CALIFORNIA.
JUST THE RECIPIENTS DOESN'T
INCLUDE. FAMILIES THAT. MEANS
OF THE THAT SUPPORT BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES THEY THEY MAY BE THE
ONLY PERSON IN THEIR IN THEIR
FAMILY WITH WITH LEGAL STATUS
AND ABILITY TO WORK LEGALLY. IN
IN THE UNITED STATES. I'M.
ANSON'S DHAKA HAS ENDED THEY
HAVE NOW THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WOULD HAVE
BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR DHAKA BUT FOR
THE END OF THE PROGRAM BY THE
BY THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE ALSO ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND- BENEFICIARIES OF A
PROGRAM CALLED TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS- MANY OF THEM
WHO HAVE LIVED IN THE COUNTRY
FOR MANY YEARS. AND THEN
FINALLY A SPECIAL NO I THINK TO
LOS ANGELES COUNTY THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF UNACCOMPANIED
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHO HAVE
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES-
FLEEING MILEY CONDITIONS IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRIES MAINLY
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA. LAST YEAR
THERE WERE EIGHT THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS PLACED IN
IN CALIFORNIA WITH ROUGHLY 42%
OF THEM PLACED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. I'M WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
FEW FEDERAL POLICIES THAT ARE
SPECIAL NOTES ADD TO- IMMIGRANT
YOUTH IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES- I OFTEN
REFER TO THE POLICIES AROUND
CHILD SEPARATION AND CHANGES
TO- A RULING CALLED FLOREZ- AS
TWO SIDES OF ONE COIN CHILD
SEPARATION I THINK MANY OF YOU
IN THE AUDIENCE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH WHICH WAS WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ENGAGED IN LAST YEAR
WHERE THE PARENTS ARRIVING WITH
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN FOR CHARGE
WITH A WITH THE- WITH THE CRIME
AND THEREFORE THEY WERE THEY
WERE DETAINED AND THEIR
CHILDREN WERE SEPARATED FROM
THEM THIS RANGE FROM FROM
HOUSTON ADOLESCENT STAGE TWO
TODDLERS AND INFANTS. AFTER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ENDED THAT
PRACTICE THE THEM PURSUED
ANOTHER POLICY THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE EXPANSION OF FAMILY
DETENTION FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND ALLOW PERHAPS
FOR THE INDEFINITE DETENTION OF
CHILDREN ALONG WITH THEIR
FAMILIES NOW BOTH OF THOSE
POLICIES ARE ARE ARE CURRENTLY
ENJOYING TO BUT THERE IS STILL
SOME EVIDENCE THAT THERE ARE
STILL SOME CHILD SEPARATION
THAT ISN'T THAT IS MONNING AT
THE BORDER. ALSO IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED DHAKA AND TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS AND OVER THE
LAST TWO DIGITS YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN PRIEST A REMOVAL EFFORTS
THAT ARE MORE INDISCRIMINATE
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
PARKING ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE CRIMINAL
CERTAIN CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
THE ENFORCEMENT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAS BEEN RATHER
INDISCRIMINATE OFTEN RESULTING
IN IN DETECTION LONG TERM
DETENTION. OF HEADS OF
HOUSEHOLD. FINALLY IT WAS
MENTIONED ALREADY OTHER PARTS
SEE THAT IS REALLY CRITICAL FOR
THE WELL BEING OF FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN IS THE PUBLIC CHARGE
POLICY. PUBLIC CHARGE POLICY
HAS THE INTENT OF RESTRICTING
LEGAL IMMIGRATION IT IS
CURRENTLY IN JOINED BY I
BELIEVE. AS OF LAST FRIDAY FIVE
FEDERAL COURTS. BUT WHAT WE ARE
REALLY CONCERNED WITH THAT HAVE
ALREADY SEEN THE EVIDENCE OF
THIS IS IT'S NOTED IN THE IN
THE STATE ACTION AGAINST THIS
THIS POLICY IS THE CHILLING
EFFECT AND THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN PEOPLE WHO ARE OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE FOR PUBLIC BENEFITS
REALLY CRITICAL IMPORTANT
BENEFIT PUBLIC BENEFITS. THAT
CALIFORNIA IS- PROMOTING
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THOSE
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL TO THE WELL BEING OF
OUR FAMILIES THE FOR GO THOSE
BENEFITS FOR THEM SO EVEN IF
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE OR FOR THEIR
U. S. CITIZEN CHILDREN. M.
NOTING I ONLY HAVE TWO MINUTES.
SO I WANNA TALK VERY BRIEFLY
ABOUT THAT THE STATE'S RESPONSE
IN THE STATE'S RESPONSE IS
REALLY ONE OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION SO IN THE FACE OF
THIS YEAH. MORE INTENT
ENFORCEMENT AND- LIMITATION OF
BOTH- BOTH THAT UNLAWFUL AND
LAWFUL IMMIGRATION THE STATE IS
OPERATING AN IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION THAT. THAT IS
FOCUSED ON WELCOMING IMMIGRANTS
AND ALSO CREATING PROGRAMS THAT
WE KNOW ARE CRITICAL FOR THE
LONG TERM WELL BEING AND
INTEGRATION OF IMMIGRANT YOUTH
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. AT THE DEPARTMENT WE
ADMINISTERED THE LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHICH I'VE I'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED- THE LARGEST
PROGRAMS THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM WHICH IS ROUGHLY A
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WITH THE- ABOUT A
THIRD OF THAT INVESTMENT
HAPPENING HERE. IN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND THAT
SUPPORTS NATURALIZATION
SERVICES WHICH WE HEARD FROM
THE EARLIER PRESENTATION ARE SO
CRITICAL FOR IMMIGRATION LAW
SUPPORTS REMOVAL DEFENSE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING
DEPORTATION IT ALSO SUPPORTS-
DOC I SERVICES. WE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS TALK TO SERVICES AND-
THIS YEAR WE ARE EXPANDING
SERVICES ON TO HIGHER ED
CAMPUSES WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE C. S. USE AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN OUR
SERVICES PARTNERS TO DELIVER
THOSE SERVICES ON ON CALLOUSED.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. THE OTHER
SIDE OF OUR WORK IS ENSURING
THAT OUR PROGRAMS WHICH WE
ADMINISTER ACTUALLY REACH
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS THAT
THEY'RE INTENDED TO SERVE THAT
WE ARE ENSURING ACCESS AND
EFFECTIVE DELIVERY OF SERVICE
SO JUST KNOW A COUPLE OF THOSE
PROGRAMS- CAL FRESH COVERAGE IS
CRITICAL. IT'S A CRITICAL ANTI
POVERTY MEASURE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- THIS YEAR WE
HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING WITH
THE WICK PROGRAM IN THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAM- TO EXPLORE
HOW WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY ACCESSIBLE TO
BRING COMMUNITIES. AND WITH OUR
NEW HOME VISITING INITIATIVE WE
HAVE BEEN RATHER INTENTIONAL
MAKING SURE THAT HOMELESS
THERE'S- ACTUALLY GOING THE
HOME. AND IF YOU WANT TO JUST.
OTHER WHO WHO MAKE THAT HELP.
AS SERVICE IS PART. I'M THAT'S
SAD ENCLOSING I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE STATE AND
SUPPORTING- IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION EFFORTS I AM
GRATEFUL TO ALL OF THE PARTNERS
WERE ACTUALLY DELIVERING THE
SERVICES ON THE GROUND MANY OF
WHOM ARE HERE TODAY- I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE PUBLIC FOR YOUR
INTEREST INTO THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY THE FAMILIES WHO MAKE
CALIFORNIA SUCH A THRIVING
STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WERE. AS WE LEAD INTO HIS
MORALS PRESENTATION YOU KNOW
THAT THE CHILLING EFFECT FOR US
AS POLICY MAKERS IS SO
FRUSTRATING WHEN WE DO ALL THE
WORK TO INTRODUCE THE BILLS
MANY OF WHICH ARE REFERENCED IN
THIS AMAZING BACKGROUND OF THE
WHITE PAPER THAT I HOPE YOU ALL
TAKEN READ- IT'S JUST. I SO YOU
SAW THIS THESE SIDE BARS TO.
WHICH I HAVE TO DO TO KEEP FROM
JUST. I DON'T KNOW IMPLODING
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CHILLING EFFECT IN AND TO HEAR
THAT STATISTIC WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO
INTERNALIZE. EIGHT THOUSAND ON
ACCOMPANIED MINORS. IS JUST
STRIKING. AND WHAT WE MUST
CONTINUE TO DO TO PROVIDE THEM-
SAFE HARBOR. THANK YOU MS
MORROW. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
AGAIN RENEE MAILLOT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN IN OUR
DEPARTMENT WE ADMINISTER THE
MEDIC HELP PROGRAM AND I HAVE
THE DISTINCT PLEASURE OF
OVERSEEN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS AND
ELIGIBILITY AND THE DEPARTMENT.
AND SO I HAD A WALL WITH MY
STAFF IN TERMS OF THE TWO
EXPANSIONS THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL I'M MITCHELL HAD
MENTIONED SO AS PART OF THE
BUDGET I HAVE FOUR TWENTY
NINETY FOUR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY. APPROXIMATELY
NINETY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
WAS APPROPRIATED FOR A FOR
BRINGING INTO COVERAGE
APPROXIMATELY NINETY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS- BETWEEN THE AGES
OF NINETEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS INTO FULL SCOPE COVERAGE
INTO THE MEDICAL PROGRAM. THIS
NEW POLICY WILL BE EFFECTIVE
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND ONCE OUR LEGIBILITY AND
ENROLLMENT SYSTEMS ARE READY
THEN WE'LL START WITH THE
ACTUAL INVOLVEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS. THIS BUILDS UPON
THE SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE HAD THAT WAS REFERENCED-
WITH THE PYRE BUDGET WHERE WE
PULLED IN CHILDREN UP TO THE
AGE OF NINETEEN REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. M. FOR THE
POLICY AS WELL AS THIS NEW
POLICY THAT WE'RE GOING BORN TO
BE IMPLEMENTING. UNDER SB
SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE ESTIMATED
A PROBABLY APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE IMPACTED
AND OF THE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WE ALREADY
HAD A ROLE IN THE MEDIC HOW
PROGRAM APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. AND THEN THE
BALANCE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE ELIGIBLE
BUT NOT INVOLVED IN OUR
PROGRAM. WE ACTUALLY DID THE
I'M IMPLEMENTATION OF SP
SEVENTY FIVE WE HAD AT OUR PEAK
ENROLLMENT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE ENROLLED IN COVERAGE AND
THEN LA COUNTY ALONE WE HAVE.
I'M APPROXIMATELY FORTY ONE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BENEFITED FROM THAT POLICY. IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM TODAY WE
SERVE JUST APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN MILLION INDIVIDUALS
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT
POPULATION IS SERVED HERE IN A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. SO AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS NEW POLICY OF
EXPANSION WE WOULD SIMILARLY
EXPECT THAT ABOUT A THIRD
ELIGIBLE POPULATION THAT WOULD
COME INTO COVERAGE WOULD BE
SERVED HERE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AND AGAIN OF THE NINETY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WE EXPECT
TO COME INTO COVERAGE ABOUT 75%
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
ALREADY ENROLLED IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM IN RESTRICTED
SCOPE COVERAGE. LEÓN UPON THE
WORK THAT WE DID WITH SB
SEVENTY FIVE. BEEN WORKING WITH
ADVOCATES AND ARE COUNTING
PARTNERS IN TERMS OF THIS
EXPANSION SO WE ARE WORKING ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF NOTICES I
HAVE PROVIDED IN THE PACKAGES
THE FIRST NOTICE THAT WILL BE
GOING OUT TO ARE IMPACTED
POPULATION. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING ON DEVELOPING-
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE TRANSITION AND
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
AN ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT
PLAN FOR INDIVIDUALS AND THIS
WILL COME TO LAY OUT THE- THE
LANDSCAPE FOR THE WORK THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING FOR THE
TRANSITION. THERE WILL ALSO BE
A NOTICE- GOING AND SO THE
FIRST NOTICE THAT WILL GO OUT
WILL BE IN JAN IN NOVEMBER IT
WILL BE A GENERAL NOTICE
INFORMING THE IMPACT THE
POPULATION OF THE CHANGE THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. AND THEN OUR
COUNTIES WILL WORK ACTUALLY
AFFECTION WAIT THE CHANGE SO
PEOPLE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM BETTER
M. RESTRICTED SCOTT MEDIC COW
BY THE USE OF AID CODES WILL
THEM IDENTIFY THE POPULATION
THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THIS
POLICY. CONNIE SWAP BOTTOM MIKE
LEE EMBOLDENED TO FULL SCOPE
COVERAGE WHERE THAT COVERAGE
WILL TURN. JANUARY ONE SO
INDIVIDUALS WILL GET A NOTICE
IN NOVEMBER THEY WILL THEN GET
A SUBSEQUENT NOTICE AROUND
MIDDLE LATE DECEMBER. TELLING
THEM ABOUT THE CHANGE IN THEIR
COVERAGE COM JANUARY ONE AND
THEN THAT WILL BE FOLLOWED UP
BY ANOTHER NOTICE FROM OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS BECAUSE
DEPENDING UPON THE COUNTIES
THAT THEY WERE SIDE AND- I'LL
HAVE TO THEN SELECT A MANAGED
CARE PLAN ARE AUTOMATICALLY BE
ENROLLED IN A MANAGED CARE
PLAN. IN THEIR COUNTY BASED
UPON OF THE CONTRACT AND THE
MANAGED CARE SYSTEM. AS WE I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
POLICY WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS WE DO
HAVE A US WEB PAGE THAT IS
DEDICATED TO THIS EXPANSION AND
THAT IS WHERE WE'LL POST ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
RELATIVE TO THIS EXPANSION THE
NOTICE IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS DEVELOPING THAT WILL BE USED
BY THE COUNTIES OR THAT WILL BE
SENT OUT BY THE DEPARTMENT WILL
BE TRANSLATED INTO THE
THRESHOLD LANGUAGES THAT ARE
USED BY MEDIC HOW WE HAVE
NINETEEN THRESHOLD LANGUAGES
PLUS. WHICH ALSO- INCLUDES
ENGLISH AND I'M ALSO WORKING TO
HELP ENSURE THAT THE-
ELIGIBILITY AND MOMENT SYSTEMS
THAT THAT- ELIGIBILITY POLICIES
HAVE BEEN CHANGED TO THEN
EFFECTUATE THAT COVERAGE THOUGH
COME JANUARY ONE ANYONE KNEW
THAT IS APPLYING FOR HANNAH CAL
PROGRAM TELL THEM BE PUT INTO
THAT FULL SCOPE COVERAGE TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS. OF THE POLICY.
I'M IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO US
IN TERMS OF EDUCATING PEOPLE
ABOUT THIS POLICY AND I THINK
TO THE POINTS MADE REGARDING
PUBLIC CHARGE WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS RATHER THAN IN SEEING YOU
WAIT FEAR FOR PEOPLE. IS POINT
PEOPLE TO A PLACE OF
INFORMATION BECAUSE KNOWLEDGE
IS POWER SO THROUGH THE-
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY WE HAVE
DEVELOPED A PUBLIC CHARGE GUIDE
FOR PEOPLE TO REFER TO. AND
THEY GIVE SOME FACTUAL
INFORMATION FOR PEOPLE AND SO
WHAT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE LOOKING AT
COVERAGE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT POLICY GOAL
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION IT IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT STEP IN TERMS
OF THIS EXPANSION POLICY OF
LOOKING AT COVERAGE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THE DIFFERENT PATHWAYS THAT
THEY IN. PEOPLE CAN CALL THEY
CAN GO TO THEIR MAIN OFFICES
THEY CAN APPLY ONLINE THEY CAN
USE OUR PAPER APPLICATION THE
PAPER APPLICATION IS. ALSO IN
ALL THRESHOLD LANGUAGES AS WELL
AS IN LARGE PRINT WE ALSO HAVE
IN A MOMENT THE SISTERS IN THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT CAN HELP
PEOPLE TO ENROL. AND THEN
ANOTHER- ACT OF THE BUDGET WAS
TO MAKE AVAILABLE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER A TWO YEAR
TIME PERIOD. FOR HEALTH
NAVIGATORS TO HELP PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS IN OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO ALSO- CONDUCT
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES TO HELP
INFORM PEOPLE ABOUT COVERAGE
OPTIONS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH INCLUDES MEDI
CAL AND COVER CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN THAT MONEY CAN BE USED TO
HELP ESPECIALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE
HEAVY IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
THEY CAN TARGET THOSE POPULAR
AS FOR THOSE DOLLARS. AND
HELPING THEM TO UNDERSTAND
COVERAGE OPTIONS THAT. TO THEM
AND THE RESOURCES THAT THEY CAN
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF AND
LEARNING ABOUT THE COVERAGE
OPTIONS AND OUR PROGRAM. AND
WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK. AS I
LISTEN TO YOU I'M OFTEN
REMINDED THAT YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE OUR RULES THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO APPROPRIATING
LEGISLATE. THE ROLE OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT'S IS TO
OPERATIONALIZE AND YOU KNOW OUT
REACH IS IT REALLY TIP AT
TYPICALLY AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST IN TERMS OF WHAT WE DO.
YOU KNOW COVER NOT COMING UP
WITH THOSE. COLDS IN OF ITSELF
AND THEN TAKE YOU OFF FOR EVERY
VEHICLE THAT THINKING YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW I MEAN TO DO YOUR WORK
AND SO THAT'S WHY THE
NAVIGATION FUNDING AND
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ALSO HAVE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
WITH COMMUNITY THAN GOVERNMENT
DOES. AND SO I'M NOT I SEE SO
MANY PARTNERS IN THE ROOM I C.
STAFF FROM SAINT JOHN'S CLINIC
AND OTHERS IN THE ROOM BECAUSE
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS ARE CRITICAL
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HELP
US BY DOING THE JOB. AROUND OUT
REACH TO HELP WITH TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THE CHILLING EFFECT-
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE GUY THAT'S
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE- WITH
REGARD TO PUBLIC CHARGE HOW TO
PEOPLE AT AS THAT. SO THE GUY
CAN BE ACCESSED BY THE-
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ON THEIR
WEBSITE I'M AND WE CAN ALSO
MAKE THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE
I'M I'LL GIVE YOU THE WEBSITE
THAT YOU CAN ALSO I'LL LOOK BUT
YOU CAN USE TO GO TO THAT. THE
GUY DIRECTLY. IT'S H. T. T. P.
S. COLIN. I. TWO BACKSPLASHES
IMMIGRANT GUIDE DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S AVAILABLE- ON THE
WEBSITE AS WELL TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
A MISTER O'BRIEN. THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CENTER MITCHELL AND SENATORS
PAN ALLEN MY NAME IS DAVID
O'BRIEN AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE'RE SO PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO BE HERE- TODAY TO
SPEAK TO ALL OF YOU- A LITTLE
BIT. ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THE INVESTMENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE. AN
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR THE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT POPULATION. SO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADMINISTERING
THE STATES- MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR STATE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM. WHICH IS
COMPRISED ENTIRELY OF GRANTS TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO HELP
AFFORD COLLEGE- WE DON'T DO
STUDENT LOANS EVERY DOLLAR WE
DISBURSE IS EVERY STUDENTS TO
KEEP. NEVER HAS TO BE PAID BACK.
STUFF WAS DONE EXCELLENT JOB IN
THE GRAND PRIX FOR YOUR
REFERENCE SENATOR PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT WE OFFER AND
FINANCIAL AID- STARTING ON PAGE
THIRTY FIVE FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE HAVE ALSO
PROVIDED A ONE PAGER THAT I HE
WAS INCLUDE THE PACKETS. WITH A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION SERVICES AS WELL AS
OUR CONTACT INFORMATION. ON
THERE BUT- REALLY WANTED TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO YOUR STAFF
AND THE COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION IN THE BACKGROUND-
SO A BASIC PRINCIPLE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS NOW. HAS
BEEN THE STUDENTS IMMIGRATION
STATUS SHOULD NOT BE WHAT HOLDS
THEM BACK FROM PURSUING A
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY EDUCATION.
AND THE STATE FIRST BEGAN TO
DEMONSTRATE THIS PRINCIPLE IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE WHEN WE LED
THE NATION IN PASSING- WHAT
WHAT WE CALL SIMPLY BILL FIVE
FORTY OR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY.
WHICH I DECLARED THAT ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS COULD
ATTEND OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. AND PAY THE IN
STATE TUITION RATE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ARE
ENTITLED TO PAY WHEN THE
ATTEND- OUR INSTITUTIONS.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY THE DREAM
OF GOING HIGHER EDUCATION WAS
STILL OUT OF REACH FOR SO MANY
OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AT
THE TIME. BECAUSE IT WAS ON
AFFORDABLE- IN THE TWO
THOUSANDS A SERIES OF STATE
BUDGET CUTS LEAD OUR
UNIVERSITIES TO RAISE TUITION
SEVERAL TIMES. AND IT BECAME
APPARENT THAT- ALTHOUGH WE HAD-
OPEN THE DOOR FOR SO MANY OF
OUR DOCUMENTS SINCE WE'RE
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY WERE GONNA. BE
NEEDING. TO AFFORD AN ACCESS
AND THRIVE IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
SO TEN YEARS LATER IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED WHAT WE CALL THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT WHICH IS
TWO BILLS- AUTHORED BY- ONE OF
THE- ONE OF THE GREATEST
LEADERS IN THIS SPACE
CALIFORNIA'S EVER SEEN THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIL STUDIO. AND
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT-
CREATED AN APPLICATION OF
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION. AND SAID THAT
STUDENTS WHO WERE ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS UNDER EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY COULD NOW GET STATE
FINANCIAL AID MAINLY THROUGH
OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS-
THE SECOND LARGEST FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM IN THE UNITED STATES
AFTER THE FEDERAL PELL GRANT
PROGRAM. AND SO SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE DREAM ACT FOR
PRES WE'RE PLEASED TO SAY THAT
OVER TEN THOUSAND DREAMER
STUDENTS HAVE ATTENDED COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND RECEIVE STATE FINANCIAL
AID. TO HELP OFFSET THOSE COSTS.
HOWEVER AS UNFORTUNATELY IS
OFTEN THE CASE WITH THIS
POPULATION WE STILL HAVE
POLITICAL CONSTRAINTS IN PLACE.
THAT ARE KEPT US FROM THE THAT
CREATED AN INEQUITABLE
SITUATION VIRTUALLY WHEN IT
CAME TO FINANCIAL AID. SO VERY
RECENTLY JUST THIS PAST YEAR IN
FACT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR WERE PLEASED TO SAY.
TOOK TWO MAJOR STEPS TOWARDS
RECTIFYING THAT AN EQUITY AND
PROVIDING- ADDITIONAL SERVICES
TO OUR DREAMER POPULATION. THAT
WILL HELP THEM AFFORD AND
THRIVE IN COLLEGE SO PART OF IT
HAD TO DO WITH WHAT WE CALL OUR
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
THE DREAM ACT- OPENED UP CAL
GRANTS FOR DREAMERS STUDENTS
WHO- HAD RECENTLY GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL WHICH IS GREAT
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS WE KNOW COMES STRAIGHT
FROM HIGH SCHOOL. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A LARGE AND GROWING
POPULATION OF WHAT WE SOMETIMES
CALL ADULT LEARNERS FOR
RETURNING STUDENTS. WHICH
INDIVIDUALS WHO FOR WHATEVER
REASON DID NOT ATTEND COLLEGE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
OR MIGHT HAVE ATTENDED SOME
COLLEGE BUT SOMETIMES HAD TO
DROP OUT DUE TO THE HIGH COST.
AND THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT WE CALL ENTITLEMENT MEANS
NOT ENTITLED TO A STATE CAL
GRANT. THEY CAN'T COMPETE FOR A
LIMITED POOL OF CAL GRANTS IF
THE NOT A RECENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE. AND THE ORIGINAL
DREAM ACT EFFECTIVELY LIMITED
DREAMERS ABILITY TO RECEIVE
WHAT WE ALL THESE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANTS SO IT SHOT OUT A LOT
OF ADULT LEARNERS AND RETURNING
STUDENTS FROM GETTING SICK
EIGHT. THIS YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY STATE BUDGET
ACT REMOVE THOSE RESTRICT. AND
ACTION CONTAINS EXPLICIT.
LANGUAGE DREAMERS IN A BEFORE
FORTY STUDENTS. ENTITLED TO
FULL. BODY WHEN IT COMES TO
COMPETING IN APPLYING FOR ALL
STATE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS.
TIME SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO SEE THAT AND THAT IS
ALREADY PAYING DIVIDENDS WE'VE
ALREADY AWARDED- JUST YOU KNOW
SINCE THIS WENT INTO EFFECT
LAST MONTH SEVERAL HUNDRED
DREAMERS. HAVE ALREADY BEEN
AWARDED COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS
AND MORE AND MORE EVERY DAY-
ADDITIONALLY OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR SHOWED-
LEADERSHIP THIS YEAR. IN
PROVIDING ANOTHER HALF TO
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL AID FOR
OUR DREAMER STUDENTS. SO IS IT
IT'S MENTIONED- AND A LOT OF
YOU IF YOUR ADVOCATES KNOW
ALREADY DREAMERS ARE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAM SO THAT'S THE
FEDERAL PELL GRANT. FEDERAL
SUBSIDIZED STUDENT LOANS AND
FEDERAL WORK STUDY AND BECAUSE-
A LOT OF THEM PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE DHAKA
STATUS HAVE A REAL CHALLENGE IN
BEING ABLE TO. YOU KNOW FIND
WORK AND USE THAT INCOME TELL
AWESOME POSSUM HOLLY. YOU KNOW
OTHER THAN REALLY STRUGGLING
AND HAVE THAT SORT OF.
TRADITIONAL WORKING WHILE IN
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AND SO THE-
LEGISLATURE THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LEÓN MONNING. CREATED
THE DREAMER SERVER CONSENT OF
CRAP PRO. REALLY INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM THAT WE THINK SPEAKS TO
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA SO
SUPPORTED IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
IT WAS WILLING TO GET CREATIVE.
UNDER THIS PROGRAM EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE CAL
GRANTS OR DREAMERS WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO PERFORM COMMUNITY
SERVICE OR VOLUNTEER WORK- SUCH
AS INTERNSHIPS RELATED TO THEIR
MAJOR COURSE OF STUDIES. AND
RECEIVE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL AID ON
TOP OF THEIR EXISTING CALIBER
AT EIGHT. TO HELP THEM PAY FOR
COLLEGE SORT OF VERY EXCITED
FOR THIS INDUSTRY MAKE
COMMISSION IS GONNA BE ROLLING
OUT THE- THE PROGRAM LATER THIS
YEAR. WHEN I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT WELL THIS DOESN'T TOTALLY
MAKE UP FOR THE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID UNFORTUNATELY.
THE DREAMERS YOU'RE STILL NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE WE DO HOPE
THIS WILL HELP CLOSE THAT GAP
SOMEWHAT IN PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO PERFORM
VOLUNTEER SERVICE OR GET KEY
EXPERIENCE- IN A CAREER FIELD
THAT THEY MAY BE LOOKING INTO-
THROUGH AN INTERNSHIP. AND I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE THIS IS A
VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW I KNOW BUT
I WANT TO CLOSE OUT THE- WIFE
FROM MY COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE SECTORS.
REGARDING THIS CHILLING MESSAGE
IN HERE IT THE DAY AT THE
STUDENT IT CAN SHIN. SOO IT WHO
IN OUR CASE DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WANT TO FILL OUT THAT DREAM ACT
LOCATION. BYE FOR FINDING A
UNDERSTANDABLY NERVOUS ABOUT
SHARING THAT INFORMATION IS A
LOT OF PERSONAL INFORMATION IN
THEIR ARMS ABOUT SHARING THAT
WILL PICK UP AND- THERE ONE
WHETHER IT'S WORTH TAKING THE
RISK TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION. SO I WANT TO JUST
REITERATE A COUPLE OF THINGS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
NOT THE FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT WE
VALUE NO WE ARE POPULATION. WE
VALUE THE STUDENT POPULATION-
AND WITH THE STEVEN A
COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING ALL STUDENTS
INFORMATION. AND PRIVACY TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW WHEN
YOU APPLY FOR IT THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT. THAT
INFORMATION GOES TO US AND ONLY
TO US- WE AND FURTHERMORE WE'RE
WE'RE PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE
DON'T AT THIS TIME ANTICIPATE.
THAT THE RECEIPT OF FINANCIAL
AID EVEN IF THE PUBLIC CHARGE
WILL GOES INTO EFFECT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL- BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF- AS PART
OF PUBLIC CHARGE. I'M WE
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULT
CHOICES THAT THIS COMMUNITY IS
FACED WITH. BUT OUR MESSAGES
JUST IF YOU WANT TO PURSUE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO APPLY WE
HOPE YOU WILL APPLY FOR FIVE.
BILL A SEEK THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION AS RENEE STEPPING
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IT NOT
BUDGET POWER. AND HIGHER
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO GET THAT KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT POWER OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BILL THEN YOU WE'VE
INVESTED DO YOU BELONG HERE AND
WE ARE HERE TO SERVE YOU- I
WANT TO JUST CLOSE QUICKLY BY
NOTED. THAT. RICARDO ACTIVE XIN
ON THIS ONE. HERE THAT THE
NUMBER ON THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
NOT THE BEST NUMBER SO- WEBSITE
IS THERE C. S. A. C. C. SACK
DOT CA DOT G. O. V. AND WE
HAVE. A CALL CENTER A STUDENT
SUPPORT CALL CENTER WHERE IF BE
FURIOUS MISFIRING STUDENT OR
CURRENT STUDENT OR IF YOU'RE A
PARENT OF AN ASPIRING OR
CURRENT STUDENT AND YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. ABOUT HOW TO GET
FINANCIAL AID WHETHER YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE HOW TO FILL OUT THOSE
COMPLICATED FORMS. PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND CALL US THE PHONE
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
C. EIGHT GRANTS. SEE A GRANT AS
IN CAL GRANT BUT WITHOUT THE L.
I THINK IT'S TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN
TWO SIX EIGHT. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS A LINE UP OF
THOSE. BUT I ASSOCIATED WITH C.
A GRANT AND WE DO HAVE SPANISH
SPEAKING STAFF AS WELL AS
TRANSLATION SERVICE FOR SEVERAL
OTHER LANGUAGES. SO HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THAT'S PAN THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND-
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
ALL DOING TO BE SURE THAT THE
ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR- ACTUALLY GET
IMPLEMENTED. TRYING TO FOCUS
MOST OF IRAQ'S AROUND PUBLIC
CHARGE BECAUSE- THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE- CAN. FIND PAST
PROGRAMS BUT IF PEOPLE ARE
FEARFUL OF PARTAKING. THEN
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
SERVICES RIGHT CAN I GET THE
HELP- SO I GUESS THE FIRST
QUESTION FOR IN RELATION TO
SOCIAL SERVICES- AND AGAIN-
APPRECIATE- ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GOING ON DEPARTMENT. I HAD I
DID HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH US
SOME OF THE COUNTY FOLKS ARE.
AND I KNOW IT'S HARD TO TRACK
IN SOME SENSES WE DON'T ASK
PEOPLE WHAT'S YOUR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND SO FORTH TO SELL.
BUT IS ARE THERE IS THE
DEPARTMENT LOOKING AT AND
WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES AND
TRYING DEVELOPED AT LEAST SOME.
MECHANISM THERE'S TO TRY TO GET
SOME IDEA OF. HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE. NOT RENEWING SAYING THEY
WANT OFF OF PUBLIC PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FEARFUL OF THE
PUBLIC CHARGE AT THE ONE THAT
PRIDE HARDEST AS PEOPLE WHO
WOULD QUALIFY TO NEVER SIGN UP
BECAUSE THERE D. YOU KNOW IT'S
TOUGH HOW DO YOU. TRACK THAT.
BUT EVEN THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY
END WHO SAY WELL I'M REALLY
AFRAID OF PUBLIC CHART SO I GOT
TURNED DOWN I DON'T I'M OUT OF
TOWN FRESH ON TURNING AWAY. SO
FOR THIS IS THERE SOME EFFORT
TO TRY TO- WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY IS GOING TO BE ON THE
FRONT LINES TO TRY TO. GET A
SENSE OF HOW TO WHAT DEGREE
THAT'S HAPPENING AT SO I HEAR
ANECDOTALLY. BUT THE MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY TRY TO TRACK ARE
WE HAVING. ARE PEOPLE BASICALLY
TURNING DOWN SERVICES THAT WE
ARE FUNDING. SO THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES HAS BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE WITH THE
NUMBER OF PARTNERS INCLUDING
INCLUDING THE COUNTIES. TO TRY
TO MONITOR THE PARTICIPATION
RATE OF IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
AND- IF YOU LOOK AT AT SOME OF
THE LAWSUITS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD WHERE- THE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE HAVE
ATTESTED TO THE TO THE DROPPING
OF PARTICIPATION IN CERTAIN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE. PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE TO THE PUBLIC CHARGE
RULE SO THERE IS A PARTNERSHIP
THERE AND I AND I AND I WANT TO
KNOW ON SENATOR MITCHELL
MENTIONED EARLIER ALSO THAT THE
NEED FOR THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS. AND
THAT IS. PARTNERSHIPS WITH.
TRUSTED MESSENGER AND THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN AND OUT
REACH AS AS RENEE MENTIONED AND
IN THE LEGAL SERVICES. AND SO
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO BRING ALL OF
THOSE TABLES TOGETHER TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHERE
ARE WE SEEING. THE DROP IN
PARTICIPATION WHAT IS THE
EFFECTIVE- MESSAGING FOR
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES AND HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY EFFECTIVELY REACH
THOSE POPULATIONS I APPRECIATE
IT BECAUSE I THINK PART OF THE
REASON WHY COLLECTED DATA IS SO
WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHICH
RESEMBLE WHICH- WHERE DO I
TARGET OUR EFFORTS TO HAVE THE
BIG. IMPACT WHERE WHERE IS THE-
WE'RE OUT REACH FAILING. WERE
MORE SUCCESSFUL AT AND SO. AND
SO HOW DO WE- PROVIDE MORE
GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF WHERE WE
FOCUS OUR EFFORTS- BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE
UNLIMITED RESOURCES SO. WE CAN
MAKE MAXIMUM USE OUR RESOURCES.
AND THEN RIGHT I AS FAR AS
DEPART HEALTHCARE SERVICES
OBVIOUSLY IS. THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES VERY INTERESTED
IN BOTH DEPARTMENTS HERE- ALSO
EDUCATION EVEN THOUGH IT'S-
BUT- SO. IN TERMS OF SO YOU
KNOW WE PASS. AND AT THE END D.
WE'RE FINDING. COVERAGE WHERE
PEOPLE DOCUMENT IN. I'LL BE OFF
PREVIOUSLY ZERO EIGHTEEN NOW UP
TO TWENTY SIX. HOW IN ANY
TAUGHT YOU TOUCH A LITTLE BIT
ON THIS. I'M STILL CONCERNED
THAT YEAH WE HAVE A GUIDELINE
THAT PEOPLE MAY STILL BE AFRAID
TO APPLY BECAUSE OF PUBLIC
CHARGE IN FACT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE SEEN ANY OF THAT WITH
RESTRICTED MEDIC COW BECAUSE AT
LEAST WITH YEAH. SO I KNOW YOU
KNOW TAKE THOSE AND ROLLED INTO
FULL SCOPE BUT- I DON'T KNOW IF
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO ARE
DROPPING OFF AND THEN THE OTHER
THING IS THAT BECAUSE AT ONE
BIG CHALLENGES PUBLIC CHARGES A
BIT OF A MOVING TARGET IN PART
THE REASON IT'S A MOVING TARGET
IS ALSO BECAUSE WE'RE PUSHING
BACK AGAINST. SO TED NIELSEN
OFFICIALLY IS THIS TO TAKE
PLACE IN THE FIFTEENTH THERE'S
OF SUCCESSFUL LAWSUITS CETERA
AT SO CAN YOU MAYBE ALSO SPEAK
TO HOW THE PART COMMUNICATING
WITH THE COUNTY SO ON THE FRONT
LINES TO ENROLLMENT. OF THAT
THEY JUST BE VERY FRANK WE HAD
A PROBLEM BEFORE WHERE STATE
POLICY WAS THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON DHAKA. WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET
MEDIC HAL BUT BECAUSE THERE WAS
A LETTER SENT COUNTY. IS
INDICATING THAT AND TO RECALL.
HOW COMPLICATED THE- OUR
SYSTEMS ARE DE ELIGIBILITY
COMPUTER ACTUALLY REJECTED THE
DHAKA EVEN THE OUR POLICY AND
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO WORK
AROUND BUT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DIRECTION FROM THE AGENCY
COUNTIES DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
WE'RE DOING IT AND SO PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON DHAKA BEFORE WERE
APPLYING EVEN WHEN THEY
QUALIFIED THEY WERE TURNED AWAY
BY CALIPHATE BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T SO I I'M JUST BRING THAT
UP BECAUSE I'M GONNA TALK ASK
ABOUT HOUSES COMMUNICATION PATH
GOING BETWEEN. D. C. S. ANDY
COUNTIES ON THE FRONT LINES SO
THAT THE PERSON FROM THEM TO BE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT MISS
COMMUNICATING TO PEOPLE- AND-
BECAUSE ONCE PEOPLE HEAR THAT
MESSAGE FROM THEIR ELIGIBILITY
WORKER THEY WALK AWAY TO THINK-
I'M QUALIFIED HUESO- SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO HOWARD THE BEING SURE
THAT THAT COMMUNICATIONS
HAPPENING- THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND WITH THIS FREQUENCY- THE
SPECIALLY WITH POTENTIAL
CHANGES THOSE THINGS ARE MOVING.
AND WOW DE KLERK HOLLY IS THAT
LIVED TO BE SURE TO. IN THE END
THE- IS APPLYING- DOESN'T. YOU
KNOW THINK THAT THEY GET THE
YEAH. AND AS SELF THE SPEED
THAT. SO TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION
ABOUT THE DROP OFF SO ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVE BEEN DOING
IS CHECKING IN WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AS WELL AS ALSO
LOOKING AT OUR OWN DATA. WE
HAVE NOT IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
OUR IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS WE
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY APPRECIABLE
OKAY I DECLINES IN A MOMENT WE
HAVE ACTUALLY HEARD THAT THERE
ARE ACTUAL INCREASES IN THEIR
HOME AND GIVEN. THAT IN
PARTICULAR BUT FOR THAT-
POPULATION THAT'LL BE SUBJECT
TO THE NEW EXPANSION SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HEARING BUT IN TERMS
OF OUR DATA WE HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY APPRECIABLE CHANGES THAT
ARE ANY DIFFERENT. THAN ANY
OTHER POINT IN TIME WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT MEDIC HOW HOW IS
ELIGIBLE IMMIGRANT LARGE AND WE
KNOW THAT WHEN WE MAKE MORE
PEOPLE QUALIFIED EXCEED NOT
ONLY TO THE PEOPLE WHO WE AT
THE MORE PEOPLE AROUND THEM TED.
AGAIN ROLE WE JUST DIDN'T KNOW
LIKE WHICH FRESHER WAS GONNA
KOREAN OUT. GIVING SORRY YEAH.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- WE HAVE BEEN DOING
GIVEN SOME OF THE FEDERAL
POLICIES IS WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS. IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNICATION SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE I HAVE IS ONE WILL BE
PROVIDING DIRECT GUIDANCE TO
THE COUNTIES. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY'S
REGARDING THIS POLICY WORKING
WITH THE COUNTIES ON MAKING
SURE THE SYSTEMS ARE ALL
WORKING. BECAUSE WE CAN'T
IMPLEMENT THAT POLICY UNTIL THE
ACTUAL SYSTEMS ARE WORKING ON
AS WE EXPECT THEM TO WORK AND
THEN WE HAVE TO NOTIFY OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
SYSTEMS ARE READY. FOR THIS POP
THEY SHOULD. TO YOUR COMMUTE
PATIENTS KEY. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE YOU. THE
POLICY. THAT WE GIVE THEM IN
TERMS OF ART DIRECTION FOR HOW
YOU NEED TO BRING THIS.
RELATION INTERCOM. BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE NOT MISS COMMUNICATING
INFORMATION. OUR COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS ARE NOT
SAFE EXPERT ON IMMIGRATION
FRONT THEY KNOW SOME THINGS BUT
WE WANT TO POINT PEOPLE BACK
TO. THIS PUBLIC CHARGE GUIDE
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT THERE TO
BE MISCOMMUNICATION. OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY. IN THE COMMUNITIES
FOR THE COVERAGE. WHAT ARE AND
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS IN TERMS OF IF
THEY'RE GETTING QUESTION. OUR
COMPANY AND- ALSO WAS SEEN I.
THE OLD MAN OF. SCRIPT THAT CAN
BE USED FOR END OF IT. BUT IT
IN MONEY TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE WE
LEVERAGE THE. RESOURCES MAKE
AVAILABLE TO. SO. THEIR
KNOWLEDGE MAY BE SOMEWHAT
LIMITED- KNOWING THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES SQUARE NOW YOU HAVE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THEY MAY NOT
BE SO INTO READING EVEN A
TRANSLATED DOCUMENTS THERE ARE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP THEM
AND TIGHT THEY CAN TALK. TO
THAT THEY CAN GET I MEAN WE
WOULD CERTAINLY WHAT PARTNER
WITH OUR WONDERFUL PARTNERS OR
SOMEONE THERE IN THE AUDIENCE
BUT- IT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ALSO IF THE ELEGY WORKER
DOESN'T HAVE THE INFORMATION.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE WELL WHAT
LANGUAGE HE'S BECOME HANDING A
DOCUMENT- IT'S GOT IT LIKE
THERE'S GOT TO BE A HAND OFF TO
SOMEBODY WHO CAN ACTUALLY
ANSWER QUESTIONS EXPLAIN SO IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON. YES THAT IS THAT IS
PART OF THE PROCESS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE LOCAL RESOURCES IN
THE COMMUNITY SOME PART OF WHAT
SOCIAL SERVICES DOES. THEY DO
FIND- ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN
THEN HELP PROVIDE SOME ILLEGAL
ANDERSON THAT'S OF WE HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS BUT JUST ALSO IS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT URGES
DURING ASSISTANCE OR ARE WE
WORKING COUNTIES THAT COUNTIES
HAVE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN IT
WE'RE DOING. AS COLLABORATIVE
AFTER OKAY WORKING BOTH WITH
THE TOWNIES WITH- SOCIAL
SERVICES WITH ADVOCATE
ORGANIZATION SO THROUGH ALL OF
OUR VARIOUS COMMUNICATION
STREAMS WE ARE SHARING
INFORMATION WITH FOLKS. OUR
INTENT IS NOT TO GIVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. TO OUR FAMILIES
BECAUSE THIS IS OVERWHELMED. AT
LEAST ONE TO POINT PEOPLE THERE
ARE TRUSTED- GROUPS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT WORK WITH THE
IMMIGRANT POP. SO ARE IMMIGRANT
ADVOCATES THAT WE WORK WITH
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL
IN TERMS OF THE COMMUNICATION
AND HOW THEY CAN HELP TO
SUPPORT. OUR BENEFICIARIES OR
APPLICANTS THAT ARE COMING TO
THE RECOGNIZE YOUR LIMITED TIME
I LOOK FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOU MORE OF THE DETAILS.
THANK YOU. MODEL YOU BETTER BE
READY FOR THOSE BUT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS THAT. I
THINK WE JUST HAD A PRECURSOR.
SUB THREE HEARING DON'T FOCUS
ON. READY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SENATE ALLEN ANY QUESTION I'M
UNFORTUNATELY GONNA GO I GOTTA
GO SPEAK SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT I
WILL TUNE IN NOT TO THE REST OF
THE NEXT PANEL AND SHOUT OUT TO
THE BUSH IT WAS GONNA BE
SPEAKING AS WELL- BUT- BUT THIS
IS JUST FANTASTIC AND FASTING
AND I'VE JUST ASK THE CHAIR TO
BE ADDED TO THIS COMMITTEE SO
HOPEFULLY WILL. MAKE THIS W.
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU SENATE OR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
TO THE PANEL WE APPRECIATE YOU
FOR COMING THANK YOU. OKAY TAKE
IT EASY SO- IF YOU'RE FOLLOWING
ALONG ON THE AGENDA YOU'LL SEE
THE KIND OF OUR FIRST
PRESENTATION GAVE US ALL A
COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF IN
HISTORY OF RECENT FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION CHANGES. THIS PANEL.
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY PLAYING AND
THIS LAST PANEL ASK YOU ALL TO
COME IN IF WE COULD GET THE
NAME PLACARDS CHANGED OUT
PLEASE. WE'LL HAVE THE LAST
PANEL COME FORWARD AND THEIR
FOCUS IT WILL BE TO PROVIDE US
ALL. MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AS ALL OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES. OF IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN WHICH IS THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
AND IN KEEPING WITH- ANY PUBLIC
HEARING WE WILL IN THE HEARING
FOLLOWING THE LAST PANELS
PRESENTATION WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT- WILL ASCERTAIN HOW
MANY PEOPLE TEND TO MAKE
COMMENT. AND THAT'S WHEN I'LL
TELL YOU- HOW MUCH TIME EACH
MEMBER THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE COME TO THE MIKE THAT'S
IN THE MIDDLE PERFECT THANK YOU.
AGAIN THAT'S FOLLOW THIS UP
LAST PANEL. OKAY. AGAIN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HEAR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT WE CAN
DO LET THE LEGISLATURE
HOPEFULLY MANY OF YOU IN THIS
ROOM. WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY LEAH
BUSH TO SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY SERVICES
AT JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF
SAN DIEGO. IT'S WORKING AT THE
BORDER WITH US. FOR THE NET
HELP ME. AND YOUR LAST NAME.
THE NIGHT AT MASSU THANK YOU IS
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE AFRICAN
COMMUNITIES PUBLIC HEALTH
COALITION SHE'LL SHARE THE
EXPERIENCES OF AFRICAN
IMMIGRANTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
LOS ANGELES. ODESSA BERRY
POWERS IS AT AS AN IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY AT THE CHILDREN'S
LAWSON OF CALIFORNIA SHE WILL
SPEAK ABOUT M. GOOD CHILDREN
WHO THE STATE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR BECAUSE THEY ARE WITHOUT
PARENTS OR SUFFER FROM ABUSE
AND NEGLECT. AND FINALLY JOSEPH
THE V. EIGHT. VIELE VIELE IS
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT- TURLOCK
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS MR THE EILAT
WORLD DISCUSSED THE CAL E. I.
T. C. TAX CREDIT ON AND THE
JOINT EFFORT TO EXPAND IT TO
INCLUDE I. T. I. N. HOLDERS AS
A POVERTY ALLEVIATION TOOL
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
WE'LL START WITH YOU MISS BUSH.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING- THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE COMMITTEE TO
SENATOR MITCHELL EXCUSE ME. AND
ALL THE STAFF FOR HOSTING THIS
EVENT TODAY- DODD SENATOR PAN-
AND ALSO SENATE ALLEN WHOSE
ACTUALLY VISIT OUR FACILITY
THANK YOU. I'M I HAVE WORKED AT
GFS FOR EIGHT YEARS AND OVER
THE PAST YEAR I'VE MANAGED OUR
RESPONSE TO THIS ISLAND SEEKING
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN IN NEED
AT OUR BORDER. THIS SLIDE SHOW
OF PHOTOS- HOPEFULLY PLAYING
ACTUALLY IN FRONT OF ME HERE IS
JUST A SAMPLING OF THE MORE
THAN EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COME TO
THE MIGRANT FAMILY SHELTER THAT
JEFF S. OPERATES. EACH ONE OF
THESE PEOPLE HAS UNIQUE STORY
IN THEIR SEARCH FOR A BETTER
LIFE. JEFF I STARTED ITS WORK
AT THE BORDER OF CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO MORE THAN A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. HELPING JEWISH
REFUGEES FIND SAFETY AND A NEW
START. THAT MISSION CONTINUES
TODAY AS WE ASSIST IMMIGRANTS
AND PEOPLE IN NEED OF ALL
FAITHS AND BACKGROUNDS. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN JEFF A STAFF
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
ENVISIONED IN CONVENED A GROUP
THAT IS NOW CALLED THE SAN
DIEGO RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK.
THE NETWORK WAS INITIATED INTO
INCREASED IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY THROUGH A HOTLINE. WHERE
ANYONE COULD CALL TO GET HELP
FOR AN URGENT LEGAL NEED. IN
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ENDED A PROGRAM CALLED
SAFE RELEASE. THE HOTLINE
RECEIVED A CALL THAT ABOUT
FORTY PEOPLE MOSTLY WOMEN AND
CHILDREN HAD BEEN DROPPED OFF
AT THE SAN DIEGO BUS STATION.
PRETTY MUCH NOTHING. NO FOOD NO
PLACE TO SLEEP AND IT WAS
AROUND TEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND WHAT I'M
DESCRIBING. THESE WERE FAMILY
SEEKING ASYLUM IN THE UNITED
STATES. THEY HAD ALL BEEN
RELEASED FROM A FEDERAL AGENCY.
THE ADULTS HAD ANKLE MONITORS
TO TRACK THEIR WHEREABOUTS.
MOMS BABIES KIDS WHO HAD NEVER
SEEN THE US BEFORE. VERY FEW
HAD WARM CLOTHING FOR THE COOL
OCTOBER NIGHT. THEY WERE TIRED
HUNGRY DE HYDRATED AND
SOMEWHERE SICK. AND IN C. DIEGO
THE MAIN BUS STATION. IS MORE
LIKE AN OUTDOOR TICKET COUNTER.
THERE'S NO PLACE TO SIT INSIDE.
A NOT A LOT OF BUSES ARE
LEAVING AT TEN PM ON A FRIDAY.
SO IF AN ORGANIZATION DIDN'T
STEP FORWARD TO HELP. THERE
COULD BE HUNDREDS AND OVER TIME
WE RECOGNIZE MAYBE THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES ON THE STREET.
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS
TEMPORARILY HOMELESS AND AT
HIGH RISK FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SO WITH NO END TO THE DROP OFFS
IN SIGHT THE JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE MIGRANT FAMILY SHELTER
BEGAN. THE NAME WAS BORN A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF URGENCY NOT.
A KILLER CREATIVITY OR OR- GOOD
INTENTION- IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE EFFORT THERE WAS NO FUNDING
TO DO THE WORK. WE HAD STATE
VOLUNTEERS WHO CAME TO HELP
PEOPLE TAKING SHIFTS AFTER
WORKING THEIR DAY JOBS. THE
SHELTER MOVE SIX TIMES BEFORE
LANDING IN OUR CURRENT LOCATION.
ALTHOUGH THE CURRENT LOCATION
GENEROUSLY PROVIDED BY THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IS ALSO
TEMPORARY. AND WE WILL HAVE TO
MOVE AGAIN BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR. WHEN FAMILIES ARRIVED AT
THE SHELTER. WE DO A BRIEF
MEDICAL SCREENING TO ENSURE
THAT THEY DO NOT NEED URGENT
MEDICAL CARE. WHEN FAMILIES
ARRIVE AT THE SHELTER WE GIVE
THEM WATER FRESH FOOD. NEW
CLOTHING. AND A WARM SHOWER.
WHEN FAMILIES ARRIVE AT THE
SHELTER WE GIVE THEM A SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHEN FAMILIES
ARRIVED AT THE SHELTER THEY CAN
FINALLY PUT THEIR GUARD DOWN.
THEY CAN START THINKING ABOUT
BUILDING A BETTER LIFE. TO
FURTHER ILLUSTRATE THE WORK WE
DO. I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
WOMAN WHO I MET WHO CAME TO THE
SHORT SHELTER DURING SOME OF
OUR VERY EARLY MONTHS. SHE
ARRIVED IN VAN DRIVEN BY BORDER
PATROL CONTRACTORS. SHE HAD TWO
YOUNG BOYS AGES FOUR AND SIX
AND A BABY ATTACHED TO OUR
CHEST IN A MAKESHIFT DROP. I
HAVE TWO KIDS TO- AND I THINK I
REMEMBER THINKING WELL SHE
REALLY MUST BE EXHAUSTED. WE
GIVE THE FAMILY WATER AND SOME
ORANGES AS THEY ARRIVED AND
THEY SO CLEARLY REMEMBER HOW
HAPPY THE BOYS WERE TO SEE THE
ORANGES. WE WERE DELIGHTED TO
PUSH PIECES OF THE ORANGES INTO
THEIR MOUTH WITH JUICE RUNNING
DOWN THEIR FACES. THE MOM HELD
BACK TEARS WE- WHEN OUR STAFF
TOLD HER THAT SHE WAS AT A
SHELTER SHE WAS SAFE. WE WOULD
HELP HER CALL HER FAMILY GIVE
HER FOOD AND CLOTHING. SHE
ALMOST LOOKED TOO TIRED TO CRY.
TO DO THIS IMPORTANT WORK.
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES HAD
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
RAPID RESPONSE FUND AND MANY
PRIVATE DONORS AND VOLUNTEERS.
THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR THE
SHELTERS AROUND SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION SUPPORTS THE
OPERATIONS AND TWO POINT THREE
COVERS THE MEDICAL AND HEALTH
COMPONENTS. IN THE PAST YEAR WE
HAVE HELPED MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND FAMILIES. REPRESENTING
MORE THAN EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. OVER HALF OF WHICH
OUR CHILDREN. WE OFTEN SAY THAT
THANK YOU. WE OFTEN SAY THAT
RUNNING THE SHELTER IS A
COMMUNITY EFFORT NOT A JEFF
BASS ONE. MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS HAVE COME
TO HELP AT OUR SHELTER IN THE
PAST YEAR. FOR SOME INVOLVEMENT
IN THE SHELTER IS A PERSONAL
RESPONSE TO BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING. ABOUT THE INCREASING
ANTI IMMIGRANT RHETORIC ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL. WHAT I HAVE
COME TO REALIZE IS THAT HELPING
THIS MOM AND HER KIDS. AND ALL
THE FAMILIES LIKE THEM IS NOT
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED. THIS
WORK IS A CLEAR TIED TO OUR
FOUNDING WORKERS JEFF BASS
SHORT TERM SPECIFIC HELP FOR
PEOPLE NEW TO THIS COUNTRY FOOD
SHELTER AND A CLEAN SHIRT. THIS
IS WHAT WE WERE FOUNDED TO DO.
FOR MANY MONTHS WE HAD MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND SOMETIMES IN
TWO HUNDRED NEW PEOPLE A DAY.
ALMOST A THOUSAND NEW PEOPLE
EACH WEEK COMING TO THE SHELTER.
TYPICAL STAYS LESS THAN THREE
DAYS. LOOKING BACK I AM STILL
AMAZED AT HOW WE FOUND A WAY.
WE TOOK IN ALL THE ASYLUM
SEEKING FAMILIES RELEASED TO US
AND WE FOUND A SAFE PLACE FOR
THEM TO SLEEP. WE NEVER LET
THEM GO TO THE STREET. IT WAS
DIFFICULT WORK IT IS DIFFICULT
WORK. NOW THAT THE MIGRANT
PROTECTION PROTOCOL OR REMAIN
IN MEXICO PROGRAM IS IN FULL
FORCE. THE DAILY ARRIVALS HAVE
SLOWED TO ABOUT A HUNDRED NEW
PEOPLE EACH WEEK. ABOUT FIFTY
YOU'RE SO SLEEPING IN THE
SHELTER EACH NIGHT. THE STILL A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT COULD BE SLEEPING ON THE
STREET. AND YET WITHOUT A CLEAR
PATH FOR IMMIGRATION POLICY AND
NUMEROUS LAWSUITS CURRENTLY
PENDING THIS LOWER NUMBER FEELS
LIKE IT COULD CHANGE AT ANY
MOMENT. WE KNOW OUR GAS WE KNOW
FROM OUR GAS. THAT THE HOLDING
CELLS AND ATTENTION ARE
REFERRED TO AS YOU LET US OR
ICE BOXES. CHILLING PLACES WITH
NO COMFORT. AND WE DO NOT SERVE
BURRITOS. BECAUSE THE FAMILIES
TELL US THAT THE BURRITOS THEY
WERE GIVEN TO EAT WE'RE STILL
FROZEN. SO OUR GOAL IS TO KEEP
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS
TOGETHER. TO HELP THEM FEEL
SAFE AND WARM. SAFE AND WARM
THAT IS OUR JOB. FOR MANY
FAMILIES OUR SHELTER IS THE
MIDDLE OF A VERY LONG JOURNEY
JEFF S. IS GRATEFUL TO BE IN A
GREAT STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
WHERE THERE ARE FORUMS LIKE
THIS CONSIDERING THE NEEDS OF
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND FOR PARTNERS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND FIERCE
ADVOCATES LIKE ME STILLER
RELEASE WHO SPOKE EARLIER. BUT
AS MUCH WE'VE DONE TO HELP
FAMILIES THROUGH THIS TIME OF
CRISIS. THIS IS NOT A TIME TO
CELEBRATE. AS I MENTIONED WE
RECOGNIZE THE FEDERAL POLICY
CAN CHANGE AT ANY TIME. AND WE
STILL HAVE MANY FAMILIES COMING
THROUGH OUR DOOR. TO CONTINUE
TO KEEP CHILDREN LIKE THESE. ON
YOUR OWN POWER POINT YOU CAN
SEE SAFE. WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
TO KEEP FUNDING THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE SHELTER TO
FIND A WAY TO FUND
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATIONS TO
HELP ASYLUM SEEKERS DOCUMENT
THE ABUSES IN THE TRAUMAS THEY
HAVE EXPERIENCED WHEN THEIR
CASES. AND TO KEEP UP THANKS
FOR THE IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OUR WATER IS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE WAY AN
ASYLUM SEEKING CHILD COULD
ENTER OUR STATE AND I
APPRECIATE BEING HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE WAYS WE CAN CONTINUE
TO KEEP FAMILIES WITH IMMIGRANT
BACKGROUNDS. SAFE AND WARM IN
THIS COUNTRY. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. AS WE SAY IN THE SAN
DIEGO RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK NO
WIND IN OUR COMMUNITY STANDS
ALONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH MASSIVE. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATORS FOR
CREATING THE SPACE WHERE WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WAS ARE THEY JUST
RAISE OR AN ORAL HEARING WHAT
IS GOING ON WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY I KNOW THIS IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME TO EXPRESS HOW WE
FEEL WHAT IS GOING ON OUR
COMMUNITY BUT I CAUGHT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES COMMUNITY LEADERS
WHO ARE REPRESENTING A
COMMUNITY. THAT PEOPLE USE OUR-
SO- THEN YOU JUST START. SOCIAL
DETERMINES WHAT IS SOCIAL
DETERMINES. SORRY SOCIAL
DETERMINES OUR- THINGS THAT'S
PLACED- BASED THAT IMPACTED.
ONCE LIFE QUALITY CONDITION.
AND IT ALSO SHOWS THE OUTCOME-
HEALTH IMMINENT HEALTH- THAT IT
CONDITION TO BE HOUSING SCHOOL
FOOD ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE LIVE
JOB WELL WE HAVE AND SOCIAL
SUPPORT MAINLY SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRANT CHILDREN WE
HAVE TO YOU THAT SYSTEM THEORY
SAYS LIKE WHAT IS THE SOCIETY
DOING FOR US. WHAT IS THE
COMMUNITY WHAT'S A FAMILY AND
IT GOES TO INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN
SO WE HAVE TO LOOK KIND OF FORM
THE FAMILY DYNAMIC THAT WED
IMMIGRANT EXPERIENCES AND MOST
IMMIGRANT REFUGES ARE THE MAJOR
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS THE LOSS THE
PRE AND POST MIGRATION
STRESSORS TRAUMA LOSS THAT'S
WHAT IT'S IMPACTED SO DODD GOES
DOWN TO DEPENDS WHAT AGE GROUP
WE LOOK AT FOR CHILDREN IF IT
WAS ZERO TO SEVENTEEN THAT'S
SUBJECT TO SUIT TOM THE
LIFESTYLE. THE POLITICAL
GRANDMA THE ENVIRONMENT THIS
OCCASION A DISCRIMINATION ALL
THAT MAYBE I'M TALKING ABOUT
AND BLACK COMMUNITY EMIGRANT.
RAFI MEETS SO WHEN WE TALK.
ABOUT CHILDREN AND FAMILY LET
ME GIVE A LITTLE BIT NUMBER I
SAW THE EARLIER DATA. FULLER
HOME SITES WHAT JANET BED I'M
UNFORTUNATELY THE AFRICANS WHO
ARE THE CARIBBEAN'S DATA SHOWS
OTHER IMMIGRANTS. BUT I DID MY
LITTLE NUMBER SAY'S LIKE- STUDY
SHOWS THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
IT HAS FOUR POINT MILLION. FOR
M. BORN BLACK IMMIGRANTS THAT
INCLUDED CARIBBEAN AFRICAN
ORIGIN. WITH THAT THE FIRST.
HAITI IS THE FIRST AT JAMAICA'S
A NUMBER ONE NUMBER HE D. IS A
SECOND THE THIRD IS NIGERIAN
AND YET THE UPON THE FORCE OF
COURSE IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
SECOND LARGEST STATE. HAS THAT
AFRICAN OR CARIBBEAN BORN
IMMIGRANTS IMAGINE THAT SO HOW
DO WE DO WITH THOSE CHILDREN
SUIT. MENTAL HEALTH IS THE BIG
IMPACT FOR IMMIGRANT REFUGEE.
BECAUSE. A HIDDEN PROBLEM IT'S
NEVER BEEN TALKED NOT ONLY THAT
THERE'S NO SERVICE THAT'S
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE. I'M A
CLINICIAN BY DISCIPLINE SO WHEN
WE TREAT SOMEONE WE GO DE
CLINICAL LOOK THAT DOESN'T WORK
AND SOME OF US BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE CAME FOR WHAT REMAINS TO US
IS SERVICE. AND THUS FAR WE
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE WOULDN'T TALK
TO CHILDREN CHILDREN ARE
SUBJECTED AS I SAID THE FAMILY
LIFE WHEN YOU GO TO SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR THE TAE.
TRANSITIONAL IS YOUTH THAT
SEVEN DIFFERENT HAS CLOSE TO A
PROBLEM OF MINUTE ISSUE WHICH
IS HARD TO TREAT. BECAUSE ON
ONE MOST IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
THE REFUGEES THEY CLINCH TOOK
ON COMMUNITY BECAUSE COLD HARD
TO REACH COMMITTEE TYPE THAT
NAME BY THE WAY WOULD NOT HARD
TO REACH WE JUST UNDER SERVICE
OR WE CAN BE A RICH. HELLO
SWITCH STOP THE IN SOME SORT OF
TREATMENT. TO DO THAT- WE HAVE
TO COME UP WITH CHANGING THE
TRADITIONAL I'VE TREATED MEANS
LIKE WHAT ARE WE DOING THIS
SOUNDS LIKE ALL ON TO THE
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ON TO DO THE
SAME TO BOBBY BORE AND THAT'S
WHAT AFRICAN COMMUNITY CAME IT
WAS BIRTH AND THEIR SPOTS TO
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AMONG
IMMIGRANTS BLACK IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IT'S ME GRUNT
DRIVEN ORGANIZATION THAT'S
INCORPORATED TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. JUST MOVING FOR WHAT
WHAT WE DOING RIGHT NOW IS WE
DOING SOME WHAT AT SMALLER
LEVEL THE JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE
DOING WE TAKE IN DETAINEES WHO
DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH WHO WAS
TRAVEL SIX SEVEN MONTHS THROUGH
ALL SOUTH AMERICA TO GET TO
MEXICO SO WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
THEY GET THERE THEY HAVE THIS
IDENTITY ISSUE THEY IDENTIFIED
THEMSELVES AFRICAN SO WHEN IT
IS UNFORTUNATELY ONLINE NOW THE
COMMUNITIES NO ONE AT LEAST NOT
MUCH COMPLETE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION- ANYTHING COOL
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF-
CARIBBEAN AND A BLACK
IMMIGRANTS THAT'S HOW WE STEP
IN SURE ENOUGH WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO OFFER BUT WE DO
HAVE A LAND USE TO UNDERSTAND A
CUSTOM. TWO OFF OF THEM LIVE IN
SUPPORT THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING DETAINEES COMING FROM SAN
DIEGO. ATLANTE ANOTHER ISSUE WE
HAVE IS. BASED ON THE CUT THE-
HOME SECURITY- WE TEND TO BE
LABELED THAT. FGM FEMALE. JIM
TIME INFORMATION THIS IS ONE OF
THE ISSUE AMONG OUR CHILDREN.
BUT AGAIN WE DON'T COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THAT HOW TO PREVENT
AND IS THAT THERE IS A
PUNISHMENT CRIMINALIZATION
WHICH DEPARTMENT OF HOUSE- IT
WAS JUST A WELFARE CAUGHT I
GUESS. IF YOU HAVE PRACTICE BUT
WE SEE THAT WITHIN OUR CHILDREN
BUT NORMALLY THAT TO TRY MY THE
FACT THEY FACING WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY. WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S WHAT THE
OUR CHILDREN HOUSES IMPACT
BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE TO STEP
UP OFF AGAIN COALITION WORKING
WITH. HOME LIKE SECURITY
CREATED THIS THE FIRST WESTERN
OUR IF JIM A COALITION TOGETHER
OKAY WE ALSO DOING SOME
ADVOCACY GROUP WHO HAS
DEPARTMENT- OUR IMAGES M.
MENTAL HAVE STRESS HEARTS IN
SACRAMENTO. THE SITES IN A
CONNIE. ABOVE COMMISSIONED TO
PREVENT AND. COME UP WAS AN
INVENTION. I'M THIS ADVOCACY
PROJECT. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF AFRICAN AND CARIBBEAN
IMMIGRANTS IN GENERAL ACTUALLY
WE HAVE SOMETHING IN COMMON AS
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE HOW DO WE
ADVOCATE HOW DO WE BE HEARD
WHAT WOULD LIKE TO BE TREATED
WHAT TREATMENT WE NEED TO HOW
DO WE EXPAND THE TRADITIONAL
SERVICES ANY PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
SERVICES HAVE. SO WE'VE BEEN
DOING ADVOCACY GROUP BY.
ADMISSION NOW WITH ON TO TEASE
SUCH US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OFFICE
ANY AS STAKEHOLDERS GATHERING
CREATING A SPACE LIKE THIS
AROUND TABLE DISCUSSING WHAT IS
THE CURRENT ISSUE HOW DO WE
HELP THOSE DETAINEES. WHO
DOESN'T HAVE A LANGUAGE WHO
DOESN'T HAVE A SOCIAL SUPPORT
HERE BUT HE'S BEEN THROWING
JUST BECAUSE THIS THAT THE PUT
THE CURRENT. POLITICAL CLIMATE
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE EITHER
OF- THE ISSUE OF FGM WITHOUT A
PUNISHING THE COMMUNITY THE
WOMEN DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE A
CHOICE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN HER
CULTURE AND FAMILY. AND THE
PUNISHMENT AND HERE IN IN MY
STATE WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO
PREVENT THAT THIS IS NOT A
CHOICE. I HAVE TO HOW IDENTITY
IDENTIFIED AS TO WHERE I BELONG
THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME PROUD
THAT'S WHY I'M I'M NOT GOING TO
CHANGE MYSELF. BECAUSE OF THE
BORDER JUST BECAUSE I WRITE IN
UNITED STATE AND THAT'S THE
PROBLEM SO HOW TO COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THIS IS WHAT WE
DOING- SO WE CALL. UPON ALL
THIS STAKEHOLDERS LOADING YOUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO COME UP
WITH THE IDEA SO WITH THIS
PROJECTS GOING ON NOT ONLY
THAT- RIGHT NOW WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AT IT. DO. WE ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF NOT ONLY CHILDREN BUT.
COMMITTEE ON LARGE. HOW TO
REDUCE THE STIGMA OF MENTAL
HEALTH SO PEOPLE CAN BE TREAT
IT- THERE'S SO MANY FACTORS
THAT LEADS TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH. THEY SAY SOCIAL
DETERMINES WHAT ONE OF EITHER
WANTED TO AS A MAJOR FACT THAT
BAD SO UNLESS YOU HAVE TO COME
UP. SUCH AS THE SOLUTION- THIS
PROJECT WHAT WE DOING ADVOCACY
THEN WE COME UP IDEA WE HAVE TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION WE'RE
NOT JUST GOING TO TALK THE
PROBLEM WHAT IS. A LOT OF STUDY
BEING DONE WHAT IS BEING LOST
ME AND WITH IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
COMMITTEE A LOT OF- YOU KNOW ON
THE STUDY BEING DONE WHAT THE
FACTORS OF WHAT IS MEANT TO BE
A REFUGEE. MY SISTER SHARING
WHAT IS SHE DOING DAY TO DATE
BUT HOW DO WE COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION TO RESULT WAS WHAT WE
HEAR. TODAY SO. AS A SIDE AS
ANY OTHER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
THE AFRICAN DESCENDED COMMUNITY
IS WORKING HARD I'M PROUD TO
SAY AFTER YOU CAN CALL SHOULD
WHICH IS- THE COMMITTED RAPE
AND ORGANIZATION THAT SPEAKS
MORE THAN TEN AFTER. WHICH IS
I'M A CLINICIAN ALL JIM SPEAK
MORE THAN ONE LANGUAGES THAT'S
THE KIND OF THINGS. I'LL GIVE
EXAMPLE. THE CAMERA LADY FROM
DETENTION. CENTER SHE'S SIX
MONTHS PREGNANT SHE WAS
REFERRED TO US. LUCKILY YOU
PROUD TO SAY YOUR PHONE CALL
THE WHEN WE SEE WE WENT-
INTEGRATED HER- SO I FIRST SHE
WASN'T REALLY HAPPY SHE WAS
RESISTING HELP BECAUSE OF HER
STICK MOTHER FEAR. THE FACT WE
COME FROM PRE AND POST TRAUMA
IT IN PRE MIGRATION WE DON'T
HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PUBLIC CONSTITUTE. POLICE
DOESN'T MEAN OUR FRIEND RIGHT.
NOT FRIEND HERE EITHER BUT AT
LEAST. SO. BECAUSE OF THAT WE
DON'T HAVE NO TRUST. SO WE ARE
STILL DEALING M. BUT THE REASON
I BROUGHT THIS EXAMPLE IS I'LL
TELL YOU HOW CULTURE MEANS TO
US. AFTER WAS BECAUSE NATIVE
LANGUAGE ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
SPOKE WITH HER. SHE'S NOT
SMILING TO START CRYING HARD.
THE FACT MIKE SHE FEELS THERE'S
SOMEONE AFTER SIX MISTRIAL
RULING THROUGH ALL ELEVEN
COUNTRIES TO GET HERE. AND THE
FIRST THING SHE ASK IS WHAT DO
I GET MY FOOD. DO NOT ASK ANY
URGENT BUT THE FOOD WAS
SOMETHING WHAT. CREATE A
BELONGINGNESS SHIP SAFE THAT'S
WHAT WE TALKING ABOUT IT'S A
COMPLEX TO UNDERSTAND WHO WE
ARE AS A PERSON AS A CULTURE.
BUT WE MUST COME AND THE MIDDLE
TO REACH OUT LET YOU KNOW WHAT
WE ARE AND COME TO WITH SOME
SORT OF. SUPPORT INCLUDING FIND
A LOCATION. THE REGULAR WAY
WORKING FUNDING DEBT. SO COLD
ORGANIZATION IS NOT SHOWING
THE- POSITIVE OCTOBER AT LEAST
THE- OUTCOMES WE EXPECTED TO
BE. SO WE ALSO HAVE OTHER WAY
TREATING THIS. AN OPERATION LOS
M. PARKS ACROSS PHYSICAL AND
THE MENTAL EMOTIONAL DOMAIN
FROM PHYSICAL AND MENTAL LOSSES
LOSING FRIENDS LOSING THE
NEIGHBORS LOSING THE STATUS OF
THE ORIGIN OF THE COUNTRY ALL
UP ON THAT IT TAKES AWAY OUR
SELF ESTEEM WILL BE BE COME
HERE UNDEAD ALSO REDUCE OUR
IDENTITY ON IS A JANET ISSUE
AMONG AFRICAN AND CARIBBEAN- SO
WE'LL HAVE TO COME OUT WITH THE
TREATMENTS I'M AN AFRICAN
CALLED ISSUE LATELY BEEN
WORKING HARD MY COLLEAGUE DR
SAVANT THE WHO IS A- THE
OUTSTANDING RESEARCHER HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THIS JOB IS. SO WE
HAD TO COME UP WITH THE
TREATMENT IT'S CALLED- CACHO
LOSS THERAPY MODEL WE HAVE A
LOT OF SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
PROTECT EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
TREATMENT BUT. I DON'T FEEL
LIKE NONE OF US WORKING FOR THE
IMMIGRANT COMING FOR A CERTAIN
CULTURE THAT STUDY HASN'T BEEN
AT LEAST NOT TESTED THAT SO WE
CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA. TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF LOSS
THAT'S A BIG TRAUMA EVEN HERE
WHEN I STATE FOR YOU KNOW I
DON'T HAVE TO PREACH ABOUT THAT
AFRICAN AMERICAN FOR FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS. IT'S A LOSS OF
CULTURE IT LOSS OF IDENTITY WAS
WAS STRUGGLING MORE SO FOR US
FOR IMMIGRANTS COULD BE WHEN WE
COME HE WOULD IDENTIFY THE
BLACK WOMEN THEY DON'T CALL ME
ETHIOPIA LADY. SO WE HAVE TO DO
A MULTIPLE LAYER OF
DISCRIMINATION AS WELL. THAT'S
THE REASON WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF LAWS WHAT IT MEANS
TO US. AND ALSO MIKE RIGHT MY
TIME OKAY SO SHE WAS TELLING ME
AND GENERAL WE HAVE THIS
TREATMENT THAT ADDRESSES. I
KNOWLEDGE- CULTURE ENDED
DIFFERENCES OUTCOME. ANON IS
THE MISTRESS KNOWLEDGE THE
TRAUMA AND ALSO COME OUT WAS
COPING MECHANISM FROM A
CULTURAL PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS
THE KIND OF TREATMENT WOULD
LIKE TO ELABORATE AND SUPPORT
SO. I CHALLENGE YOU AND ASK YOU
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND DUMP YOU
ELECTIVE OFFICIALS TO PARTNER
WITH US. TO TALK OVER THIS NONE
STOP A TRAUMA ISSUE AMONG
AFRICAN IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. HE WAS VERY
POWER. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
SENATORS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK TO YOU ALL TODAY ABOUT
THE NEEDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOU. MY NAME IS- DOES A
VERY POWERS AND THE IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER OF CALIFORNIA. CLC
REPRESENTS ALL- CHILDREN
DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS AND LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTY. IN TOTAL WE REPRESENT
OVER THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA
MISTER POWERS CAN YOU MOVE THE
MIKE A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU I
SEE THERE ARE TV GUIDE.
ABSOLUTELY HOPE THAT'S BETTER.
SO MANY OF OUR CLIENTS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED OR OTHERWISE IN
NEED OF IMMIGRATION ASSISTANCE
AND MY JOB AS C. L. C.'S
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY. IS TO
TRAIN CLC ATTORNEYS AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
ISSUES FACED BY UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH. TO WORK WITH C.
L. C. ATTORNEYS TO IDENTIFY THE
IMMIGRATION NEEDS OF OUR
CLIENTS. ARE AND WITH M. BEADS.
CHRISTIAN REPRESENTATION AND IN
A SMALL NUMBER OF CASES PROVIDE
DIRECT REPRESENTATION TO OUR
CLIENTS IN NEED OF IMMIGRATION
ASSISTANCE. I ALSO THINK YOU I
ALSO REVIEW AND REVISE ALL-
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
PREDICATE ORDERS- BEFORE
THEY'RE SUBMITTED TO THE JUDGES
AND DEPENDENCY IN LA COUNTY.
AND IN SOME PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING CASES I WILL APPEAR
IN COURT AND EXPLAIN TO THE
COURT THE BASIS FOR THE SEARCH
REQUEST OR AT THE IMPACT THE
CHILD'S IMMIGRATION CASE CAN
HAVE ON THE DEPENDENCY CASE. SO
TODAY I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT. HOW UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER
YOUTH ENTERED THE STATE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THE CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES THEY FACE AND
HOW THEY CAN BE BETTER SUPPORT.
SO FIRST I WANT TO ADDRESS WHO
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH ARE.
THEY ARE CHILDREN WHO CAME INTO
THE STATE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
FOR ABUSE OR NEGLECT. AND THEY
HAPPEN TO BE UNDOCUMENTED AND
THIS INCLUDES CHILDREN WHO ARE
IN IMMIGRATION REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS AND CHILDREN WHO
HAVE NEVER HAD ANY CONTACT WITH
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS. SO TO
CLARIFY CHILDREN IN THE STATE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ARE DE
LEÓN CHILDREN IN THE STATE
EXCUSE ME THE FEDERAL FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. CHILDREN WHO ENTER
THE STATE FOSTER SYSTEM HAVE
BEEN ABUSED OR NEGLECTED BY A
PARENT OR CAREGIVER DCFS FILED
THE PETITION IN DEPENDENCY
COURT. AND THE CHILDREN ARE
PLACING DCFS CUSTODY IN
CONTRAST CHILDREN IN THE
FEDERAL FOSTER CARE CAN.
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE CHILDREN
WHO HAVE CROSS INTO THE UNITED.
GUARDIAN THEY'VE BEEN ADMITTED
AS UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
TRANSFERRED TO THE CARE OF
OFFICE OF REFUGEE SETTLEMENT NO
SPONSOR IS AVAILABLE TO CARE
FOR THEM SO THEY ARE
TRANSFERRED TO LONG TERM
FEDERAL FOSTER CARE. NOW THERE
IS SOME CROSSOVER BETWEEN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL SYSTEMS SOME
OF OUR CLIENTS IN THE STATE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM- ENTERED AS
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN. THEY
WERE TRANSFERRED TO OUR CUSTODY
THEY WERE THEN RELEASED TO A
SPONSOR THERE'S A
DISINTEGRATION OF THE FAMILY
UNIT MAYBE THERE'S ABUSE
ABANDONMENT OR NEGLECT. AND
THEN THE CHILD WAS- DCFS BECAME
INVOLVED AND THE CHILD WAS
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY. HOWEVER WE
ALSO HAVE CLIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
TRAFFICKED INTO THE UNITED
STATES THEY ENTER THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM WHEN THE
TRAFFICKING WAS DISCOVERED WE
HAVE CLIENTS WHO HAVE ENTERED
THE UNITED STATES ALONE IT THEY
FIND THEMSELVES HOMELESS THEY
HAVE. NO FAMILY OR FRIEND
CONNECTIONS- IT DCFS BECOMES
INVOLVED THAT WAY WE ALSO HAVE
MANY CLIENTS WHO ENTERED THE
UNITED STATES AS INFANTS
THEY'VE LIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR THEIR ENTIRE LIVES-
THERE IS SOME ABUSE POSSIBLY
NEGLECT- FROM THEIR PARENTS.
AND DCFS BECOMES INVOLVED. ALL
OF THIS IS TO SAY. OUR CLIENTS
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY OF
EXPERIENCES AND ENTER THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM AND A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT WAYS AND ALTHOUGH
THEIR EXPERIENCES VERY ALMOST
ALL UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH
QUALIFY FOR SOME FORM OF RELIEF.
WELL ALMOST ALL UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
QUALIFY FOR SOME AVENUES TO
LEGAL STATUS THERE'S NO
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH.
RECEIVE THE IMMIGRATION
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY NEED TO
TAP ACCESS THAT RELIEF AND THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE BECAUSE
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN WHO LEAVE
FOSTER CARE WITHOUT OBTAINING
LEGAL STATUS BE SUBSTANTIAL
BARRIERS AS THEY TRY TO
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD AND
THESE BARRIERS INCLUDE THE
INABILITY TO LEGALLY WORK. THEY
CAN'T ACCESS MANY FORMS OF
FINANCIAL AID AND THEY FACE THE
CONSTANT FEAR OF BEING DETAINED
BY ICE. SO TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN FOSTER YOUTH
NEED ASSISTANCE FIRST ASSESSING
OUR IMMIGRATION NEEDS AND ALSO
BEING LINKED WITH IMMIGRATION
REPRESENTATION THE CRITICAL
FIRST STEP TO DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT A FOSTER YOUTH
NEEDS IMMIGRATION ASSISTANCE.
IS DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
THAT FOSTER USES UNDOCUMENTED
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY TWO STEP
PROCESS. FIRST WE NEED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE CHILD IS
BORN IN THE UNITED STATES AND
IF NOT WE NEED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THAT CHILD HAS ALREADY
RECEIVED STATUS. IN OBTAINING A
COPY OF THE CHILD'S BIRTH
CERTIFICATE EARLY ON IN THE
DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO LINKING THE CHILD
WITH IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. CALIFORNIA
LAW DOES REQUIRE THAT THE COURT
ORDER THAT A PERSON TO MAKE IT
BE PRODUCED IF THE COURT.
EITHER DETERMINES THAT
REUNIFICATION SERVICES TO THE
PARENTS AREN'T GOING TO BE
OFFERED OR IF THE COURT
TERMINATES THOSE REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. BUT FOR MANY CHILDREN
THIS DENIAL OR TERMINATION OF
REUNIFICATION SERVICES. DOESN'T
HAPPEN FOR MANY YEARS IF AT ALL.
AND IN OUR EXPERIENCE EVEN WHEN
THE JUDGE DOES MAKE THE ORDER
REQUIRING THE PRODUCTION OF THE
BIRTH CERTIFICATE THERE ISN'T
ALWAYS THAT FOLLOW UP NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE IS OBTAINED. SO IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MANY JUDGES
REQUESTED THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE
BE ATTACHED EARLY ON IN THE
PROCESS TO THE JURISDICTION
DISPOSITION REPORT BUT AGAIN AT
THIS PRACTICE ISN'T ALWAYS
FOLLOWED. AND EVEN IF THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE IS OBTAINED HE
DETAILS ABOUT A CHILD'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS MAY REMAIN
UNCLEAR. OFTEN A CHILD PARENT
OR CAREGIVER IS THE PARTY WITH
THE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE CHILD'S
IMMIGRATION CASE IF THE CHILD
IS IN REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS IF A
CHILD IS IMMIGRATION
REPRESENTATION IF APPLICATIONS
FOR STATUS HAVE BEEN FILED ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD. AND WHEN
THE CHILD IS REMOVED FROM THAT
PARENT OR CAREGIVER IF THEY
LOSE THAT LINK TO THAT
INFORMATION AND AS A RESULT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE HAD
MANY CHILDREN IN DCFS CUSTODY
RECEIPT AND ABSENTIA
DEPORTATION ORDERS. FOR FAILURE
TO ATTEND AN IMMIGRATION
HEARING BECAUSE THEY DID NOT
KNOW THAT THEY HAD AN
IMMIGRATION HEARING THAT THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO ATTEND. WISHIN
THAT WE PROPOSE TO THIS. IS TO
IMPLEMENT AS A PRACTICE. THAT
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS TURN OVER
COPIES. OF THE CHILD'S BIRTH
CERTIFICATE AND IMMIGRATION
RELATED DOCUMENTS EARLY ON IN
THE DEPENDENCY PROCESS
PREFERABLY AT THE INITIAL
HEARING. THE CHILD HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS BEING BORN
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES
AND IN NEED OF IMMIGRATION
ASSISTANCE. ARE WE NEXT NEED TO
LINK THAT CHILD WITH
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION IS
CRITICAL TO SUCCESS AT EVERY
STAGE OF THE PROCESS AND I WANT
TO REMIND YOU ALL THAT CHILDREN
ARE NOT ENTITLED TO GOVERNMENT
APPOINTED REPRESENTATION IN
IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS. LEGAL
REPRESENTATION IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL CRITICAL IN TODAY'S
POLITICAL CLIMATE WHERE
CHILDREN ARE FACING INCREASED
PUSH BACK FROM U. S.
CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES AND THE RULES RELATED
TO IMMIGRATION RELIEF ARE
CHANGING ALMOST ON A DAILY
BASIS. IN MANY COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THERE IS NO
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE RECEIVE THE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY TO OBTAIN
IMMIGRATION RELIEF. AS A RESULT
OF A LEVEL THAT ASSISTANCE- THE
LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE THAT A
FOSTER YOUTH GETS ON OUR
IMMIGRATION CASE VARIES FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE
AND LA WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY TO
IDENTIFY AND DOCUMENT IT
CLIENTS. ASSESS THEIR
IMMIGRATION NEEDS PREPARE THE
ORDERS THAT THEY NEED TO ACCESS
FOR EXAMPLE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS. AND LINK THEM
TO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
PRO BONO ATTORNEYS WHO CAN
DIRECTLY REPRESENT THEM I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT DCFS RECENTLY
SIGNED A CONTRACT WITH A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION CALLED
THAT STATIC. AND THAT'S WHAT IT
IS REPRESENTING MANY OF OUR
CITIES ELIGIBLE CLIENTS.
SIMILAR SITUATION IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. SAN DIEGO COUNTY HAS A
MEMO OF UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
SAME DIEGO VOLUNTEER LAWYER
PROGRAM TO WORK WITH SUCH
APPLICANTS MAY ALSO PARTNER
WITH OTHER A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK WITH-
THERE OTHER CLIENTS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER FORMS OF
RELIEF. AND THEY WORK WITH
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS TO INVEST
IN ARRANGING A MEDICAL
EVALUATIONS TRANSPORTATION
INTERVIEWS OBTAINING ALL THE
NECESSARY IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS. WANT TO CONTRAST
THAT WITH THE EXPERIENCE IN
SACRAMENTO IN PLASTER COUNTIES
WHERE OUR ATTORNEYS AT SEAL C.
TRY TO LOCATE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND PRO BONO
ATTORNEYS REPRESENT OUR CLIENTS
IN THEIR IMMIGRATION CASES BUT
WE ROUTINELY HAVE TO PAY
PRIVATE COUNSEL TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR CLIENTS GET
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION. SO
ON THE WHOLE CALIFORNIA HAS A
PATCHWORK SYSTEM FOR PROVIDING
REPRESENTATION TO UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH AND THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING SOME BUT FAR TOO MANY
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH ARE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND THEIR-
AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM WITHOUT
EVER HAVING BEEN. WITHOUT EVER
HAVING BEEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ACCESS LEAVE
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO. AT
THE SOLUTION THAT WE PROPOSE TO
THIS IS STATEWIDE FUNDING FOR
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA. ADD TO THIS NCLC IS
CO SPONSORED A BILL MAYBE
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR I HAD THAT
HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN YOUR
MATERIALS- AND THAT WOULD
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR QUALIFIED
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
REPRESENT UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER
YOUTH. AND THEIR IMMIGRATION
CASES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH DON'T LOSE ACCESS
TO THE IMMIGRATION STATUS AT
THE QUALIFY FOR SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY OUR DEPENDENCE ON THE
COUNTY. AND IT'S NECESSARY TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF A DOCUMENT
A FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITE- LET
ME START BY AGAIN THINKING YOU-
AND ALSO FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND TAKING YOUR STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT THE DATE-
BUT ALSO IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
INCLUDE IMMIGRATION AS ONE OF
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
CHILDREN WILL BE IN I'M IN LA
COUNTY AS WELL AS AT THE SAME-
MY NAME IS JOSEPH GELATIN I'VE
BEEN THE DIRECTOR POLICY NOT
BECAUSE IF WHAT YOU'RE LEFT
WITH THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH
IS A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
WOULD NATIONAL IMPACT WHAT
BANDS THE RIGHTS. OF IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES THIS LEGISLATIVE
YEAR AND THE BUDGET UP ON
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSES TO THAT
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
IMMIGRANTS BUT THEN ALSO
CREATES A WELCOMING ENVIRONMENT
AND STAY FOR ALL OF THEM SOME
OF THOSE VICTIMIZED IT
VICTORIES INCLUDE INVESTMENT TO
THE CENSUS INVESTMENT TO WAS
HOW HEALTHCARE INVESTMENT
TOWERS- AND MAKING A PERMANENT-
BUDGET ITEMS- LEGAL SERVICES TO
HELP THOSE THOSE EMERGENCY NEED
AND MOST RECENTLY A POTENTIAL
ALLOCATION OF FIVE MILLION FOUR
DOT COM- LEGAL AND FILING FEES
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE AT A PAN THE
CASE IN THE SUPREME COURT. JULY
WAS ALSO SPONSORED LEGISLATION
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME HE
WOULD ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS AND THAT CITIZENS TO
BE APPOINTED TO BOARD AND
COMMISSION SOMETHING THAT WE
FEEL IS IMPORTANT FOR MAKERS TO
BE INTEGRATED BUT ALSO A
SPONSOR OUT LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A NEW CAR GRANT AS
MENTIONED BEFORE- BUT ALSO
INCLUDE A DREAM LACE ON IN ALL
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AND BECAUSE
THEY SO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
STUDENTS HAVE A SOMEONE TO TALK
TO BUT THEN ALSO EXPANDED DREAM
LOAN PROGRAMS FOR THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY ADVANCING INTO
PROFESSIONAL. DEGREES OUT WHY
WE CELEBRATE THESE ADVANCEMENTS
THAT A LOT MORE THAT THE NEEDS
TO BE DONE I'M ANDY CELEBRATION
ESSENTIALLY MARKS A REALITY IT
TO TELL REALITY WHAT IS THAT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO OUR STATE
PASSED PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH THE MAJORITY OF
HOLLY FOR INDICATING THAT THEY
WANT. TO ACTUALLY. I DID NOT
ACCESS TO. AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
LANCE TO LAUNCH ATTACKS. TOWARD
IMMIGRANTS CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP IS NOT A LUXURY BUT
A NECESSITY. TO PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS- PREVIOUS OBVIOUS
BECAUSE MENTION THE GENERAL
DEMOGRAPHICS OF IMMIGRANTS I
WILL NOT GOING TO DETAILS. I'M
MORE INTO THAT BUT I JUST LIKE
TO GO MORE SPECIFIC IN REGARDS
TO BACK UP. THE BACKUP
POPULATION. AS MENTIONED MANY-
FOLKS ARE OUT COULD BE.
RECEIVING THAT BENEFIT THAT
PROTECTION. THE RECENT REPORTER
BY OUT MIGRATION POLICY
INSTITUTE INDICATE THAT ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND- I STUDENTS
ACROSS THE NATION COULD BENEFIT
OUT OF THAT. AND WHAT ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND I ACTUALLY
CALLED CALIFORNIA THEIR HOME SO
WE HAVE THE BIGGEST POPULATION
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE. GOING
TO HAVE THAT PROTECTION AND
GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
OKAY OUR- OR- HIGHER EDUCATION.
ALSO DOCTOR RECIPIENTS ARE
PARENTS TO SEVENTY THREE US
BORN CHILDREN. AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS PAY ABOUT TWO POINT
ONE BILLION IN FEDERAL TAXES
AND ONE BILLION A STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES. THEIR OWN I'M
NEARLY ELEVEN THOUSAND HOMES-
AND PAY APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION- IN IN MARCHES
AND ABOUT NINETY MILLION IN
RENTAL PAYMENTS EIGHT YEARS SO.
AS MENTIONED DOCTOR RECIPIENTS
ARE PART OF ALSO OUR OUR
COMMUNITY. I'M AND THEREFORE
ARE ARE THEY THE SUCCESS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE A STACK TO DE
COMICS OF SAYS NOT ONLY FROM
DOCTOR RECIPIENTS BUT IT ANY.
ANY IMMIGRANT. IN THE LAST
BUDGET- CYCLE WE WAS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AS A
STATE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- INVEST IN THE FUTURE
BUT THEN ALSO WE- WE- WILL. WE
PROVIDE SOME- SOME RESEARCH FOR
WINNING THE RAINY DAY COMES AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT. HAVING SAID
THAT THERE WERE SOME MISSED A
PATERNITY IS- AND ONE OF THOSE
WAS IN REGARDS TO THEY THEY
INVESTMENT TOWARDS EXPANDING
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT-
CAL ATC. FRONT DOCUMENT TO
WORKERS. IN ADDITION TO THAT
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
FOR THE ELDERLY AS- I'LL AS IS
BECAUSE PRIVATELY MENTION.
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN IN DAY
STAY FOR TEN YEARS AND THEY
HAVE INVESTED AND THEREFORE WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF THEM WHEN THEY BECOME
ELDERLY- AND LASTLY GIVEN THAT
WE HAD TO DOCK- SUPREME COURT
HEARING COMING UP IN NOVEMBER
TWELVE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
INVEST AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
PROTECT- THOSE. THOSE
IMMIGRANTS. HAVING SAID THAT-
THE CAL- THE TAX EXPANSION IS
CRITICAL FOR US GIVEN THAT
IMMIGRANTS CONTRIBUTE AS
WORKERS- AND WE KNOW OUR HOPE
IS THAT WE REQUEST THAT. THEY
WILL BE INCLUDED- AND IN ANY
TYPE OF EXPANSION. I'M IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT ABOUT THREE
MILLION WORKERS WILL BENEFIT
FROM THAT NEW NEW EXPANSION.
HOWEVER UP CLOSE TO FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES WILL
NOT BE. WHEN I HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS BENEFIT GIVEN THAT THEY-
PAY OR IT- FATHER TAXES VIET
ACTING NUMBERS WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY NUMBER. THAT THE
IRS GIVES TO THEM TO PAY THEIR
TAXES YET THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ANYTHING BACK IN RETURN.
APPROXIMATELY NINETY THOUSAND
ALSO I'M- OUR CHILDREN. UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX- I WILL NOT BE
RECEIVING THOSE THOSE BENEFITS.
I'M OUR WORK OUR MEMBERS- JULY
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
HOSTILE WORKERS. OUR DAY LABORS
ARE STREET VENDORS WE USUALLY
WORK IN THE FORMAL INDUSTRY AND
EVERY SINGLE DAY WE ARCH THEM
TODAY AND FOR THEM TO FILE
THEIR TAXES. BECAUSE AS WE SEE
ME QUESTION FOR POTENTIALLY
MOVING UP AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
PAYING TAXES IS ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE SEEN IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF- BILLS TO
HAVING JUST AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. SO MOST OF OUR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY- FATHER TAXES- AND FOR
US A SEIZURE BUT EQUITY BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY'RE
PAYING THEIR TAXES AND IT'S A
MATTER. OF THEM GETTING THEIR
MONEY BACK- IN RETURN. BASED ON
ON ON DATA AND REPORTERS AT THE
DISASSEMBLY DEVELOP IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THEY STAY WOULD
ONLY I SPENT ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY. TO PROVIDE
THAT BENEFIT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. SO IF IMMIGRANTS
ARE AND BILL IS IN DOLLARS WHY.
WE NOW CAN I GIVE SIXTY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. LASTLY ASIDE
PERMEATES AT ONE OF THE OTHER
KEY PRIORITIES MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE. THE USA LABOR
SENATE YOU SEE BERKELEY LABOR
SENATE INDICATES THAT ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIA'S. I
BAR DUCKS HEALTHCARE MOST OF
MOST OF THEM ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT. THE
BUILDING INSTALL- BY SENATOR
RUSSELL- AND ASK SOMEBODY-
MEMBER ENSEMBLE THAT OUGHT TO
BE EVASIVE BUT THEN ALSO
PROVIDE RESOURCES. AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT BASED ON ON
CONVERSATION BY GOVERNOR NEEDS
SOME AND SENATOR RUSSELL THAT
HE WILL COMMIT TO INCLUDE THAT
IN THE BUDGET AND HAVING TWO.
GREAT CHAMPIONS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES WE HOPE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WILL. WILL MOVE
FOR WHAT. I'M AND. AND LASTLY I
WILL SAY THAT I C. RELEASED IT
THAT K. I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO MOVE FORWARD DOES NOT
DENOUNCE BEN AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE I SAID IT'S A PENDING
WAITING THAT PROVIDE A LINK IS
THAT YOU'RE BITING EVE DHAKA
IS- IS IT ELIMINATED WHICH
COULD BE AS SOON AS JANUARY OR
IN JUNE THE QUESTION BECOMES
WHAT IS IT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH
THAT POPULATION GIVEN THAT THEY
ALREADY ARE IN THE PROFESSIONS
ARE PAYING TAXES- AND LASTLY A
KEY ASPECT OF A MINOR. WHO MAY
HAVE GOT BACK UP AND NOW IT'S
OVER EIGHTEEN THERE'S A KEY
PROVISION UNDER FEDERAL LAW
THAT SAID THAT ONCE YOU START
ACCUMULATING UNLAWFUL PRESENCE
DOCKING BAR YOU FROM IS STATING
THE OBVIOUS THREE YEARS OR TEN
YEARS DEPENDING ON YOUR
SITUATION SO THAT IS CRITICAL
FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHO GOT BACK I WENT UNDER
EIGHTEEN WON'T WON'T BE
PENALIZED IN THE FUTURE MY DATE
THREE AT TEN YEAR BAR. I'M
LASTLY WHEN THE THINGS THAT I
DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT WE
YOU KNOW BASED ON THE RESEARCH
THAT WE SO WE HAVE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PUBLISHING OF
IMMIGRANTS- AT AND YET WE DON'T
HAVE AN AGENCY- SECRETARY THAT
SEEKS TO PROVIDE A BOLD VISION
FOR IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION WE
HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THAT SERVES ABOUT THREE
POINT TWO MILLION CUSTOMERS
EVERY YEAR WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS US THERE'S
ABOUT ONE TO ONE MILLION.
VETERANS WHEN WE HAVE TEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS AND WHILE WE
HAVE SOMEONE APPOINTED WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
APARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICE HAS A
GREAT CHAMPIONS OUT WITHIN THAT
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE A
SECRETARY NORTH AGENCY THAT
WILL HELP THEM AND COMPLEMENT
THEIR WORK- AND AGAIN I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO I APPRECIATE
YOUR STAFFING YOU FOR BEING IN
THIS HEARING. FOR I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING FULLER WE
DON'T. THANK YOU. THAT. NO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS. AND CERTAINLY- I
HEAR YOU WHEN YOU SAY THERE ARE
EVEN MORE WE CAN DO AS
CALIFORNIA- I GUESS THE I WOULD
SORT OF POSE THIS QUESTION-
AND- WHO'S GONNA TRANSFER THAT
BUT YOU KNOW PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO. AS WE ARE TRYING TO
DO OUR EFFORTS IN THE STATE OF
COURSE FOR SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME AND EFFORT TRYING TO
OVERCOME THINGS ARE COMING DOWN
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THERE ARE
ELECTIONS COMING UP- THIS IS A-
PUBLIC. SENATE HEARING SO
THERE'S NO OPINION- AT THAT I'M
EXPRESSING HERE ABOUT. WHAT
SITES PEOPLE TAKE. ON THE
ELECTION WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
AFTER THE HEARINGS OVER- BUT-
WHAT ARE SOME THINGS THAT. YOUR
THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF THEIR
THINGS WE ARE GOING TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO TRY TO DO IT STATE
BUT- WHAT KIND OF ISSUES DO YOU
THINK NEED TO BE DISCUSSED.
WHEN IT COMES TO ASIDE FROM ON
DOING A LOT OF THE STUFF THEY
WERE DOING THAT- THAT THAT YOU
THINK ARE LIKE THE TOP PRIORITY
BECAUSE YOU CAN SPEND ALL DAY
TALKING ABOUT. IN TERMS OF.
CHANGING. ON AND TERMS OF
FEDERAL POLICY WE SHOULD BE
DISCUSSING AS WE GET CLOSER TO
NOT ONLY PRIMARIES FOR
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO FOR.
BASICALLY ALL THE CONGRESS
PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT VIEWS IN
OUR CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION-
AND- AS WELL AS YOU KNOW OTHER
OTHER REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL.
SO BUSH I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE AT TWELVE FORTY FIVE DO
YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I'D GIVE YOU A SHOT
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
LEÓN ONLY IF YOU WANT TO.
THANK YOU DODD DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES. OKAY SO I THINK AS
AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF IF I WISH
ONE THING IT SHOULD BE
SOMEWHERE WHAT ACCULTURATION
PROCESS IT SHOULD BE SOMEWHERE
LIKE A SYSTEM THAT NAVIGATE IT
TODAY MING CULTURE. I THINK AS
AN IMMIGRANT IMMIGRATION AND
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES THAT'S THE
MAJOR ISSUE IS THIS IS OUR
CULTURE BE AREA THERE'S A STICK
MODEST SO MUCH IN SOCIAL AND
PRE AND POST TRAUMA AND LOST
ALL THIS IS WE CARRY SO MUCH-
LEVEL OF ISSUES TO BRING WITH
OUR SELF YET. WE ARE ALSO
EXPECTED JUST TO FIT THE CISCO
SYSTEM OR BUSINESS ANY SECTORS.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE GREAT
CONTRIBUTION TO ANY SECTOR
STERN AND I STATE IT WAS
PRESENTED EARLIER WHEN IS OF
AFRICAN AND- IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE A LOT OF FAT CONTRIBUTION
AT THE INTEGRATED PENETRATED
WITH EVERY SECTOR HOWEVER BUT
THE NEW ARRIVAL MAINLY THE
CHILDREN WE DON'T HAVE THE
SYSTEM THAT NAVIGATE. TO THE
MAIN CULTURE AND ALSO- BRING
GAINES OR TRYING TO LEARN EACH
OTHER CULTURE AND THE RESPECT
OF WHAT IS THE OTHERS
PROSPECTIVE VERSUS JUST
SPECIALLY RIGHT NOW THIS THE
POLITICAL- CLIMB IT WOULDN'T
ALLOW US TO BE WHO WE ARE AS A
CULTURAL. IS LIKE TO BE
AMERICAN IF NOT YOU DON'T FIT
HERE THAT'S THE KIND OF
ATTITUDE WE GETTING SO THE
MOTHER THE CHILDREN GOING WITH
THE MOST M. COMMUNITIES HAS-
WHAT IS A GOOD JOB WE HAVE THAT
INCIDENTS IMAGINE RARING HIS
CHILDREN HOW YOU RESPOND HOME
THE SURFACE STEP IN. THAT'S THE
KIND OF HAVE REALLY DISSECT
EACH ISSUES TO GET INVOLVED
MAKE SURE IT'S MORE PREVENTIVE
EDUCATIONAL VERSUS PRIMITIVE
ANY SECTORS THE STAFF IS TAKEN
AWAY WELL THAT'S THEIR JOB BUT
HOW DO WE EXPLAIN TO THEM THIS
IS HOW WE CULTURE PROSPECT IS
NOT ABOUT- WHAT IS THAT NEGLECT
OR ABUSE. THOSE ARE THE THINGS
OF LITTLE THINGS MIGHT BE
NOTHING BUT M. IS A LOT TO US
BECAUSE THEY SAID EARLY SARAH
DETAINEES ARRIVED WHEN THEY
ARRIVE HERE A LITTLE FOOD MEANS
A LOT TO THEM LISTEN I'VE BEEN
HUNGRY. IT'S ASSISTS MALES
BELONGINGNESS WE HAVE TO BE. IT
WAS STRENGTHENED IDENTITY
WITHOUT- SEPARATION THAT'S WHAT
I'M ASKING THANK YOU. AT LEAST
FOR SO ALEX JULY SEEKING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A STRATEGY
FOR NEXT YEAR'S STARTING ONE OF
THEM IS HOW IS THAT CALIFORNIA
LEADERS ENSURE THAT THEY CLOSE
TO THREE MILLION LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS ARE READY
TO BECOME CITIZENS BECOME
CITIZENS FOR TO PULL TWO MAIN
REASONS ONE IS IN REGARDS TO
THE POLITICAL- REALITY ONCE YOU
BECOME A CITIZEN YOU HAVE THAT
YOU KNOW THE RIGHT TO VOTE. I'M
SO THAT CAN CHANGE DRAMATICALLY
BUT THEN TO ALSO RELATED TO THE
BUDGET EVE FOLKS BECOME CITIZEN
THEM THAT THE STATE WILL GET
REIMBURSED REGARDS TO THE
WHATEVER SERVICES THAT THEY
THAT THEY CAN DO FOR US IS- WE
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONVEYED IS A STRATEGY
TO ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT MAYBE
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIFTH WE OUGHT
TO HAVE A GOAL OF NATURALIZING
ONE MILLION- THE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE. AND THAT CAN CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY THE POLITICAL
LANDSCAPE ACROSS THE STATE BUT
THEN ALSO- ISOLATES OUR BUDGET
THE SECOND ASPECT IS HOW YOU
KNOW WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR- AND THE LIKE IS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO IMMIGRANT A
SPECIFIC AREA OF WORK- BUT I
THINK WE ALSO SEE HOW IS THAT
WE CAN DO THAT LEVEL OF THE
SAME LEVEL OF WORK THAT WE DO
IN IN CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN.
ELECTED OFFICIALS INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR GO ABROAD AND SO LIKE
WE ARE DOING THIS GREAT WORKING
WHEN I CHAMPION WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALSO ELEVATE THAT
THE SAME LEVEL OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WITH IMMIGRATION BECAUSE
THE TWO OF THEM ARE ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
THERE ACTUALLY FLEEING THOSE
COUNTRIES BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE SO HOW DO WE TIE THE TWO
THINGS TO TOGETHER. TO THE
BALLPARK BET THAT THAT THAT-
SOME OF YOU HAVE I'M LASTLY AS
AT LEAST FOR US IT'S LIKE HOW
DO WE CREATE SYSTEMS IN PLACE
THAT- OUR I SEEKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS OUR AGENCIES ARE
INCLUSIVE THAT THERE IS A CO I
COME DRIVEN DATA THAT WE CAN
SHOW LIKE IF WE DO A THAT MEANS
THAT FOLKS WILL HAVE A BETTER
OUTCOME EITHER A JOB WHAT
LANGUAGE ACQUISITION. JEAN
THERE'S MEANTIME WORK BEST
WITHIN WITH EIGHT C. AND NOT
SEE A GREAT A GREAT REST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. SERVICES
TRYING TO INTEGRATE THEIR MODEL
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TRACK.
FROM A PROJECT WITH THE PROJECT
MANAGER THAT DOWN TO LOOK AT
THE WORK. THIS REPRESENTATION
IS CRITICAL TO ALLOWING M. GUNS
TO ACCESS THE RELIEF THAT THEY
QUALIFY FOR AND ALSO TO
CHALLENGE UNJUST POLICIES OR TO
CHALLENGE- I'M JUST
INTERPRETATIONS OF CURRENT AND
IMMIGRATION LAWS. MISTER
POWERS- WHAT'S THE TOTAL
POPULATION IF YOU SENATE I
MISSED OF THE TOTAL POPULATION
OF UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN
BOTH THE FEDERAL FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND OUR STATE SYSTEM.
FEDERAL FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I
DON'T HAVE THOSE FIGURES IN
FRONT OF ME BUT IN OUR STATE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM THAT'S ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
IS ASSESSING EXACTLY HOW MANY
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO MECHANISM.
FOR SCREENING ARE IN DOCUMENT-
EXCUSE ME FOR SCREENING ARE
FOSTER YOU REALLY COOL STATUS-
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH OTHER
COUNTIES IN BASED ON ESTIMATES
FROM OTHER COUNTIES WE- GUESS
THAT THERE IS ABOUT- WE
ESTIMATE THAT THERE IS ABOUT
BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR
HUNDRED UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER
YOUTH. EVERY YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA- I KNOW THAT IN LA
COUNTY ACCORDING TO MY COUNT WE
HAVE AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED
ONGOING CASES THAT WE ESTIMATE
THREE HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
NEWMAN DOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH
ENTERING THE SYSTEM EVERY YEAR.
STATEWIDE STATEWIDE AND JUST TO
GIVE ME A THE UNIVERSE BUT JUST
YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL I WILL
HOLD YOU TO THE NUMBER BUT JUST
I'M TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND. THE NUMBER IN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM. IN THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM. YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE
TO LOOK INTO THAT I MEAN ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT TENS OF THOUSANDS.
IN I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THAT I MOST OF MY CLIENTS PRIOR
TO JOINING C. S. HERE WORKED AT
KIDS IN NEED OF DEFENSE I WAS
REPRESENTING UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS MAY HAVE BEEN RELEASED
SPONSORS YEAH THEY WERE NOT
PART OF THE A FEDERAL FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. YES I WOULD WANT
TO LOOK INTO THAT AND I
WOULDN'T WANT TO GIVE AN IN
CROWD CAMBER OKAY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THE THING IS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO THE PANEL FOR
YOUR TIME DEEPLY APPRECIATED I
THINK. YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD AS A- TRUE
REFLECTION WHICH WAS A PART OF
OUR GOAL TODAY. IS TO BROADEN
OUR THINKING AND OUR
CONVERSATION AROUND. WHO THE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IS. AND
THE DIFFERENT KIND OF UNIQUE
NEEDS AND SERVICES WE AS A
GOVERNMENT. WITH OUR PARTNER
AGENCIES NEED TO STEP UP TO
PROVIDE SO THANK YOU I THINK
THE PANEL IS A REFLECTION OF
THAT. SHE TOO YOU'RE WELCOME.
SO WE'VE COME TO THE END OF OUR
AGENDA AS WITH ANY PUBLIC
HEARING WE OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF I COULD SEE
BY A SIGN OF HANDS HOW MANY
PEOPLE INTEND TO SPEAK. OKAY
GIVEN THE TIME EVERYONE'S GOING
TO HAVE ONE MINUTE WE HAVE A
TIME KEEPER. AND IF YOU'VE EVER
SEEN ME IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN ME-
RUNNING HEARING. YOU'LL KNOW
THAT I WILL CUT YOU OFF.
BECAUSE THE MORE TIME YOU TAKE
IT'S LESS TIME FOR THE PEOPLE
BEHIND YOU IN LINE. AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE.
SO IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
EITHER YOUR STATEMENT OR
QUESTION. AND YOU'LL HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO DO SO. THANK YOU. I'M
SURE RAIN AND SENATOR I GREW UP
IN BALDWIN HILLS WENT TO.
AUDUBON GRADUATED DORSEY AT
SIXTY SIX. AND MY QUESTION IS
FOR MS MORROW IS SHE STILL HERE.
GOOD BOTH OKAY BECAUSE MY SON
WAS A TWO A CHEMISTRY TEACHER A
MANUAL ARTS HIGH SCHOOL WHICH
IS A AN INNER CITY SCHOOL. AND
HE WOULD FAIL 60% OF HIS KIDS
EACH YEAR. HE'S NOW A RESIDENT
DOCTOR AT TRIPLER HOSPITAL IN
HONOLULU. AND ONE OF HIS
FRIENDS WAS HIS FORMER STUDENT-
ALTHOUGH THAT WASN'T THE ISSUE
ALREADY SPOKE THAT TO HIM WITH
HIM. THE OTHER ONE IS THAT WHEN
HE WAS A TEACHER HE ALSO STAYED
AFTERWARDS AND HAD THE KIDS
RUN. AND HE HADN'T HAD TO GET
M. CLEAR THEY RAN MARATHONS
EVERY YEAR INCLUDING THE LA
MARATHON. BUT HE COULDN'T GET
THEM CLEARED. SO HE HAD TO
ACCOMPANY EACH KID TO THE
CLINIC TO SEE A DOCTOR BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T GET IN TO SEE A
DOCTOR. AND HE WAS OUTRAGED SO
I NEED THIS NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. BECAUSE HE SAID THE
YOU KNOW HE WAS JUST DEVASTATED
HE SAID WHEN HE'S A DOCTOR IS
GOING TO WORK AND CLINICS. SO
THAT'S MY COMPUTER FOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE GOOD. AFTERNOON NOW MY
NAME IS THE SONG EACH RAISING
HAVE THE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
WELFARE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
PROGRAM IN LA COUNTY AS WELL AS
A CHILD HEALTH AND DISABILITY
PREVENTION PROGRAM. I
APPRECIATE THIS HEARING TODAY.
I'M SO I'M ALSO A CLINICIAN AT
ALL OF UCLA MEDICAL CENTER AND
I WANTED TO PROVIDE COMMENT ON
THREE AREAS THAT I THINK YOU
MAY WANT TO FOCUS ON I'M IN THE
FUTURE. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHT I THOUGHT STARTED PAN
ON HOW TO OPERATIONALIZE. I'M
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL- FOR
PROVIDERS SO I'VE WITNESSED M.
IN MY ROLES THAT FAMILIES ARE
SEEKING CARE ONLY FOR
THEMSELVES. AND THEIR CHILDREN
IN SITUATIONS M. OUR TECHNICAL
NEEDS TO THE FEAR FACTOR THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED. VOTING
INSIGNIFICANT. AND MORE ABOUT
MORTALITY AND PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE IS I LET THE LAST THING
THAT PEOPLE WANT ACCESS BECAUSE
THEY MAY BE. TARGETED BEFORE
ACCESSING HEALTH SERVICES SO.
I'M PERHAPS PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS
NEED ADDITIONAL EDUCATION ON
ADVISING FAMILIES REGARDING
ACCESS TO CARE AND THAT MAYBE
LIKE A- PIECE OF THAT. THE
OPERATIONAL LOOP THAT YOU MIGHT
PULL. IT TOO ESPECIALLY WITH DH
THE EIGHT I. PROVIDING GUIDANCE
TO PROVIDERS ON HOW TO ADVISE
THEIR FAMILIES TO SEEK
COVERAGE- OKAY WHY LEGAL
INFORMATION SOURCE EDUCATING
PROVIDERS- WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
REMAIN UP TO DATE ON THE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS OF ACCESS TO
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND GUIDANCE ON
ENROLLMENT- AND THAT'S
CURRENTLY LACKING. I'M GONNA
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP IF YOU HAVE
IT IN WRITING YOU CAN SUBMIT IT
TIGHT TO HAVE IT IN WRITING AND
I'LL ALSO ADMIT IT'S YOU AND
THE OTHER AREA IS MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH- AND-
EDUCATING PROVIDERS ON TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. I'M AND
SCREENING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THOSE SERVICES FINALLY IN
REALLY- IMPORTANTLY CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS
ON. MAY LOSE ACCESS TO FULL
SCOPE MEDIC HOW IT EACH TWENTY
ONE. AND AT THAT POINT THEY
KIND OF DROP OFF THE HEALTH
CARE CAN'T CLIFF I'M LOSING
ACCESS TO SUCH SPECIALTY CARE.
AS WELL AS- LEE IT MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND THERAPY SERVICES
SO THEIR SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION. WE DON'T HAVE DATA
BECAUSE WE DON'T ASK ABOUT I
IMMIGRATION STATUS ON THE
NUMBERS OF CHILDREN WHO MAY NOT
BE ACCESSING THE SERVICES. AND
THE D. CELL THANK MY NAME IS
ALLISON THANK YOU. SO I'M GONNA
SAY AGAIN ONE MINUTE. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE AT THE MIKE YOU
DON'T SEE THE EXPRESSIONS OF
ALL THE. OTHER PEOPLE BEHIND
YOU WHO REALIZE THAT YOU'VE
GONE OVER THE MINUTE. SO AGAIN
OUT OF RESPECT TO THE PEOPLE
BEHIND YOU IN LINE TO TAKE WITH
YOU HAVE IT IN WRITING YOU CAN
GIVE IT TO A SUB. AND IT WILL
BE GIVEN TO US SO ONE MINUTE
PLEASE YOUR NAME. THANK YOU
DEBORAH COLEMAN DIRECTOR FOR
THE OFFICE FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
ALSO IN THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
THE IMPACT OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY IS FACING- RIGHT NOW
WE ARE SEEING A DECREASE IN
ATTENDANCE DUE TO THE
IMMIGRATION. CLIMATES OF
CHILDREN ATTENDING EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS. AND
ALSO OUR- EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVIDERS LACK THE
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION. OZ'S
TRUSTED GATEKEEPER TO GIVE-
IMMIGRATION POLICY INFORMATION.
TO THE PARENTS THAT THEY SERVE.
I SHARE WITH YOU TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS I'D LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER ONE IS SUPPORTING THE
FUNDING. FOR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH IMMIGRANTS
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY
HAVE THE TOOLS TO WORK WITH
FAMILIES. THE SECOND IS ABOUT
FUNDING TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
TRAINING FOR EARLY EDUCATORS SO
THEY CAN BETTER SUPPORT- THE-
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WHO
EXPERIENCED STRESS. AND UNEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT AND FOR THE WITNESSES. THE
TIME KEEPER IS THERE TO HELP
YOU FIRST LET. THANK YOU
SENATOR IS AND THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ROSE VENUE I GUESS AND I SERVE
THE IMMIGRANT HEALTH ACCESS
TASK FORCE OF LA CUNY. I WORKED
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION. WE SUPPORTED
THROUGH THE IMMIGRANT HOUSE
ACCESS TASK FORCE. ASSISTANCE
IN ENROLLMENT FOR MEDICAID
EXPANSION FOR ALL KIDS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS ELEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
WERE ASSISTED AS PART OF THE
ESPY SEVENTY FIVE EFFORT. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SP SEVENTY
FIVE ROLLOUT IT TOOK THREE
CONTACTS IN ADDITION TO THE TWO
NOTIFICATIONS FROM DH CS TO GET
SOMEONE TO ACCEPT INFORMATION
AROUND SP SEVENTY FIVE. A YEAR
LATER INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF SP SEVENTY FIVE IT TOOK
TWICE AS MANY IF NOT MORE
CONTACTS ON TOP OF THE DH CS
NOTIFICATIONS. WE WILL STAND AS
IMMIGRANT HEALTH ACCESS TASK
FORCE WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS
EXPANSION IS ADVANCED TO YOUNG
ADULTS BUT WE OFFER THE
IMMIGRANT HEALTH ACCESS TASK
FORCE AS A RESOURCE. TO YOUR
OFFICE MS MAILLOT AND TIM IS
RELEASED TO ENHANCE YOUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS AND TO GET TO
THE TRUSTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO ARE WORKING ON THE FRONT
LINES WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT AND FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP NEXT WITNESS. HI
LESLIE HI MY CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
QUESTION THAT THE LAST QUESTION
YOU POSE TO THE PANEL I'D LIKE
TO ADD TO THINGS- ONE IS THAT
AS THERE ARE THERE'S A LITTLE
POCKET IN THE CHILDREN'S
BUREAU. OF CURRENT EMPLOYEES OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHO ARE
ACTUALLY DOING GOOD WORK AND
WANTING TO HELP US SERVE
FAMILIES BETTER- ONE COMES IN
THE FORM OF FAMILY FIRST WHICH
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN
ENTHUSIASTIC. ABOUT JUMPING
INTO BUT IT'S A SYSTEM THAT IS
DESIGNED OR FUNDING THAT IS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE THE
SEPARATION OF FAMILIES AND KEEP
MORE CHILDREN AT HOME WE NEED
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. AND
THE SECOND RELATES TO FORI
FUNDING FOR ATTORNEYS FOR
CHILDREN AND PARENTS WHICH OUR
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR DID A
BEAUTIFUL JOB OF QUICKLY
ADOPTING NECESSARY BUDGET ITEM
SO THAT WE COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT. BUT IMPLEMENTATION IS TO
DATE NONEXISTENT- IS FIVE
MONTHS AND WE HAVE YET TO HAVE
A PROCESS IN PLACE THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO DRIVE DOWN THOSE
FUNDS SO WE ARE AT RISK OF
LEAVING FEDERAL DOLLARS ON THE
TABLE. AND ALL THOSE DOLLARS
WILL HELP CHARLES LIMIT MYSELF
ABOUT THAT PLEASE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. HI I'M DANIELLE
ONE DROVE WITH CHILDREN NOW- WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR KIDS OF COLOR- AS WELL AS
KIDS LIVING IN POVERTY AND IN
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES- TO MAKE
SURE THAT CAN GROW UP HEALTHY.
AND READY FOR COLLEGE CAREER
AND CIVIC LIFE- WE NEED TO
ENSURE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION FOR ALL
STATE SERVICES THAT SUPPORT
FAMILIES- AND SO THAT THOSE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED BY
TRUSTED MESSENGERS. AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES- WERE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SENSE. YOU
KNOW THAT AND CHILDREN BEING IN
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE HIGH
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS. LIVING
IN COMPLEX FAMILY SITUATIONS IN
HOMES WHERE ENGLISH IS NOT THE
FIRST LANGUAGE UNEVEN HOMELESS
CHILDREN. ARE AMONG THOSE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO
COUNT IN THE UPCOMING CENSUS-
SO GIVEN THESE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES WE WANT TO STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE. OF THE STATE
INSURANCE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION MATERIALS
ADVERTISEMENTS MESSAGING AND
TRAINING OF SENT CENSUS
WORKERS- TO ADDRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF COUNTING ALL
YOUNG CHILDREN. THANK YOU FOR
SHAKE THAT NEXT WITNESS GOOD
MORNING SENATOR MITCHELL'S.
SENATE PAN AGAIN MY NAME IS
JAMES MARMOT FIRST FIVE LA AND
SO I'M ACTUALLY OCCUR TO THANK
BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. WORKING WITH
GOVERNORS IN THIS ACTUALLY-
INVESTING TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN. IN SUPPORT
FOR CHILDREN WHICH ULTIMATELY
HELPS ADDRESSED THE ISSUE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. ULTIMATELY
WE KNOW THAT FIRST FIVE LA THAT
90% OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
ZERO TO FIVE. SOLD MILLIE THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED
WHETHER IT'S CHILDCARE HOME
VISITING OR DEVELOPMENT OF ST
SCREENINGS. IS IMPERATIVE WHICH
IS WHAT YOU ALL HELPED INVEST
IN SO WE TREAT TRUDY THANK YOU
ABOUT THAT. AND JUST FOLLOWING
UP ON MY CALLER DEBORAH'S
COMMENTS WE KNOW FROM EARLY
LEARNING PARTNERS THAT CHILDREN
TURN UP THE CHILD CARE.
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS. CHILDREN TRYING
TO OPEN THE SCREENINGS SO IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPERATIVE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE OUR
PARTNERS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
THAT THEY'RE STILL ABLE TO
APPLY FOR THESE SERVICES
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC CHARGE. WHICH IS AN
ISSUE WE WORKED ON HEAVILY
WHETHER LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL- ADVOCATES TO REALLY
HELP PEOPLE ELEVATE THE ISSUE
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT. THE
ISSUE NEEDS TO BE TALKED ABOUT
IT MORE BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THIS. PAST YEAR YOU
BOTH HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN THIS.
AND THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE YES. SENATE
IS MITCHELL AND PAN MY NAME IS
JESSE FIRST WEEKS ON THE
AFRICAN COALITION WE JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST
IN ALL THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW
THAT YOU'RE DOING- BUT I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE ARE
ALREADY WORKING ON EDUCATING
OUR PEOPLE THEY HAVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AFRICAN
IMMIGRANTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE GRAPHICS
THE CHARTS THAT WERE PRINTED UP
THERE WE DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING
AFRICAN EVERYTHING SAID. ALL OF
THAT WELL THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
HAS A HEADING THAT PRINTER JUST
A FEW WEEKS AGO SAYING AFRICAN
IMMIGRANTS ARE MORE EDUCATED
THAN MOST INCLUDING PEOPLE BORN
IN THE US BUT ALL THE
RESEARCHERS NEVER PUT AFRICAN
IT'S ALWAYS AUTHOR WE DON'T
WANT TO BE ALL THE ANIMAL WE
WANT TO BE KNOWN AS AFRICAN.
AND SENATE TO- YEAH IF TOMORROW
WE ARE ALREADY WORKING ON THE
PUBLIC CHARGE THE AFRICAN
COALITION WE ARE GOING OUT TO
THE COMMUNITIES WE TEACHING
THEM WE EXTENDED WORKSHOPS. SO
WE CAN TELL THEM BECAUSE THERE
IS A BIG FEAR. IN THE AFRICAN
COMMUNITY ABOUT PUBLIC CHAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU. HI MY
NAME'S TERRY CAN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
ADVOCACY AT CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE JUST REALLY WANT TO
THINK BOTH THE SENATOR MITCHELL
SENATOR PAN FOR THIS HEARING-
ONE JUST WANTED TO SHARE
CHILDREN SINCE IT IS OBVIOUS
EXTREMELY COMMITTED- TENSION
RESEARCHERS ARE THERE FOR
COMMUNITY SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SUPPORT THE CENSUS
TWENTY TWENTY OUTREACH AND- OUR
OFFICES WILL ACTUALLY BE.
SERVING A CENSUS ACTION KIOSKS
SITES- SO WE'RE HAPPY TO STAY
CONNECTED ON THAT ON BUT WE
ALSO WILL BE SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORTING DOES ZERO TO FIVE-
OUTREACH AS WELL BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IS A POPULATION HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDERCOUNTED
ONE THING WE WANTED TO SHARE AS
A RECOMMENDATION. ON IN TERMS
OF JUST HOW WE WRAP OUR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO
SUPPORT OUR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
ON IS TO LEVERAGE OUR SCHOOLS-
C. CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE IS
EMBARKING ON A NEIGHBORHOOD
SCHOOLS INITIATIVE CALMLY KNOWN
AS A COMMUNITY SCHOOL ON AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO BRING.
FULL MENTAL SERVICES ON CAMPUS
WE ARE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
FLORENCE GRIFFITH JOYNER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND WHAT'S ON
TO BRING A SPECIAL TREATMENT TO
HELP MEDICAL CLINIC AND SO
WE'RE REMOVING THOSE BARRIERS
FOR OUR FAMILIES- AND BRING
THOSE HEALTH SERVICES TO SCHOOL
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE
CAN- SUPPORTER AMERICAN
FAMILIES. YES THANK YOU THANKS
FOR COMING HERE AND I JUST
WANNA SAY COME SAMMY THAT THAT
IS HOW YOU C. THINKING CREAN
PROUD DAUGHTER OF KOREAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS YEAH SO IT
WILL REGARD FOR TOM SAHA NEED
THAT COM SON NOM HE HA. HA YEAH
HANNAH ME THAT. YES THANK YOU
IF EYES IN THE BACK YOU CAN.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
CALLING PATTERN HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. LA UNIFIED HAS
BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT M.
ENSURING ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS ARE FOR THE FREE PUBLIC
EDUCATION. OUR BOARD OF
EDUCATION AS FAR AS NUMEROUS
RESOLUTIONS DECLARING OUR
SCHOOL THE SAFE HAVENS FOR ALL
STUDENTS. AND WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ON HOW TO ADDRESS
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY. THERE ARE WE ARE ONE
LA UNIFIED CAMPAIGN WE HAVE
PROVIDED GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES AND PARTNERED
WITH THE CITY COUNTY. AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
IN SPITE OF THESE ASSURANCES
ARE PARENTS AND STUDENTS STILL
LIVE IN FEAR AND ANXIETY. IN
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE DISTRICT RECEIVED REPORTS
THAT STUDENTS WERE ABSENT DUE
TO REPORTED ICE CHECK AT
CHECKPOINTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED MAST IMMIGRATION
RAISE THIS PAST SUMMER PARENTS
WERE CALLING SCHOOLS SAYING
THAT THEY WERE AFRAID TO BRING
THEIR AND PICK UP THEIR
CHILDREN. IN ADDITION THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED RULE
CHANGES SUCH AS THE PUBLIC
CHARGE AND SNAP CHANGES. AIMED
AT CURTAILING BENEFITS TO
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES FUEL THIS
FEAR. FOR EXAMPLE FAMILIES HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN AND APPLYING
FOR SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAM. AND
ALSO EXPRESSED FEAR OF IS
SUBMITTING MEDICAL FORMS FOR
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. DESPITE STOP
REASSURANCES. FAMILIES CONTINUE
TO DECLINE THE SERVICE AS. WE
HAVE THE UNIFIED WE THANK YOU
FOR HOSTING THIS. THIS
CONVERSATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO BETTER
SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS FIRST OF
ALL I WANNA THANK- CHAIRWOMAN
MITCHELL AND SENATOR PAN FOR
THIS GREAT HEARING MY NAME IS
MARIO CHAVEZ I'M DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR ST
JOHN'S WELL CHILD AND FAMILY
CENTER PROUD TO SAY SENATOR
MITCHELL REPRESENT SEVEN OF OUR
CLINICS AND WE'RE THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF CARE TO
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATIONS OF THE
UNITED STATES- OBVIOUSLY THE
PUBLIC CHARGE RULE CHANGES
INTENDED TO CONFUSE PEOPLE AND
HAVE PEOPLE DESCEND ROLE FROM
SERVICES WE'RE BEGINNING TO GET
A LOT OF CALLS. ABOUT IT THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MAILLOT GREAT
TO HEAR THAT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED- TO
DO OUTREACH TO OUR COMMUNITIES
I'M JUST INTERESTED IN HOW WE
WOULD ACCESS THAT MONEY-
YESTERDAY WE DID A TRAINING FOR
ALL OF OUR CALL CENTER
OPERATORS ALL OF OUR- BENEFITS
ENROLLMENT COUNSELORS- WITH
WITH NEIGHBORHOOD LEAGUE
SERVICES AT- WE'RE PLANNING ON
DOING A POPULAR EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN WITH ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS BUT I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF THERE WAS. RESOURCE
ACCESS TO DO THAT TYPE OF WORK.
WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU THE
HAVE FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THE
GO. THESE CARDS PERFECT NEXT
WITNESS HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SELLING OF OUR OWN WITH
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP A
STATEWIDE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. AS NOTED EARLIER-
ONE INTO KIDS HAVE AT IMMIGRANT
PARENTS AND FOR US I'M NOT ONLY
THE CURRENT POPULATION BUT THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
DEPENDENT ON- IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES THE WORK WE DO. THE
INTERSECTION ALLERGY BETWEEN
IMMIGRATION POLICY AND HEALTH
AND FOR US HEALTH EQUITY IN
PARTICULAR IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND- AND SO SOME OF THE-
CONDITIONS WE LIKE TO PUT FORTH
AND WE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MANY OF. THE PEOPLE REFLECTED
HERE ON THE PANELS AND I'M IN
THE- AUDIENCE IS TO THINK
ABOUT- INNOVATION LIKE MEDICAL
LEGAL PARTNERSHIPS- WE'VE SEEN
SOME REALLY CREATIVE WAYS.
AGAIN IN THE DRESSING THE NEEDS
OF FAMILIES AS A WHOLE SO
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THAT. AS
WELL AS- THINKING ABOUT- THE
ACCESS POINT THAT IS VERY
COMMON IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
TOUCHES THAT. TO REACH FAMILIES
AND- AND ALSO HOW UNIQUE- IT IS
IT IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
TRANSLATION CULTURE. CONTACT
THE I THINK IT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CARRYING A SEINFELD
I'M THE MATRON RELATIONS
COORDINATOR AT THE LOS ANGELES
OR A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. WE'RE PERCENT ALMOST
TWO MILLION STUDENTS IN EIGHTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. MY POSITION
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN RESPONSE. THE
RESPONSE OF THE FEAR IN THE
COMMUNITY. M. I WANTED TO POINT
OUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR THESE
CONVENING AN A FOR ALL THE
SPEAKERS THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO
GATHER FOR TO M. VERY
IMPRESSED. M. I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT I MIGHT BE CONCERNED
THAT IN THEIR REPORT THE TERM
M. ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IS USED
ON PAGE THIRTY FOUR SO I WOULD
LIKE. IF THAT CAN BE CHANGED AS
POINT GUY BESIDES POINTING OUT
THAT I WANTED TO. POINT OUT TO
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WHILE
THERE YOU SOME REDUCTION IN
EMISSIONS. A REFUGEE LEVELS
THERE IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE TO LOOK I'D
INNOVATION US ORIGINALLY
MENTION IN THAT CASE MANAGEMENT
AREA SPECIFICALLY AND WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ASYLUM SEEKERS.
CHILDREN MOST OF THEM THAT DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO NAVIGATION
SERVICES THERE WHILE THERE IS
SOME SORT OF INVESTMENT IN
LEGAL SERVICES. I THINK IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO LOOK INTO
THAT AND LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF. YOU ARE GATHERING STERN
THERE COULD BE MORE
REPRESENTATION OF. US TALKING
ABOUT ELIGIBLE TO NATURALIZE
THIS IS ONE GROUP THAT HAS BEEN
LEFT BEHIND. SO A BEING PART OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER WITH YOU
ON THE OUT REACH BECAUSE AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WE CAN SET
UP THE HEARING INTO IT ALL AND
THEN. THE WE'RE LIMITED IN
TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO DO
OUTREACH WE'VE LIVESTREAMED.
THE WEBSITE IT'S LIVE STREAM
FACE TIME SO WHATEVER- SUPPORT
YOU CAN PROVIDE OUR OFFICE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROPER
GROUPS ARE IN THE ROOM WE WOULD
WELCOME AND QUICKLY TO POINT
OUT BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP LIKE THE ROLE OF
SCHOOLS AND IMPORTANCE ALSO OWN
ACTIONS THAT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN A BE SIX NINETY NINE WAS
NOT MENTIONED IN THE REPORT. I
THINK THAT WAS BOREDOM SURE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS NOW M.
FORESEEN LIKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE. YOU FAMILIAR AND WELL
COMING LEARNING ENVIRONMENT SO
SCHOOL ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SHOULD HAVE IMPLEMENTED
POLICIES OF JULY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SO. WE ARE AVAILABLE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE. STILL ON
THE- EXCELLENT I HOPE DISTRICT
NOW THAT YOU'RE BILL TO DO THAT
Q. NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU. A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHELSEA WILK
CONSTITUENT. NOT SURE OF
ANYTHING LIKE THIS EXIST
ALREADY. BUT I WONDERED IF-
CALIFORNIA OR POLICY COULD BE
DEVELOPED AROUND- CREATING-
TREATIES WITH DIFFERENT.
COUNTRY IS THAT A LOT OF
IMMIGRANTS ARE MIGRATING FROM.
TO CREATE SOME ECONOMIC
SYNERGIES BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING A LARGE
ECONOMIC POWER. AND SOME OF
THOSE COUNTRIES. SO THAT THE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS. ARE THEM
MORE PROSPEROUS EITHER HERE IN
THEIR- THEIR- COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN. THEREBY IMPACTING
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN I APPRECIATE
YOU AND THAT IS AT STAKE CAN
ENGAGE IN A TREATY BUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE-
ONE OF THE COUPLES OFFICES
BECAUSE WE'VE GOTTEN WITH
MEXICO IN THERE OTHERS THAT ARE
GROWING. BUT. SAY IT AGAIN. NO
NOT SISTER CITIES WE ACTUALLY
HAVE BEYOND THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
MORE CULTURAL BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE SEVERAL
OFFICES THAT DO JUST THAT WE
DON'T COLUMN TREATIES BECAUSE
WE'RE A STATE BUT WE DO AN
INTERVIEW CANADA MEXICO ELEMENT
THERE ARE YES LET'S SEE I THINK
IT'S WITH IN THE BIZ FED- GOBIZ
GOLD THIS THANK YOU GOBIZ UNIT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
HAVE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WHERE
WE- ARE EIGHT KNOWLEDGE JEAN.
COUNTRIES THAT WE HAVE TRADE
WITH- AND REALLY TRYING TO
EXPAND ON POLICIES TO HELP WITH
IMPORT AND EXPORT WITHIN
DIRECTLY THAN SAY A CALIFORNIA
OKAY AND THEN THE LAST THE LAST
PIECE I WANTED TO JUST THIS IS
MORE OF A COMMENT OR QUESTION I
WONDERED ALL THE IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS AT
THE BORDER WHERE THEY WERE JUST
TAKEN THERE WAS NO WAY TO
ATTACH THE CHILD TO THE PARENT.
WHERE ARE THOSE CHILDREN JUST A
QUESTION I WAS WONDERING YET
THOSE ARE DIFFICULT QUESTIONS
WE HAVE TO ASK ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS- BECAUSE
MANY OF THEM ARE STILL BEING
HELD IN AND AS WE ALL PAINFULLY
SEEN THOSE OF US WHO VISITED-
THE CAMPS AND WATCHED. ON THE
NEWS THERE WAS NO PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY FOR ANY KIND OF
REUNIFICATION AND SO THERE WAS
NO. SYSTEM PUT IN PLACE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PARENTS WHERE
THEIR CHILDREN WERE WERE PANTS
REMOVED I MEAN SO IT IT IS A
TRAVESTY. YOU KNOW BEFORE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE I RAN- I
WORK DIRECTLY IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION. AND WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS FOR
CHILD CARE FACILITY. THE
PEOPLE WHO TAKE CARE OF
CHILDREN IT. IT IS OFFENSIVE
BEYOND MEASURE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WAS DONE WE HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT
THE BACKGROUND OR
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF CHILDREN
WE HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT THE- THE
DECENCY OF THE CONDITIONS IN
WHICH THEY'RE LIVING. IT IS
OFFENSIVE BEYOND BELIEF. NEXT
WITNESS HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RANDALL ARE BEING A
GOOD COMMUNITY LEVEL QATAR
ACADEMY WE SERVE AROUND THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS ACROSS A
CAMPUS IN LOS ANGELES MOST OF
HOME MANY OF WHOM ARE IMPACTED
BY IMMIGRATION OF CELLS OR
THEIR FAMILIES- AS WITH THANK
YOU BOTH CENTERS FOR THIS
HEARING. AND ALSO FOR OTHER
GREAT WITH THAT YOU'VE DONE TO
EXPAND ON ACCESS TO I'M ON THE
SERVICES THAT ARE SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED AND ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING MICE WHEN I'M
ADVOCATING ASKED THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXPAND ESPECIALLY
SERVICES FOR MENTAL HEALTH. FOR
FAMILIES AND FOR CHILDREN- THE
IMPACT OF TRAUMA AND JUST LIKE
THAT DRAMATIC THESE TWO TEAMS
ARE GOING THROUGH- WE'RE JUST
SEEING IT IN CLASSROOMS
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ACADEMIC MATERIAL BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MUCH GOING ON WE
FIND THAT WE DO HAVE A STRONG
WITH THE WHOLE PROGRAM WE ALSO
HELP. ADVOCATE WITH OUR OWN
FAMILIES TO- TRAVEL TO
SACRAMENTO INTO THE CAPITAL TO-
DO SOME LEGISLATIVE THAT
LEGISLATE APATHY HOWEVER- JUST
EXPANDING THAT THAT ACCESS TO
SERVICES ARE STUDENTS OUT HERE
IN LOS ANGELES MEANTIME
REFERRING TO STUDENTS. SINCE
THE CLINICS ARE LOCAL I'M
OFTENTIMES A LONG WAIT LIST I'M
NOT JUST IN THAT YOU KNOW
STUDENTS ARE KIND OF. SUFFERING
CONTINUING TO HAVE CHALLENGES
DURING THAT WE LIST. NEXT
WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SHELDON MURRAY SOME A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE MINORITY
PSYCHOLOGY NETWORK WHICH IS A
NEW ORGANIZATION THAT'S TRYING
TO COMBAT THE STIGMA AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH A VERY CULTURALLY
COMPETENT WAIT AND WE CAN
CHANGE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
TRIED TO HELP OF BETTER BRIDGE
THE GAP BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH
IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES- MY I
HAVE THAT AS A OF A COMET AS
MORE THAN INVITATION TO OFFER
IMPIAN SERVICES TO THE SENATORS
AND ANYONE ELSE WHO BELIEVES
AND YOU KNOW REMOVING THE
STIGMA OF MENTAL HEALTH. AND
TRYING TO UPLIFT THEIR SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I ECHO WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE SAID THANK YOU
FOR COMING IN ENSURING THAT.
THE ORGANIZATION WE APPRECIATE
IT. NEXT WITNESS. YEAH I THINK
THINKING I WAS GONNA BRING THIS
DOWN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT MY NAME IS MARK
THEY WORK AT PH IF YOU WAKE
PROGRAM AND EVEN OUR PROGRAM IS
NOT- PART OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE. NAMED IN THE PUBLIC
CHARGE WE HAVE SEEN HOW DOES
AFFECT OUR FAMILIES AS WELL SO
I THINK THAT- HOSTING THIS IS
IN PART BECAUSE WE GET TO
NETWORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES.
AND HOPEFULLY THE MESSAGE GETS
OUT THAT WEEK IS NOT PART OF
THE PUBLIC CHARGE FOR- HOWEVER
WE ARE SEEING FAMILIES THAT ARE
BEING IMPACTED- THEY'RE
REFUSING TO COME TO THE
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID
THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE GONNA.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT THEM
SOMEHOW IN THE FUTURE SO I
THINK A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN
EITHER- WORKING WITH ATTORNEYS
WITH THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA TRYING
TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF SERVICES THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT ARE NOT
AFFECTED AND PARTICIPANTS NEED
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THEM. I
THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF WE
CAN SOMEHOW FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN GET LEGISLATION TO HELP.
I'M JUST GETTING THE MESSAGE
MAY BE MORE MORE FOCUS ON THE
POSITIVE OF WHAT. IS NOT
AFFECTED SO PARTICIPANTS CAN.
CONTINUE. Q. AND THE LADY IN
THE RED BLOUSE WILL BE OUR LAST
MEMBER THE PUBLIC TO TESTIFY
YES. NEXT WITNESS. HELLO THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU HAVE TODAY. I
AM A T. OCCURRING FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
TOLERANCE. IF WE HAVE A POLICY
IF WE HAVE A- STATE THAT RUNS
ITS POLICY DRIVEN THE
STATISTICALLY DRIVEN. A TRAGEDY
AND A TRAVESTY LIES HERE THAT
MAJORITY OF MINE THE
COMMUNITIES ON NOT EVEN TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT. THAT'S A TRAGEDY.
AND I SPEAK FOR MY COMMUNITY AS
A MUSLIM. AND I SEE THAT THE
ACTUAL UNDER ON NON
REPRESENTATION. AND IF YOU TALK
OF WELL BEING AND THAT'S MY
FAVORITE WORD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THAT IN BUT
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY TRAUMA
FROM FEMALE GENITAL MUTILATION.
I'M ONE OF THE CO FOUNDER OF
THE TASK FORCE HERE IN LOS
ANGELES I HAVE SEEN NOTHING
COMING FROM WAR CRIMES. THAT IS
THE MAJORITY OF THE KIDS THAT
ARE COMING FROM THE MIDDLE EAST
FROM AFRICA AND FROM SOUTH
AMERICA. AND NO ONE HAS EVER
MENTIONED THAT. AND THAT CAR
IS. A BIG PROBLEM A BIG ISSUE
RIGHT NOW BUT IT DOESN'T AFFECT
OUR COMMUNITIES SO WE DID HAVE
A DISPARITY YOU WANT US TO WORK
AS A STAKEHOLDER WOULD YOU. WE
NEED YOU TO STAND UP TO WHAT
YOU SAY AND WE NEED TO KNOW WHY
IS THE EXCESSIVE PROFILING NOT.
ONLY INDIVIDUALS I WILL
COMMUNITIES I WILL BE JUST OUR
RELIGIOUS LEADERS ARE RELIGIOUS
BASIS OF WASH. AND I NEED TO
KNOW THAT WE CAN. STEP UP AND
CREATE A BRIDGE OF
COMMUNICATION AS COMMUNICATION
IS SO IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT
DRIVES THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE ARE ACTIVE. MEMBERS
OF THE US. ECONOMY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CENTERS THANK YOU FOR A HOSTING
THIS HEARING IN LOS ANGELES- MY
NAME IS MIGUEL MARTINEZ I'M AT
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF A
STATE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
UCLA- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM AND- UCLA
ITSELF PRIDE THEMSELVES IN
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED. I COMMUNITY THE
STUDENTS- WE RANGE FROM I.
FINANCIAL AID ASSISTANCE
SIMILAR TO- WE'RE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING WHAT. OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM MY C. SECT
MENTIONED. AS WELL AS ACADEMIC
AND LEGAL SERVICES IN
PARTICULAR YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND HELPING TO. GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE THE FUNDING TO- HAVE US
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- YOU SEE AND
UCLA HAVE ALWAYS BEEN OUTSPOKEN
IN THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
SECTOR OF OUR COMMUNITY- AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY YOU JUST WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND I'VE MENTIONED
THAT. AS YOU KNOW YOU SEE I
HAVE IS THE ONE THAT CHALLENGE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IN
THEIR DECISION TO GO AHEAD AND
ABRUPTLY AND THE- DACA PROGRAM.
SO WE ARE HEADED- NOVEMBER
TWELFTH TO GO AHEAD AND
CHALLENGE THIS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DESPITE WHAT THE
OUTCOME WILL BE. TO BE AN
ACTIVE PARTNER WITH THAT THE
STATE OF THE LEGISLATURE TO GO
AHEAD AND STILL PROVIDE FOR
THIS- IMPORTANT SEGMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND ALL THOSE SEEKING
TO GO AHEAD AND PURSUE THEIR
ACADEMIC GOALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO SENATE IS THANK YOU
FOR HOSTING THIS MY NAME IS HOW
ONE MAN GETS TO I AM- AND
IMMIGRANTS AND I AM WORK AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR AFRICAN COALITION
FOR. WE ARE MEANT TO HEALTH.
AND I JUST WANTED TO. SAY AS
EVERYONE. TALKED ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH TO KEEP IN MIND FOR.
HAVE FUNDING FOR GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS AS SUCH AS
AFRICAN COALITION. BECAUSE WE
ARE. WORKING PROXIMITY WITH THE
COMMUNITY. AND SO WE COULD BE
BRIDGING. THE COMMUNITY. WITH
YOURSELVES THROW I. SO WE NEED
TO BE MORE OF US STANDING AND-
I'M SURE THERE ARE A LOT OF
ORGANIZATION THEY HAVE NOT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE BUT
WE ARE. BUT SO WE'RE GOING TO
BRING THE WORD OUT SO THEY'LL
BE MORE ORGANIZATION. GETTING
FINDINGS SO THEY CAN REPRESENT
THEIR COMMUNITIES AS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH M. AS
THE NONPROFIT- GROUPS WERE
TALKING ABOUT FUNDING. I. AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE DID IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME LAST YEAR AND A
FORMER NONPROFIT AGENCY LEADER
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE REALLY
IS. A COMMUNICATION GAP AND
SOMETIMES AN UNDERSTANDING GAP
FROM THE NONPROFIT SECTOR IN
TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING THE ROLE
OF A STATE BUDGET AND VICE
VERSA AND SO LAST YEAR WAS THE
FIRST YEAR WE DID IT WE'RE
GONNA DO IT AGAIN THIS YEAR. WE
HOLD A BUDGET TRAINING FOR THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR WE BROUGHT
DOWN THE DIRECTOR OF THE SENATE
BUDGET- COMMITTEE. TO TALK
ABOUT IT SO WE COULD SPEND HALF
A DAY TO BE EDUCATED ABOUT THE
STEPS THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
UNDERSTAND IF THERE IS AN
AVENUE FOR YOU TO BE FUNDED
THROUGH IT OR NOT. SO I HOPE
THOSE OF YOU WHO REPRESENT
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WILL
STAY CONNECTED TO MY OFFICE SO
ONE THAT DATA SAID IT'LL BE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE NEW
BUDGET IS RELEASED IN JANUARY.
YOU'LL BE MADE AWARE OF THAT
CLOSING COMMENTS DR PAN THANK
YOU FOR COMING THANK YOU AND I
JUST WANNA THANK ALL OF THE
SPEAKERS AND ALL THE ATTENDEES-
FOR BEING HERE AND GIVING US
YOUR- INPUT IN YOUR THOUGHTS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
YOU IS MOVE FORWARD I ALSO
SHOULD. QUICKLY NOTE THAT MANY
OF YOU MENTIONED THE CENSUS SO
I HAPPEN TO CHAIRED THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS THAT'S MIGHT
SELECT COMMITTEE THAT CHAIR SO
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID. AND
CERTAINLY PLEASE REACH OUT TO
MY OFFICE IF YOU HAVE OTHER.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WISH TO
SHARE WITH. BATES REGARDING THE
UPCOMING CENSUS WHICH IS REALLY
CRITICAL AS WELL IN TERMS OF
BEING SURE THAT- PEOPLE GET
COUNTED AND THAT WE GET THE
RESOURCES WE NEED BUT AGAIN AND
I WANNA THANK EVERYONE FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND I GET A ONE
THANK THE CHAIR- HOLLY MITCHELL
THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO JOIN YOU IN THIS-
VERY PORTS LIKE ANY HEARING.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
DOCTOR PAN I HOPE EVERYONE
HEARD SOMETHING TODAY LEARN
SOMETHING NEW MATT- I KNEW
COLLEAGUE IN THIS FIGHT FOR
EQUITY IN OUR STATE AND THAT
YOU HAVE IN MIND WHAT YOUR
ACTIVISTS ACTION WILL BE. TO
HONOR CONNIE AND ELIJAH
CUMMINGS AND TO HONOR THE
CHILDREN WHOSE LIVES WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO IMPACT IN A
POSITIVE AFFIRMATIVE WAY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
. THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
. IS
THAT IS THAT IS THAT
. THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE